[Music]
it's like a long time since we've been
in meeting
so welcome to
our budget meetings so our annual
planned meetings
we've got a lot of work to get through
in the next day or so i say also
gathered me
i've got apologies from councillor duty
she's going to try and get along which
she's able to uh so that's the first and
the other is
just a little be appropriate actually
i've noticed in the paper this morning
that denise hamilton of tuahe
has passed away a number of us would
know denise very well
very strong representation on a number
of issues including the footpaths
where the europa is so
um i've left a message for the family
this morning to let them know our
thoughts are with them and
arrange some flowers to go on behalf of
the council but if we could just stand
for a moment silence to recognize
denise's passing
thank you
is there uh any conflicts of sorry are
there any other apologies for recording
any conflicts of interest
so just
we're fine to
not wear masks as long as members of the
public aren't here or if the media
arrives so if they do
uh then we'll need to put our masks on
at that particular point in time so just
but of course that's up to any
individual if you wish to wear that
that's entirely up to you but just to
let you know
where that's at so now it now come to
the overview and financial strategy so
hand over to
both jeff and jim do you want to say
anything to start with jim
just a very brief introduction um the
staff have worked very hard to keep the
proposed or the draft annual plan 2223
with a an average rate increase of 4.3
inevitably as you go through the detail
there's some unders and overs in there
but that's what it averages out at which
was the i guess the high level
expectation and i think they've
delivered on that
the operating environment according to
standard and poor's for us is very
stable
so we're getting the same credit rating
we've had before which is a something
rather stable which is good we did push
for an upgrade but
you know fiscally the organization and
the council is in very good shape
when you are discussing the budgets i
would encourage you also to pay
attention to the the benefits of the
work and the service levels because we
tend to just focus on the money
but sometimes it's useful to think about
what are we actually leaving behind if
we spend that money for
your kids your kids kids and future
generations which we use the term
well-beings but in my language that's
what it actually means so but it's very
easy when we talk money just get tied up
with the numbers and forget what it is
we are buying
but i'm pretty pleased with the work
that's gone on the main challenge for
all of us in a delivery sense
is going to be omnicrom and what that
means and
it's kind of like the phony war
we know there's an enemy out there we
can't actually see it
but when it arrives it's either going to
be by stealth and we don't appear to be
following the norm from other countries
because of
our small population and the various
measures we've taken but
once it does get moving it will
you know a thousand becomes three
thousand then becomes six thousand it
moves very quickly so in our in our
response to that as an organization
where we're doing everything we can to
prepare for it but we don't actually
know how it's gonna work because we've
never been there before so
and the other issue which is a real
issue is just the
pressure on staff and the uncertainty of
the government's reform agenda
particularly three waters but it's
broader than them it's the whole of the
organization so
we're going to see more people under
pressure during the year so
having said all of that
as you've seen from the week we've been
doing with jared's team trying to get a
better handle on resources to delivery
and
you know making sure we're not asking
our people to do unreasonable things so
with that introduction like to hand over
to jeff
thank you
good morning
welcome to the all the twos so it's the
second of the second
of 2022. you don't that doesn't have to
happen or not
that's all right
raise that one
hopefully that doesn't jinx
um so this is the second year of our
long-term plan
um
you wouldn't expect a lot of change
and we haven't
so there's a timetable that we're
looking at
starting on the second and third
adopting a draft on the 22nd subject any
changes today
and then going out for a full
consultation period of the
one month
with the hearings on the fourth and
fifth of may
at each of the
three service centres
including oxford
and then deliberating on those hearings
on the 24th and 25th
and then the staff bringing back a final
plan for adoption on the 14th of june
with the reserve day being one week
later
so the key documents
leading into
the annual planner are much the same as
whoopsy daisy
much the same as a
ltp
uh the only difference is
is that we aren't audited for our annual
plan unless we have any items that are
significant that would cause an
amendment which we haven't
i understand there's quite a few
councils already that do
the other thing is that we don't have to
put in front of the community and
infrastructural strategy
for the 30 years which we do one for the
whole of life and there's no hot review
this year so it's a little bit more
simplistic in terms of audits
but all the other documents and
presentations are roughly the same
we
do a consultation document and it has to
be a standalone document it can't be
just mimic
the
annual plan itself it needs to actually
outline all the options uh that you are
looking for
submissions and feedback on
as jim said we are looking at a rate
movement of 4.3 it's 0.1 percent change
to what we forecast in the ltp so we're
pretty it's about five dollars
or four dollars sign to be exact
uh so we're pretty close to what we said
uh but there's a lot of
factors that
go in and out that make
that result
that number includes all of the reports
and commentaries that are having an
effect on the 2022-23
financial year so all the reports that
you've got there
are all inclusive of that
in that number
even though it's an average we'll come
in the last few slides and show you some
of the district movements
that are happening throughout
throughout the district
the assumptions and all the policies
that go into the
[Music]
annual plan remain unchanged there's no
significant change to anything there is
a change to the
rate submission
that's highlighted there in the green
and that takes into effect the local
government act that has to take effect
of the murray act that
needs to be considered in all policies
now as you touch a policy it needs to be
reviewed in accordance to that act
and with that being um
underlying amps and levels of service
provisions there's no reduction in those
you'll see some of the capital works
there there is an increase in quite a
few of our levels of service that we've
forecast previously
other adjustments so the uniform annual
general charge we're not recommending a
change to that remains at 335 dollars so
that's the key one that changes the
incidence of rates across the district
between rural and urban
predominantly
no change in the recreation level of
service for the neighbourhood amenities
that's an additional 85 dollars for the
urban area so we're saying no change to
that
the 30 cap that we're restricted to
under the rating act so we can't
breach that 30 percent in terms of fixed
charges on properties
that remains around about 26 percent uh
and it peaks in around about year eight
or nine around 28
of fixed charging
uh the roading there is a small change
and that's in relation to the
revenue and financing policy we have
moved that two dollars
the impacts are very very minor
and that's just to keep intact that 20
percent is charged by a fixed charge
and once again level of service they're
adopted
in the ltp no changes to those
effectively
the growth provision you've seen this
one before
we are keeping intact that we're going
to add
4800 properties
over the 10-year period
we've had a large increase in the in the
current year current calendar year we've
had over 900 properties and so that's
actually helped our position a little
bit but in other ways you have to allow
for additional expenditure for those
properties as well
uh and that that's a that's one of the
complex things that we're looking at
so still quite a significant
growth provision we're still thinking
that we sit on the medium to high
level with our growth over the 10 years
in the later years we've adjusted to
keep intact the calculation for our dc
movements
as you'd expect you shouldn't have a lot
of
things that are in the
annual plan for feedback uh and there's
only three
that we're saying that we're looking for
specific feedback on and that's the
level of service for our road network in
relation to the reduced funding
uh the kuiper stormwater and flooding
improvements so we're adding uh 4.3 to
that program million to the program and
the funding to complete the kaikoura
community had just an additional 600 000
for that
so the other ones that are the uh
the key
issues that we're seeking feedback in
the consultation document
there's some other issues uh that we're
not saying a key but other issues that
more
levels of service which we have to do
anyway so why would you consult on them
and that's upgrades to the ring your
airfield the actually water supply
that supplies the campgrounds and the
reserves
protection of uh natural scientific
actual areas so there's a minor increase
there of 50 000 per year
there's some other important updates
which we include in the annual plan and
that's just updating the community on on
the issues that are facing us locally
and nationally and that's
i won't go through all of those but
the key ones are the three reforms
around local government to ensure that
the
community is updated on the last recent
events
and some changes to our development
contributions policies and fees and
charges
so
when we forecasted our rating
projections
uh including the growth
um additional costs and so forth we're
very much on track to what we said in
the ltp which we should be
uh point one percent is pretty a pretty
good effort i think uh from the staff to
try and
keep that intact
very little movement
and just to try and rationalize that out
you've seen the local government index
over the next 10 years
move between 2.5 and 2.9 that's gone up
slightly
if you remember it was ranging between
2.3 and 2.8
uh sorry 2.9
uh progressive earthquake funding we've
we've got around about one percent on
that at the moment and there's a few
reasons for that we'll get into later on
mainly um interest rate movements
uh levels of service uh so we're saying
into the you can see the first
four or five years there we've got a
level of service which we use the
smoothing for to just um you know a lot
of the services we put in a long term
ones
so we've we have that
policy of spreading those long-term
assets and costs across the uh as far as
we
it's prudently to do
so other the other people that come into
the district through growth actually uh
pay for those services as well so the
baseline that we're looking at should be
somewhere between three and a half and
four point seven percent
and that's exactly what we've ended up
with in the um
in the bar graphs there
i don't have much confidence sorry i
pushed a little button yeah
don't have much confidence in the
how did that happen
don't have a lot of confidence in the um
the outer ear just in here
because this
you know we haven't really revised these
we've concentrated mainly in these first
few years to ensure we have that right
so why i don't have dutch constituents
confidence is we already haven't done
the budgets for it so it's an
extrapolation of what we think it's
going to be
so those numbers i should say exclude
opt-in to the curbside collection
and you'll see through the budgets that
jared's team
i mean kitty has done and has
put quite a bit of growth in those the
expected growth based on the current
year
and
the other one is the actually
water supply we tend to
we don't control the cost there but we
tend to negate that out as well
that's an important
uh graph that i try to make a color to
make it exciting because it's boring
stuff
um
the first time that i can recollect our
cpi is higher so the cpi is the orange
line
the blue line is local government cost
index they are the costs that affect
local government
now i've challenged these numbers three
times from burl
and got the same reply three times and
they started getting sick of me asking
but i couldn't rationalize that to start
off with but i'm starting to understand
it a bit more now
economists
are a little bit different to
accountants
but
first time ever you don't see that
correction come in until 27 28
and that's important because there's
that love affair between interest rates
and cpi
if you
look at the yellow line here that's what
our rates would be if we didn't have the
progressive earthquake funding and or
one percent around about one percent
earthquake funding that's our true rate
line in the grey
so why so that's important is there's a
substantial
risk that sits between the two factors
that appear have given us
when i did this
inflation was sitting at five percent or
4.9 the recent one that just came out
last week was four five point nine just
under six percent
and the reason the primary reason that
for that is the the cost of housing how
housing is affecting the um the average
consumer
uh there's a restriction on supplies at
the moment and pricing's just gone
haywire
um you know you hear stories that to
build a house now is 30
dearer than the previous 12 months
you know
why it stays up there is um interest
rates that you're paying on mortgages
you know your petrol has gone up um
they're not sure about the restriction
on supply not sure about how cover is
going to affect
but that produces another problem for us
because i haven't put the labor index
there but the labor index for staff for
local governments it's around about 1.8
to 2
at the current
you know the current two years so 2 this
year 1.8
next year we're going to get a lot of
pressure
uh and you're already hearing economists
like sharon zollmer from the anz saying
the real take-home pay for people
uh consumable amount is
reducing and it will do for three or
four years
so a lot of pressure is going to come
on us for that private enterprises
sitting somewhere around 2.2 2.5 they
they
are generally a bit higher than us
so a fair bit of risk sits in our
numbers
in this year but
rather than
try and be smart and
inflate them we'll see what happens see
what bill
bill's numbers are
i have confidence in them
we've used them for for nine years nine
years now
so let's see what happens
most of the effect will be around capex
works
next slide
interest rates so i explained what's
happening with them
most quite a bit of our movement this
year that's causing the cost that's
offsetting growth is interest rates
we modeled model that with our treasury
advice
and i'll have a slide next that shows
what we're facing
we've enjoyed
sitting on floating in a mixture of
floating and fixed term debt uh for some
time
with a city with the ocr sitting around
75 points
i'm pretty sure that's going to go to
1.5
in the next well
i'm not sure but they all know everyone
is saying it's 25 to 50 points on the
23rd of february
so we'll see what happens there uh the
previous forecasts that we're working
with we're saying uh an ocr that's the
official cash rate would go to two
percent
uh by april 23
so that's only just over a year away now
uh forecasts are now saying three
percent so
that's going to affect mortgage rates
um
and we're looking at a little bit of a
period of uh
increasing interest rates to try and
combat the
high inflow inflation that's in the
market at the moment and the reserve
bank want to
keep that between one and three percent
so
six percent is way outside of what they
uh wanted it to be
so a small movement for us around 45
points
we were predicting 3.3 sitting on 3.5
predicting 3.3 in the ltp
we have to move that up a little bit
because our floating rate is going to
move
and also some of our
debt that matures under our policy
to mitigate the interest rate risk is
maturing as well
so
just to show that
the top of the blue line there is we're
sitting at the moment at 75 points over
the next
year or so
that's what's expected
from
this is sourcing and said information
for it to go to three percent so each
one of those different colors shows a
movement in the sea the ocr
and so we're looking at a two and a
quarter percent movement in that oca
nothing like that was predicted uh
18 months ago or even when we adopted
the ltp
so looking expenditure 119 million
predicting in 2023
and now the areas we were seeing the
movements and expenditure
and lots of reasons for that
predominantly interest rates again
but a lot of that was forecast in the
ltp
i won't dwell on that but you can see
our two big movers
recreation and roading
and the three waters
you can see there around about
you know these three here around about
a quarter 29 of that
operating revenue uh additional 6.5
million excluding gst in rates fees and
charges we've
gone with the 2.9 movement that we
forecast in the ltp so they've been
moved right across the accounts
subsidies are greater 5 million but not
as not not as much as what we expected
them to go
um and the another revenue um which
comes in there
that uh table there doesn't really
represent
the true movements i'm sorry the the top
table i pulled that one out which is the
old fist statement which
i pulled one right wrong one but
it negates subsidies
so there's in a few our fees and charges
if you remember rodney hyde brought in a
new policy that said
any non-type of cash movements or
capital movements needed to be excluded
from an operating statement
so that's that one but the other true
movements there uh expenditure 19.2
million that doesn't represent a rate
increase um you know as you can see it's
6.5 million
a lot of growth in that figure
in terms of additional rates for
bringing in
and
you know just to explain some of it
which
the other managers will explain when
they get to their commentaries is that
they're dealing with
some of the unprecedented demand you
know probably growth have been somewhere
around the third highest um in history
the one the last 30 years anyway
and to to do to to deal with that i've
got additional resources they need to
to have to get to
provide that level of service
um capital expenditures so we're
actually moving down from 81 million to
60 million it would have been a lot less
than as well but we've got another 22
million of that shovel ready and
stimulus sort of feeding into that a bit
um
and so
you can see there that
apart from this year
we start a downward slope in our capex
program unlike a lot of councils we've
actually attended to a lot of our issues
we've got sewer outfalls and
we've got our earthquake strengthening
and that's why you see a lot of councils
with quite high rates at the moment
because they're still trying to get on
top of those sort of issues
um out here the reason that goes up is
we've got the kaiapoi library the
service centres
uh
the
parking building and some um significant
strategic roading sitting out in this
area here
and just that the funding for that just
mimics the requirements that we um
that we need to get to fund it you know
it's a mixture of subsidies loan funding
and reserves
we're building up some good reserves at
the moment under our policy i've got a
table later on that shows that
uh capex
by category i thought i'd just throw
that one in just to show that
you know we've got a good mixture there
the blue is the replacement
of assets the readers the levels of
service
and green is the growth
i've got to state that it's
predominantly
when we
categorize it as predominantly uh one or
the other
but when we do things like dc's and that
you have to consider the cost benefit
and therefore
the dc's policy is more specific and
that table there
did
probably seen this and it looks very
much like the ltp and it is
so
the readers
yeah
new new debt the green is repayment of
debt and that line there is the total
debt
and the indices for that line here sits
on the right so that's our total debt so
we're just raising a little bit there
because the red's rising and then as we
get here it drops because the green is
kicking in
and then up here we've got those uh four
or five major expenditures out here i
think the key thing um you know
as their rates are dropping even this
debt's increasing now our rates are
dropping uh because of uh
efficiencies and growth and so forth
and when you look at one of the key
indices for our credit rating
you can see here it's
dropping
even though it's increasing i would
suggest that we'll be put on positive
around about here in year two or two two
years out
when i say positive put on positive to
go to double a plus
so the sovereign at the moment was
upgraded last year to double a plus
and that's where i think we should be in
two years time so we're we're in a
really good position at the moment
subject to the alpine going
and even for that uh
even for that we've got uh contingency
plans and headroom to um to try and
combat that as well
and that just shows that um same sort of
picture that's our borrowing is a
percentage of revenue it's dropping
array here the blue is if we have
insurance the oranges we don't have
insurance to have to fund all the
capital works ourselves
um and that was done on our
we've updated this information on
of what we had previously and you can
see it's dropping away quite
significantly so it's a lot of headroom
out here
and once again if something did
adversely happen we would actually
do what we did in 2010-11 and adjust our
capex program
you'd see all this red stuff disappear a
bit and we would put in a different
program to replace it
interest
so we've just moved that interest up a
fraction
but we're still only half less than half
of what we can actually afford based on
our treasury policy and local government
way under the local government funding
agency requirements
once again good position
that's just a quick one i won't spend
time on that but that just shows that
we're building up reserves for future
replacements
not a lot of councils do this but um we
get a lot of accolade from it and it
shows that we are managing our future
replacements
according to the growth that we're
getting we're not actually
sucking up those dollars from growth and
um
and putting them into
current generations we're looking after
our future generation as well
rate cost drivers
this is just trying to put in general
and it's very general
i've done some really rough numbers
around what what how do you how does the
8.8
total movement work and after growth
getting down to the 4.3 work
so
the interest rate movement has is
costing us 1.9 of that 8.8 movement and
that's the dollar equivalent the 2.9
is on local government goods so anything
outside of basically labor and interest
additional staff levels um so it's 1.3
to meet the service level agreements and
the um
that were shown in the managers
various areas and the managers will
explain those
salary movements uh so that's that two
percent that we've got provision for for
next year that's under pressure
um
and we'll
to to a degree have to respond to what
the market does
to a degree
and then we've got other movements and
there are ups and downs all over the
place and there's a bit of smoothing
there's evil service growth there's
growth is the we've increased the covert
loan
um up to
about two million dollars now
and we've got depreciation movements and
you see the biggest one there is in
roading where we've been able to reduce
depreciation to offset some of that
capex program
due to the lower
wakakatahi funding that we're receiving
so that's uh
equals that 8.8 total greats movement
uh the growth component that we've exp
that we've got in the budget there uh
for the growth that we're getting in the
current year and the expected growth
towards the end of the year when we set
the rate on the first of july we're
saying is around about 3.7 percent it
drops it down to the 5.1 after growth
and then um this bin movement we can't
control
that's just people that are opting into
bins
and so
if you look at your the true rate
increase that's um going up the district
4.3 but once again there's a lot of
different different movements across
different areas and i'll show what those
are in a minute
so where the dollar increase has been
might i won't
delve into this you'll be looking at the
commentaries uh soon and um but you'll
see the there's it's a pretty
i'd say it's pretty general movement
right across there's some larger ones
there um but generally um there's a few
different type projects that are
included in there but mainly it's the
interest rates effect
the rest of it sort of sits on
what we were forecasting in the ltp
so the green shaded
areas there
and this is based on
dollar increase movement not percentage
movement
is the what are the rates that affect
most people across the district
the other ones in the green so a lot
more green at the top
than the blue
shaded areas which are more targeted
rates so they're
to give an example that the water rate
in
rengar will be different the one in kai
poi and so forth
and
if you look at that in a
table
[Music]
past years it's been a little bit the
opposite target rates have been slightly
larger than district rate rates um
but
uh and that's why a lot of the movements
across the district
is around about that 4.3 for
the district-wide rate any movements
above that rate is due to targeted
district wide rate movements they
everything that's
wide are the key movers there so you can
see the earthquake um
once again quite a significant portion
of that
and then general rates
um
uh the
the ones that we don't actually target
but a general
and to show that
that's the portion of breakdown of the
district-wide movement
and the individual movements that you
can see for
the individual
i've taken the key ones here there's
about another
10 or
10 or so that are around five four or
five percent um so under the
rate movement that i haven't shown
but you can see there
once again
the covert loan
interest rate
movement
is affecting quite a few of those
once again the commentaries will just
explain some of those movements
but you can see the the biggest one here
is that that covert line we've
had to
absorb some of the increases from the
closures of some of our libraries
service centres
and absorbs from that cost
and we're funding it over the 10-year
period
rates by area so just two more slides to
go
that's the rates from 1.2 percent to 4.5
you can see the ones at the top there
are giving quite a
there's not a lot of movement for some
of our western
properties
and that's
generally because they're they're larger
or they've attended to a lot of um
increases in the past
uh and it's it's good to see ranger
oxford urban there at 3.5 it's uh
they've they've had some significant
movements over the years
um
but
yeah so the other ones that are uh under
that
four point well around about the four
point three percent
another one that's the one most probably
interested in what's the outliers and
you can sort of rationalize why that's
happening if you look at the individual
rate samples which will give you the
more detail later on
all those properties there have a
general a district-wide rate movement of
4.3
but what increases them above that is
the targeted services such as the three
waters and
you know water to a drainage
and so that's what moves some of those
these ones here for the central business
area there's a little bit of effect
there
they have
the commercial error rate and
also sometimes when you get into those
larger valued properties there's some
movements
in relation to improvements on
properties and it just changes that
average around a little bit
but most should be expecting around the
4.3
once again
some of the movements that
the public the community will bring you
is if they've done any improvements on
their property and it's been kept
registered and captured that will move
their rates
there is no rate revaluation this year
sorry
property revaluation this year
that occurs at the end of this year and
takes the in effect in the last year of
rtp so any
movements that are incidental which
shifts because their
their property increases have moved
won't take effect until that year not
this year
you will see where people have had a
section and they've built on it
that will affect their rates because
they get the improved value that they're
rated on
and they're charged for
various services as well
so that's that's um
the end of that
hopefully
[Music]
it's made you a little bit more wiser
um
have you take questions thank thanks
jeff um just firstly those slides are
really good um
is it possible we could get it
okay that's good so we're going to get a
copy of those
david hills text me he's online and
listening
i know that he would probably appreciate
a copy of those as well certainly
through um hello david from all of us um
so any questions so counselor williams
yeah without growth the way i worked it
out it would have been 8.8 increase
instead of 4.3
it was one one your slide said
without the growth without the nine
thousand houses
not quite 900
900 sorry 916. so
what happens if we get
in future years a big deterioration like
the houses are going 30 percent we're
running out of land and and what have
you and all of a sudden that growth
could come to a big hulk how would that
affect our
projections
yeah it's probably a little bit less
than 8 because we've got the waist
growth in there for bins and so forth so
that's that's another fact you've got to
allow for
uh
as you progress if you go out a lot of
our capex programs would reduce but uh
the key thing there is that we're
keeping in mind of the 4 800 properties
per year so we're not actually
extending past that growth we're not
actually adding anything more in that
than what new zealand stats think it is
because we do sit on the medium to high
and we've sat on that for quite some
time now
you'd find a lot of capex programs later
on with the tap would be turned down on
those uh
there'd be a lot of factors that would
have to
come into play
uh but generally uh we're living within
some limits anyway
like what happened at the earthquakes
the opposite happened there we um
we turned off capital works programs but
we had to open up other areas
uh and after earthquakes we had an
increase of 11
so
it's it's difficult to
to determine uh but we're we're living
in a sort of a
a period of uncertainty and the one
we've got uncertainty at the moment is
isn't probably around growth it's more
around
inflation and those impacts that we're
going to have on us
so what would happen if the inflation
and the growth sort of
the inflation carried on
and the growth because of
is let's see just what happens yep just
what happens with people's mortgages at
the moment they've got to either cut
their cloth
um
or they have to um put more of the
they've got additional
expenditure to try and meet in the short
term and we'll have strategies in place
to do that
and we've
we're doing that to effect by using debt
to
try and cushion out the blow
and you can see from a lot of the
projections we've got there we've got
quite a bit of headroom to um try and
take some of that cushion
just before the other day
can someone please adjust the
temperature in here it's it's cold
um
thank you jim the the other thing we
would do councillor williams is look
through
all of the council expenditure which we
do anyway but particularly for
areas like jarrod and tracy where they
may have some consultancy resource
that's linked to because we don't staff
up for a peak
but we do need to take on consultancy or
contract resource to help us get over
those peaks so if growth turned down
then we would make a judgment as to
whether we can reduce some of our
staffing costs potentially delay an
employee replacement if they leave to
just to try and match that up to the
workflow
okay
thanks jeff when you apply growth across
the district
do you also then apply it area by area
which then affects what they pay in
water and sewer for to targeted rates
yeah that's correct yeah
so
every targeted rate which is a is an
area right where we actually look at the
population that's happening in there so
you might see
someone like gary meerwater
go out by one or two properties but
someone like woody where they've got
large growth with
ravenswood that'll move significantly
when i ask you the question though you
said you took it on this year's one july
figure plus an allowance for growth what
if an area is growing way more than that
for example with subdivisions that are
known to be coming live this year oh
definitely water into area with
ravenswood and pegasus yeah because i'm
saying we've got a little bit of
rangiora with the subdivision to the
west because some of these schemes seem
to be having quite a lot of
razors and water particularly or in
those sort of areas and yet they're
experiencing huge growth so that that
has definitely been affected into the
water yes that's that's correct and
you've seen a little bit of if they've
got um they've had capital works in the
past and they've got significant debt um
they're seeing a little bit of an effect
on the interest
that's built into that rate as well
just on the interest you you did mention
to us over the last two ltps interest
rates were likely to rise
why wasn't that factored in at the ltp
yeah it was
it was factored in uh there was a slide
there where i showed it was going they
thought it was forecast at two percent
it's now going into three percent
right
so you're saying it's probably the
impact of the shovel ready projects that
have actually pushed that up further
with the increase in debt no so we our
debts done as a as a whole cross
treasury and so we model that
and
allocate the debt based on uh need and
then that's averaged across all the
supplies so you have something like a
big project like the
stadium for instance
we take their debt on it's it's an
average debt across the other so you'll
see the others move up and down so they
take benefit of low interest rates as
well
so in the documentation that's going out
for public information will you be
putting a really good summary about
interest rates and why it isn't the same
as what was in the ltp yes thank you
thank you any further questions
well jeff can i just say
it's really excellent work thank you
that set
i guess the summary and the overview for
this next day or so um
in in general uh how we run our finances
and the level of growth that we have in
this district we are the envy of other
councils i've had calls from
neighbouring mayors very envious of how
we
run our system so thank you to you and
all the managers that have put together
our budget papers in fact can i just say
in general i think our budget papers are
excellent this year
there's no range of questions which
we've had from colleagues which really
appreciate that they've been summarised
so
thank you for the way in which the
process has been put together
thanks jeff so i intend we were
scheduled to have a break at
10 o'clock but i think we're running
good time at the moment so i think we
might go straight into roading
uh first i did ask sarah to make sure
that
managers were on notice so if i can i'd
like to get us done today now i've said
that probably jinxed it but there's no
reason why we can't so
if staff staff are on standby to come
over here and be ready to to keep moving
through
so firstly
if if the writing team want to come
joanne wants to come forward
if i
can just move a pro forma
that the recommendations and the budget
papers be adopted
we have a seconder for that secretary
councillor atkinson so it's just a pro
forma
uh we can as we've done in other years
if there's changes we just move those by
simple amendments
got a whiteboard right not next to you
so i'll put i'll put the recommend i'll
put that all those in favor please say
aye
contrary declare that carried so
um
joanne we're dealing with your pages
there's no reports relating to your
section is that correct
that i've picked up in here
so we just come to your budget summaries
thank you
it's pages one in the um
in your folders
there is one report but we can take it
under drainage um there's smart road
which crosses over between routing
drainage that better why don't we deal
with that what uh
it's probably simpler that we deal with
should we do with smarts road first uh
that report how do you want to handle
that jared you're happy to do that what
do you want to come forward so that's
4.3 item five
a tab five smarts road flooding issues
may 2021 so don are you going to lead
that
yes yes mr happy to lead there um sorry
jared if you wouldn't mind just pulling
up the report
this is a result of a
representation made to
uh the council by a number of residents
post the may flooding
um the mayor led a wee delegation out
there uh of staff
and we met with residents and discussed
their issues
since that time
we have
been working on potential solutions
the solutions are not easy
the
roading
infrastructure
is
relatively undersized
as i must say as much of the roading
infrastructure around in terms of side
drains and whatever we don't have a
standard
where we're trying to meet in every
kilometer of road we have
but in this particular instance it's
also quite difficult to upgrade that
infrastructure due to the lay of the
land
we did look at improving the
infrastructures you'll see in the report
by potentially running
cut off drains or swales across private
property
that leads to some real complications in
terms of ongoing maintenance and
ownership and
rating areas etc so what we are
recommending
is
i think
what we believe is to be a good
compromise where it is an improvement in
the existing infrastructure
but it isn't trying to aim for a
specific
level of service as such
but it certainly will improve i think in
the report
you will note that there are a number of
contributing factors to the issues there
and i don't think it would be fair to
lay them all on the council's
table
in terms of
the results that we have uh ended up
seeing out there
we're also mindful of the fact that
there were an awful lot of areas uh
which came under stress from both that
flood and and other floods
yes these residents have got together
and pointed those issues out and
that's you know all good on
them for doing that
but i i we we as staff are also a little
nervous of
um you know the expectation here versus
uh a number of other residents who may
not have been so organized or vocal
about their concerns
in summary we don't believe we do
believe there is a pathway forward here
that the council should contribute to
at this stage we have recommended that
this be considered unsubsidized
joanne might like to speak to that a
little further but it's certainly
you will have gathered the impression
that funding from nzta is difficult to
get
and difficult to justify and we believe
this is the appropriate assumption to be
made at this stage noting
that the staff will be
continuing to pursue that as an avenue
um that's about all i need to say and
happy to take questions unless joanne or
jared has anything to add
thanks don so the uh
i support what you're recommending here
by the way following the meeting with
residents but going back to
them and explaining that is that part of
your plan to make sure they clearly
understand what we are doing versus
what their expectation might have been
yes definitely we have only really been
engaging with them by email since then
we've seen a couple of updates to let
them know we're continuing to work on it
but we certainly once the council has
given us direction following this
meeting we would organize a meeting out
on site and and discuss it um that
probably would be useful having both
staff and political representation um
and i think uh i i
yes we we would then see the results of
that in terms of their expectations i
think it would be
varying amongst the personnel out there
uh once you know there are
differing strengths of opinion i guess
amongst the residents and we would see
where that fell
thanks i'd be happy to pop along to that
uh perhaps the writing portfolio holder
might also
we'll come to that uh count so that
continue the question yeah very quickly
mr manchester just around president
sitting
not just here and the the views you will
you will have had how does this citizen
we're far enough away from
or can we defend the position of
president sitting for any other
disasters in in similar type
um things that may happen are we sort of
opening ourselves up to contributing for
the rest of our lives when events come
about by doing this
i think the staff would suggest that if
you went ahead with the recommendation
here there isn't a precedent this is
just responding to issues which we do
all over the district in some form or
another where we are identified that
there is concerns
you know the staff
get on board to look at what they can do
and they look at responding i think some
of the other options which are included
in this report would certainly be moving
beyond our normal
uh level of intervention and we as staff
would be concerned about the potential
precedent for that as you would have
seen one of the options here was to
almost to establish a small rating area
and set up separate uh you know
ability to maintain things on into the
future i think that would be taking a
step into something which is really um
we would be difficult to defend
any further questions
i i'm happy to move the recommendations
someone repeated second
seconded
council atkinson just speaking to it
having
there has actually been a number of
incidents over a number of years but the
last flooding
um that occurred out there actual fact
this wasn't on our radar until the
residents raided it raised it with us
and it was they'd actually
um coped with quite significant issues
on their particular properties this year
i agree with don as there's a step it's
not going to meet all their expectations
but if
in meeting the residents they're not
happy with that they have the
opportunity in which to
submit to our annual plan uh with
further views but i think this is a
reasonable step i think don and team
have done a really good job uh coming
back to us with what i think will
will address a significant number of the
concerns
council consent do you wish to speak do
you wish to speak counsel stewart
i could comment i note what um
don has just said about
writing areas and setting precedence and
you know this issue generally
comes up
um
in the in the rural land drainage um
area all the time and it was addressed
in that district-wide
services and general
and
flat rating for services across
the district is that
now with three waters or whatever
all on hold
all on hold because
we did do quite a lot of work about um
which would have
um
taken are you talking to the motion are
you asking a question well i'm asking a
question about where does because you've
raised the general issue of a
district-wide drainage rate effectively
saying that
here is another issue another instance
of
an area we don't collect drainage rates
for and we've got pock marked across
this district and because i'm
your rural drainage person i think we've
got where does that where does that
whole issue
sit because it's overdue for coming back
so that's the question you're asking so
jared could you um yeah so um we do have
that district-wide
uh flood rate that we have had for quite
a number of years
and so
that gives us a an amount of money to be
able to get in and intervene in some
areas
it's
not enough to manage an issue like this
and this actually we're actually in this
situation we're looking at upgrading
some roading infrastructure so it's
mostly culverts and road drainage
so
the
that district-wide flood rate
is quite useful and we do
you know we allocate that to projects on
an ongoing basis um and so i suppose
this is just one of these ones that is
we had a big storm event and we had
quite a number of demands on that and
this is something that's over and above
what yeah so so council gave a direction
has decided on this it's not to be dealt
with this term but it has given a
direction perhaps when we go out on
property you might want to join us as
the portfolio holder at that meeting
sandra but
today is not we've already decided on
that so we don't need to
to
yeah
that's going to be
it's going to be addressed uh next term
as that's when we've yeah we have got we
have got a program that's been approved
by the council um in terms of
the uh district work that would be
looked at for potential district right
three waters rating
and the council has made the decision to
defer that given a number of factors
including the um three waters review by
the government okay any further speakers
to the
recommendation
uh sorry you wish to speak councillor
counselor don
thank you mr mayor i i i admitted to
mention and it's not clear in the report
if this was uh approved it would come it
would be added into the roading budget
as opposed to the drainage budget but it
would be unsubsidized roading
okay thank you all right no further
speakers i i don't really i'm not going
to respond to myself so um
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye contrary to clear
that carried thanks don
so um
joanne if we come to your pages and
we'll try and get through this before we
go to morning tea
so um
that's all right with you
thank you i will try and keep it fresh
no
take your time
so
i guess in summary one of the
one of the main things that affects our
roading activity commentary this time is
the funding levels endorsed by nz by
kotahi as part of the national land
transport program so this has been well
covered
through
the november
council meeting
following briefings and then also the
reports came back to
council in december
and were endorsed subject to
consultation through the annual plan
process
so these two were in relation to
maintenance operations and renewals
funding which had a shortfall of
637 thousand dollars over the following
sorry in the
23-24 year
and the low-cost low-risk
capital projects
which are also planned and we have
agreed a i guess a process forward
in terms of delivery of those
and i think probably just the one key
thing for me to note is that with some
of the projects that we have on hold or
are proposing to take through to
detailed design ready for tinder should
funding become available
there is a risk that these may need to
be deferred beyond
22-23 if that funding does not come to
pass
so that's just one thing for me to flag
within my commentary i have also
outlined some other projects for
consideration
main street oxford was one of those and
that was following the request for
a 40 kilometer an hour speed limit along
main street
um i would just note that the cost
estimate for that does assume that what
we would be doing is
putting in the cycle lanes to create the
traffic calming which was um sorry which
has been consulted on as part of the
walking and cycling strategy so the two
are somewhat interlinked
which is why the estimate is sitting at
450 000
we have also had requests for a new
kerbin channel from the rangiora ashley
community board
the first being on ashley street which
is rangira town center entrance from the
north
in the other on cold stream road from
ashley street to the railway line and
this request
was because there was a desire to tidy
up that area
um we would not estimate there would be
any ncta funding with those projects
and this staff's suggestion is that
those be considered as part of the next
long-term plan
process so that those projects can be
prioritised against the other needs
within the district
also included is the rangiora airfield
prize road development
and that is proposed to upgrade prize
road
um to end seal the road in conjunction
with the development which is proposed
to occur
the total cost of that is 1.2 million
dollars but there will be revenue assume
revenue from the developer private
developer
of 731 000 which would mean the cost to
council would be 481 000.
i think those are really the key issues
so oh yeah
there's one um
just one more that's not included in the
commentary and just bearing in mind
most of
our budgets and commentary were prepared
pre-christmas so um
we've uh
just been having a look in in the um
the capital works and the allocation for
next
for the coming financial year
the rangiora car parking
funding allocation we've actually got
currently got a 1.1 million dollar
carryover signaled plus 3 million
dollars for the 22 23 financial year now
with um our capital works um we've
certainly got a a
very well established now practice that
unless we've got a very clear line of
sight on a particular project that we
know we're on program to deliver or if
it is for land purchase to have some
certainty that that's going to happen in
a particular financial year
we normally actually would push that out
until the following financial year so
we're not actually suggesting that you
consider removing that but
it might be prudent for you to consider
moving that money into the
23-24 year and leaving some provision
for investigations um
design negotiations um and that would
then give you the ability to bring that
back into the 20 to 23 year at any time
if an opportunity does arise because we
know there may be opportunities that do
come up um just a bit concerned if we
put effectively 4.1 million dollars into
a capital program there's a good chance
we'll be um
carrying that forward and it shows that
we're not delivering as a
so to deal with that would would the
staff
report be the better way so we've got a
combined view of that rather than just
addressing that piecemeal now uh
yes because i think i'd like to see that
and some
thinking go behind what that amount
should be
because it picks up a workshop that we
discussed looking at alternatives other
strategies
all those things so perhaps before we do
that
because we've got um this will get
reported back to us that could come back
um as part of the recommendations
when the annual plans considered
couldn't it
by the full council certainly yes when
we reported it
i just thought it was important that we
have to see let's flag that today and if
that could come as part of that that
would be helpful
the other um
oxford you mentioned um
that's already come out of there
following the council's decision around
that joanne is there just a question
around oxford has
have we done other investigations with
that with that community with respect to
those who are short-sighted because
that's the main one of the main issues
through there is people getting across
the road
particularly from our pensioner housing
have we done any work out there or could
we do any work this coming year with
those residents to see what
options there might be to him to improve
that area for them and make it feel
safer for them
yes we certainly can
go back and engage further on that we do
have some funding in
this financial year in our minor safety
program for upgrading those crossings to
the new markings
which i'm not sure whether you've seen
them but actually the one out here on
high street i think it is they have been
marked with the there's a new
requirement for wider bars which
actually does make them stand out quite
a bit
we're also
looking at whether the crossing outside
the town hall could be relocated
slightly so it's not immediately at the
intersection which i think would improve
safety for that one
so we
ali has been again been doing some great
work for us and we'll be taking uh paper
to the oxford ohio community board as
well on that one when's it likely to go
the board i'll confirm the date and let
you know once and um
counts the meetings and um
council dude you know as well that would
be appreciated
counselor concern
yeah thanks mr mayor just around the um
coal stream road ashley street around
the the um
the priority there or like how we get it
into a priority list
um there's a couple of things that i'd
really like to know about that and is
one if council was a mind of a mind to
to move that forward as such
um
could it be done
because
would we have the ability to get it done
and number two what would be the effect
on the rates if indeed that project was
included now that's sort of if you like
moving aside the priority
look at it
um
and for me mr mayor just
looking at things like car shows and in
the way that the amp show grounds not
right at the present time or we've got
covered but is moving it's um
moving everything up and trying to get
events there to me
certainly what i saw at the car show
last
couple of weeks was pretty unacceptable
for pedestrians and people around that
area so i was just interested in what
movement it would have on the rates
could it possibly do you know could we
actually do it and then of course the
besides that is that uh question around
priorities and where that
sits do we
that's is that also something you would
like brought back as a stuff
i think that would be worthy of
consideration it was that a view here
they could come back to us before that
goes out um
yeah
that's when are we scheduled for that
that's
later this month isn't it
or is it march meeting that we
we signed that off to go out to public
22nd of february sorry i should have
raised it that's okay
it's a whiteboard issue um really um and
perhaps the account the car parking
measure as well we just put it there so
we don't um lose it who's who's handling
the whiteboard
is that you mr mr chief executive
oh they've they've got note of that okay
yeah we'll find the mechanism of getting
that but 22nd is probably the logical
time for that to come back all right
further questions
counselor
yes
um about the 50k there for the closing
or looking at closing of the um
road molcox road off of um lionside road
i would have thought that would probably
come to council to see if we
we should decis decide to do something
like that because it's going to affect
a major business in that area by closing
that and um
fifty thousand dollars just for the
seeing if we're going to close that road
is
seemed to me quite excessive for a start
and i i just don't know whether it'll be
the the appetite
right that road to be closed there
and on the portfolio to that that's the
first time i've actually heard of it
when i had a a you know a big rumor from
the business person that approached me
on it
should we have a bit more discussion on
that
before we set that for a closure because
once we've closed it'll never ever be
opened again
so i guess
to provide a bit of background that was
one of the things do you think you've
put mike a bit closer sorry
that was one of the projects that was
included in our long-term plan briefing
to council when we set the long-term
plan
the reason for
that funding
was to investigate whether
mulcox road and fernside road should be
closed or not
to do that and so i guess part of the
reason for that is there have been a
number of accidents at those
intersections over the last few years
and in 2019 i think it was there was a
fatality when a truck was hit by a train
we were always being very aware we need
to work with
our
other partners being kiwi rail and nz
on
what needs what the future of those
intersections needs to be and as part of
that we also need to do some network
modelling to understand the impacts on
our wider network if we were to consider
closure of those roads
so that's what that funding is for
there's also at the moment
waka kotahi have in their program
safety improvements on line side road
and that in itself means that we need to
form an opinion on what we want to see
happen to those intersections
so i would strongly advocate for that
project to stay so before that will be
done though it will come to so this is a
in our budget it'll come to counselling
community board i'd assume for a
direction or a workshop beforehand
around that level of travel
absolutely yeah and it's just also worth
just reminding councillors this
is a small part of quite a big and
important picture for our district so
um
both fernside and
flexton road
railway crossings and intersections with
lineside road they tie in very much with
the work that you will be aware waka
katahi have got on they've signaled
quite a significant expenditure on one
side
road
for a safety improvement also that fits
into part of the network that includes
the sku bridge so
you know each one of these can't be
considered in isolation so
if you think about the whole network of
sku bridge and flaxton road line side
road the connections between fernside
road and malcox road safety issue we've
been painting that picture with waka
kotahi
and certainly our chief executive emir
have been trying to put that issue in
front of them along with our running
portfolio holder
so
this isn't preempting any kind of
decision by the council or community on
that it's actually giving joanne some
funding to be able to
carry out the kind of investigations
that you need to do and be able to
respond to katahi as part of that
and be proactive
so
it's it is you know it is it is
important funding but it's definitely
not predetermining any possible outcome
so is this wakataki fun um initiative to
close it or is this um
the
originally a um
sorry a safety order that we had done of
that intersection recommended that
council consider closing that
intersection so there's full council it
was for council yeah so it's going to
come back poor but it's just a holding
line and
there's a budget item there yeah that'll
come back as a briefing to council and
community board yeah you know
i was mainly sure no no how would you
reply to the email that i've personally
had from the business there that
um
if you if you want some help in the
response so that uh staff can assist
with that with you
yep or if you fall it on they could
respond for you if you'd like
all right
okay uh council award
just just on that um
could you please clarify for me that
it's not completely closing off milfox
road it's just
that road would still be open for the
businesses there but the access across
the railway line is what you're
considering for safety reasons
again that hasn't been determined that
would be part of the whole investigation
and there are there are really three
options
one is there's no change it we get to
the point of deciding that um the
intersection needs to remain open and in
it is as it is um what uh and the second
option is there may be some limits to
movements in and out
um and the third is complete closure so
i mean there are options
okay and we need to work through that as
i said with council
with kiwi rail to understand and so in
the community to understand the
implications and what that might mean
good just sorry to really clarify that
question which we would not be shutting
off anyone's access to their property
that's that would no
no that would not be on the table
okay um
council ballot
um yes thank you um julian and
jared um sorry it's a bit early in the
morning um
i think most of the questions were
answered which was really brilliant to
have done a lot of the questions ahead
of time
the one question that i just wanted to
clarify was on page 12 of our agenda
which is the roading operation operating
expenditure
looking at
compared to
the budget that we had originally in the
long term plan for 2223 there was a six
percent rise in operating expenditure
um there's now it's been cut down to a
two percent increase in operating
expenditure
when we've got it so sorry you've got
the page operating expenditure page
so it's dropped from the forecast
considering that we have a 3.4
increase in growth
shouldn't we be increasing our operating
expenditure rather than decreasing it
it's actually reduction in structural
corridor maintenance quite a few lines
jared sorry jeff has just advised that's
the depreciation
reduction and depreciation effects
but there's also a reduction in corridor
maintenance
and structural maintenance
which
sorry
is and
i would assume is in
reflection of the
reduction in wakakotahi's subsidy i'm
assuming
that's what i would guess but what i'm
what i guess what i'm asking is should
we be putting in some more budget and
unsubsidized roading to try and keep up
with the growth in our district
because i'm concerned at the drop
well we aren't
in effect we are still working to
achieve the same level of service with
the budget that
we have
um
i i would my i guess my reply would be
i wouldn't be encouraging putting
additional budget into
unsubsidized at this time until we have
done some more work to determine what
that needs to look like otherwise we
would just be putting in a placeholder
that
is based more on feel
so my preference would be to go away and
do some more work on there and consider
that as part of the next
annual plan
so are you comfortable that the levels
of service in our district won't drop
with the drop in operating expenditure
no i'm i'm comfortable we can maintain
at the moment
but as i said we do need to do a bit
more work in that space
great
and just what an overall question for
the chief executive if i may which
relates to roading and all the budgets
actually
when we do the annual plan is it
possible for staff to give us a wee
chart of all the pull forwards and
carryovers so that we don't ask
questions we don't need to on those
budget lines it's hard to see when we
only have a two-year spread of budgets
when things have been pushed out or
pulled forward which relates also to
that car parking question
is it possible for that there to be a
small chart in the budget so that we can
see
um the pull forwards and the carryovers
just looking at chief i would imagine
that's possible um to be very clear
it's just quite hard for us to say i
think i think it would be
be helpful going forward it's a good
question uh councillor
sorry um williams please thank you
yeah
i'm also a wee bit concerned so brought
up about the um
the maintenance on our
gravel um shingle roads
we're always getting complaints about
and these are from some of the actual um
greater drivers there's no
there's no um guts in the service there
for them to actually spread across the
road and and redo all the time structure
you mean structure yeah and
you know so they're just basically um
spreading the stones across the road
with no um
grip to hold it all there and i know
we've had some reports saying we've got
some
i think 60 mil with um
a
base course here where we can actually
move and all that but when you actually
see the graders are sort of um
it's
something's not happening there because
we're getting so many complaints about
our roads not been good enough and um
do we need an extra budget to um
to actually you know um effectively um
put some more base course on top of
these roads so they can last better some
of the roads haven't had any yep so it's
a very good question thank you
so back in 2008 a gravel loss study was
done which is where the 60 millimeter
running course came
recommendation came from and what that
then
outlined was how much metal was required
assuming that we needed to
on our higher volume roads replace
our gravel every four years right out to
our really low volume roads which we
needed to replace scrabble every 15
years so depending on the road hierarchy
and the traffic volumes we set our
program
we do need to go back
as part of this next review of our
activity management plan and reassess
that gravel loss and make sure we've
still got that right
and also have another look at our roads
where our traffic volumes have increased
and whether we need to do some more work
um
sorry whether we need to allow for some
additional metal metal maintenance
metalling
we do
occasionally have roads that are sealed
also so they come off
our metaling list
and so in the past that's largely been
balanced
but we are in the position where we need
to review that
over the
next 12 to 18 months and we would put
that into a future program
with unsealed roads we will never have
no complaints
if we have no complaints on our unsealed
roads then
our level of service is far too high
so so i guess the point is you're going
to bring that back
in the review
you also because we had a portfolio
meeting the other day
um you're making sure that cycon and the
measurement that's there is is is
audited and kept to the standard it
needs to
and where improvements need to occur
that's being monitored and fed back so
rather than getting into the detail now
that that'll come back and perhaps to
our portfolio meetings paul if you're
happy with that
counselor becky
page 17 joanne
um old the old waimakariri bridge
handrail replacement 122
i presume that's that's our 50 with with
ccc is that correct
that's our half of it yes okay so why is
what can you explain why is that an
unsubsidized
wouldn't waka tahi have it have a
um subsidy thing in in the i can't i i
don't see how that relates to the page
back on page 15 where we have um
bridge component replacement which is
subsidised what's the difference yeah i
can explain that one so what happens is
because christchurch city and managing
that work
this in effect is our 25 share um
because they put the project into their
nltp bid
and get the approval for the waffles
so yeah thank you yeah
all right no further questions
so we've already um approved the
recommendations that are here so
thank you joanne i appreciate all the
work there's a couple of points which
we'll pick up in february later on that
have been raised here today but thanks
for all the work you've done and putting
together the budgets
right we're going to break now for
morning tea
if uh members could be back
um
10 45
[Music]
so we now come to the solid waste
budgets pages 23 to 55. there's no white
pages so though decision making pages
for your
section uh kitties that aren't already
contained in here yeah
right kitty thank you
thank you
so the key points from my budgets are in
the collection account while the over
rates overall rates income is projected
to be about 6.4 above the ltb budgets
that's mainly from the continuing the
high district growth and higher bin
uptakes and the ltp
we're proposing to increase the
recycling rate higher than we predicted
for the ltp to fund higher collection
costs processing costs and auditing
costs
but we're also proposing to partially
offset those by not increasing the
rubbish and organic spin rates as much
as predicted in the ltp
we're also
recommending that the
rubbish bag prices be increased to 3.60
to fund increased bag supply costs and
rubbish charge increases
in the waste minimisation account
the general rates
were proposing to increase that to 37
000 next year to fund
all council related costs which is in
line with the ministry for the
environment's recommendations after
their last audit
but we're not proposing any other
changes to the account especially in the
operating accounts
and the disposal account no changes are
proposed to the general rate funding
um however because the landfill levy is
increasing from 20 to 30 per ton and
rubbish transportation and disposal
charges are increasing above our cpi
these both impact on the rubbish gate
charges and we're proposing to increase
rubbish green waste non-recycling
polystyrene cleanful hardful and
commercial recycling charges to recover
cpi and other signaled cost increases
increasing bukashi charges to cover the
increases that we've had recently
but no other gate charges will be
increasing
with regard to capital expenditure
our two main pro upgrade projects the
design will start this year but probably
won't be completed until next year so
that's pushing those
projects out a year and
a couple of other smaller works which
depend on this project have also been
deferred
happy to take questions
thank you questions
councillor williams
father by councillor stewart
you just um
the rubber spring rate's increasing um
and you've got an increase here owing to
district growth and update of optional
bins
that's what's um on the um
the budget implication
i presume we're getting our income from
that as well so it's actually should be
cost neutral is that correct
because i i thought those bins were
um not costing the general rate power so
it's all um if you wanted a bin you'd
pay for it and that was that this like
it doesn't actually seem to balance out
there as far as i can see it probably
does somewhere but whereabouts is about
balance out
or does it
it it does balance out they are um
they're targeted rates so only those
people who get the bins are charged for
the rubbish and organic spins
yeah but what i'm saying is what they
pay is actually what the costs or does
the rate pass subsidise as well
well they pay
the cost of those bins so where's the
income from that in your budget in
targeted rates
if you look at
page
in the top row
um
the waist bin rates
are
two nine two seven five eight four so
that's
both of the organics and the rubbish
rates combined
so that is the full charges for those
rubbish charges
for the um
for the bins
yep so that's on page
second line down paul yeah no just
pretty hard for you know yeah for me to
pick that looks okay
thanks for the question so uh i heard
council stuart
um the redesign of the rubbish bag
which has gone to a lighter grade of
plastic instead of having handles at the
top has got that long
string
have we had any complaints about that
because i've heard complaints about
um
their robustness and the fact that it's
gone from
a quite
um
quite um handy
handle that you could tie up to this
long string
that you've got to
keep track of
while you're filling the bin so what
what prompted
it the change of plastic and the change
of design
that was prompted by
supply chain issues which i believe we
did report back to the council when it
happened last year these are locally
manufactured bags
so and they don't have the capability to
manufacture the handlebags anymore in
new zealand
so these are a temporary measure and
once they've run out we have got more
handlebags in stock and they'll be
rolled out to the customers we have had
a few complaints not too many
but it's also i've got to remember that
when we changed to the handlebags we
also got complaints about the fact that
it was more lighter weight
and less capacity even though it was
exactly the same as the original to your
top legs
can you use your microphone please
he said one of the lightweight ones
likely to run out i mean
when when they sold out
so when supplies have run out
their new bags will be rolled out okay
all right any further questions sorry
council banished
um kitty the
waste minimization policy that we have
we've been trying to reduce and divert
as many materials from landfill as
possible that's correct
um
why would we reduce the
rubbish the red bin in the green bin
from the ltp forecast
and raise the recycling so much i know
it's costs falling where they lie but
wouldn't it be an opportunity to
encourage the diversion into recycling
by keeping the red bin and green bin at
the same as predicted in the ltp
and perhaps that would help ease the
burden on the recycling bin which is
compulsory
oh as
as you said yes i'm trying to make the
costs lie where they actually come in
and my report does say that we are
looking to have to raise the recycling
rate up by
five dollars
per year for the next four or five years
to recover all of those costs so we are
getting some cross subsidy out of the
rubbish organics costs
but if we were to do that how much would
we how much would the recycling go up
it would need to go up to 127
per ton next year
so my proposal is that we increase
at this stage just five dollars
this coming year and reassess what the
price impacts will be or the cost
impacts will be before making further so
now i think you can mistake my question
if we were to keep the refuse
the
red bin and the green bin as they are in
the ltp
providing that extra income
what would then be the increase to the
recycling if we used it to offset
how much would it change
i've looked at that and
we would get very similar
costs
to the current budget sheets if we kept
the rubbish on organics to the ltp
increases
but would also have to increase the
recycling rate by three dollars rather
than two dollars per bin
but that would also put the cross
subsidy up
on a lower number of people who are
using rubbish bins
rather than everybody using recycling
bins paying additional costs
so when you i think when you answered
this question you said that it would
drop the recycling increase change from
the ltp down to 2.73 no it was would
increase it from two dollars to three
dollars so we were projected to increase
two dollars
in our budget sheet it says three
dollars yeah
it doesn't okay so three dollars you're
referring to page 26 in our agenda the
recycling rate is three dollars extra
than what was predicted in the ltp
we're already changing at five dollars
which is three dollars more than was
predicted in the ltp
plus 4.8
and so in in the table it's saying it's
an additional three dollars on top of
the two dollar increase yes sorry that's
what i'm saying yep so how much would
that change from lgp reduce if we were
to offset it by keeping the costs the
same for the green
and the
um red bin that go to landfill
to balance everything out that would
have to go to 108 so it's a three dollar
increase
right so that would make the recycling
hundred and eight dollars and save it
two dollars per bin yep so it would only
be a one dollar change from ltp if we
did yes right that's right that's what i
was just trying to clarify okay um mr
manchester question on that if i wanted
to test the meeting on that how would i
go about that the way we're doing the
pro forma and we just test it with an
amendment if you wanted to test
that so
relating to that matter so sure if once
questions are finished i'd like to do
that please okay
all right any further questions
okay so you what are you going to thank
you
and
so the amendment that i'm proposing
is to
keep
the refuse and organic spins
at the ltp forecast levels
to
encourage diversion to recycling and
reduce the change in ltp
for the recycling bin
so just to go over the consequence of
cost again just so we're clear on that
sorry did you want to say something
kitty
no so what's the consequence of cost on
that please again just so we're clear on
that it's just shifting the cost centers
around isn't it it is shifting cons cost
centers around but it's also
putting ace
or cross-subsidizing from the rubbish
and organics rates to pay for the costs
of the recycling
cost
collections and processing
so do you want to read that your
um amendment kirsten and tracy sorry to
write it down sorry that's right we'll
just give you a minute no that's cool
so it's keep the refuse in organics
rates
at ltp
ltp forecast
levels
and
use
this income
to offset
the rise
in the recycling bin
right
okay is there a second tip for that
council meetings
council making years thank you
so do you wish to speak to them yes
please um i just wanted to test the
meeting on this one with a with this
proposal um i certainly think the
budgets have been absolutely outstanding
and i'll always say that kitty's budgets
are one of the best to read the easiest
to understand
and i understand the principle of
keeping costs where they lie
however our waste minimisation policy
clearly states that we should encourage
diversion from landfill
to do that
we want to encourage people to actually
use their recycling bins and to use them
properly so we have less in the red bins
and the green bins which go directly to
cape valley
my premise here is that these forecast
figures were already in the ltp so they
have been provided and consulted on with
our community
and our community has commented on them
already and they were accepted in the
previous ltp
keeping these rates at this level which
is just a standard increase
means that
we then can provide a little extra
revenue
to be able to offset
the large rate
of increase that we're seeing in the
recycling rates due to external factors
continually putting our recycling rates
up
is
causing people to recycle less we are
seeing evidence of that in the community
where people are seeing that it's
actually not that it's not worth
bothering we want to encourage that so
in a way i'm asking the council to
slightly incentivize
at no major impact no impact on rates
but no major impact on the community
except to
reward those who are recycling and
encourage those who are using red and
green bins to divert the materials
this will benefit cape valley
this will benefit
um
our waste minimisation footprint
and it's in line with our council
policies
so i would very much like to see if
members would support this amendment
thank you just a second do you wish to
speak
you can you can reserve if you don't
wish to at the moment it's entirely up
to you
okay
counselor brian you've got some
questions counselor brian
so it's been mentioned that the green
bins are going to cape valley is that
correct
no the green bin's going to the compost
plant
so
if we cross subsidise this year
on this occasion would staff then
have the expectation that next year
you're going to do the same thing and in
consequential years you will keep
cross-subsidising
i would take council direction on that
i would not have an expectation that
this would continue and i was proposing
just to every year would refresh what
what i think is
an appropriate use of rating charges we
may find that we have sufficiently
refunding that will
reduce the rate take for the recycling
um it's
suggested that
recycling has decreased and i appreciate
we've had troubles because of covered
and
rejected
loads through some miscommunication from
christchurch has our recycling
as
tonnage irrespective of where it's
ultimately ended up has it reduced
i would say it's probably said stayed
fairly static
so on a per capita basis it probably has
produced
so if this amendment goes through
then next year you would highlight that
in the budget papers and that would be a
decision for council to see if it
continued that's my
understanding that how you would take
that kitty that's how i do it and also
next year we will be starting our waste
management and minimization plan review
and this would certainly be something we
would um include in that document thank
you
you wish to speak or do it with a
question
no i just think i'd support this um move
because i think um every cycle has
dropped off and i think we've
unfortunately um with what happened in
covert we've
been called the um
recycling police and i think we need to
start educating people to start using
their recycling bins again
and get it back to um
a better recycling level and um and
hopefully we'll keep the contamination
out of them so
i think this is a move in the right
direction at this stage
i think it's just timely reminder
everyone make sure your cell phones are
on silent
so helene shout we
like tiger beer by the way yeah
thank you
right sorry um
at council redmond
uh just to clarify mr merritt's question
um kitty what size is the recycling bin
the predominant number of recycling bins
is 240 liters but we do have 140 and 80
litre bins out there as well they're all
charged the same at the moment right
from looking at your table the recycling
bin is the cheapest of all bins is that
correct
it is and that
recycling rate also includes the council
administration costs and overheads and
all the all of the um advertising and
the collateral that we produce so it's
not just the recycling collection costs
that we're
paying for and that
there's there's also the other council
costs but yes overall it's the cheapest
bin okay
for the speakers
sorry just to complete that answer
it is already subsidised through the
waste levy so when we
charge refuse whether someone comes into
the transfer station or through the
curbside collection
that that gets charged a levy and we do
use
some of that levy income to cover our
recycling operational costs so there
already is um
some extent of subsidy going on um not
as direct as this it's a it's but it's
through that levy route
thank you um as somebody who uses all
all three bins um
we're talking about a relatively small
amount of money but we're talking about
a reasonable size principle on on this
the budgets reflect a decrease in the
red and the green
and the proposal is
that that decrease
be removed and subsidize the yellow
so the costs are not falling where the
costs are reflected
i can understand the reasoning for it
but as somebody who
studiously uh recycles has not had a bad
audit it almost ticks in all the rest of
the carry-on
so
i'm against it
transferring across to to yellowman
to me
costs for where they fall and should
their budget should reflect that
thank you
for the speakers
right to reply council about it
oh sorry nikki you're reserved do you
wish to say something sorry padme
i accept that you know we are changing
cost drivers a little bit and how we
charge this out it's about the
environmental benefits not just the
dollars and cents and we do have
obligations towards waste minimization
so to me this does make sense because we
are actually incentivizing people to not
just recycle but recycle properly
and
it's not a fair reflection when people
talk about
the costs associated with recycling
because there are far more costs in not
recycling and we really do want to keep
that waste out of the landfill and if
we're actually incentivizing people to
do that then hopefully
that will eventuate and the desired
behavior is becoming more widespread
so um this is but you know in actual
fact you know this isn't going to cost
our ratepayers anymore and in the
the average joe is never going to see
the difference
in
what the cost you know what what costs
are being driven by what um they're not
going to probably look
that closely that i've got two dollars
cheaper here and
one dollar more here but the principle
of the fact that we actually want to
encourage that recycling and discourage
the waste going to landfill um is the
underlying premise that i support this
motion and and i hope that you will also
see the same because you know at the end
of the day we cannot carry on with
status quo we must make changes and
whilst this is a tiny change it's a
change in the right direction
okay
further speakers
right of reply counts about it
do you want to use your microphone
please sorry that's right um just in
reply to some of the comments um we have
quite a few policies and council such as
the sustainability strategy as well
which we need to give effect to and
we've actually been criticized a little
bit for being slow to respond in that
space so this is only a tiny change it's
just a step in the right direction
effectively it's smoothing in a way
so i don't think it actually goes
against any of the principles that we
actually hold dear as a council i think
it builds our
reputation as a leading council that
wants to encourage sustainability and
protect the environment it's a one-off
opportunity this year because we happen
to have some cost savings in those areas
and it doesn't mean it can change
everything for the future we can review
that fully in the waste minimisation
strategy so i think this sends a message
to the community that we care about the
environment that we want people to
divert as much as they possibly can to
recycling and put as little as possible
in the red bin so i urge you all to
support it
it's really clear what the amendment is
i'll put the amendment all those in
favor please say aye
contrary
declare that carried
do we need a division
it said to me i i heard it carried i
declare it carried
well look i don't really necessarily
unless it's red unless i'm quite clear
it's carried if you really want a
division i'm happy to
to do that but i don't think we need to
do that all the time unless it's
absolutely necessary
all right
okay
thank you kitty your budgets are
complete unless there was any further
matters anyone wanted to raise
okay
all right
thank you um
water
um so
that's our next budget so that's uh
colin sir colin sorry kelly and colin hi
colin welcome to the table
yeah do you think or stuff do you think
we could make sure we get more than one
microphone up there because there are
some spare ones and it just seems maybe
just take wendy's over so you're not
having to
yes
there are some more up here as well i
think is that right
okay
all right
thanks thanks uh colin are you leading
this yes i think it's just what i'd
confirmed pages 56 to 127 is that
correct yeah and i had a report under
item 4.2
what's your report um ashley gorge water
supply why don't we deal with actually
gorge first because that has a
consequence
to the budget so that's page
25 item 4.2 pages 25 to 32.
okay cool all right so the um
the purpose of the report on ashley
gorge water supply is to inform the
council of the change in the legislative
status of the ashley gorge water supply
um and also to request the council
allocate the necessary necessary funding
to undertake works triggered by this
change in legislative status
um
so the the status change following the
enactment of the water services act
so previously under the health act the
ashley gorge water supply wasn't
considered to be a public water supply
and didn't
didn't follow the same requirements as
our other more conventional public
suppliers
however this changed when the water
services act came into force in november
last year and
it was also a bit unusual and that most
of these supplies
like this were given four years to
register in a further
i can't see the four and three years or
um to register and then
comply after that whereas
ashley gorge um
was on a previous register but the
register didn't trigger any
obligations previously but just being on
the register meant that it was
transferred to the new register and the
legislative change took immediate effect
so that means as of november last year
ashley gord should be meeting the
current drinking water standards which
it doesn't um
so hence why this is being treated with
more urgency than
other similar suppliers that weren't on
the register which include the rengar
airfield wooden beach and warren reserve
are the examples that we're aware of
so what this means is that we need to
look at undertaking an upgrade to the
ashley good supply to meet the drinking
water standards
this scheme is
most comparable to the gabriel water
supply which um
you'll recall has got undergone an
upgrade in recent years which got
filtration and uv treatment put in place
uh we got to that conclusion after doing
quite a comprehensive options assessment
so the proposal is to do an options
assessment first
um followed by the capital upgrade
and i've based the budget on the
assumption we'd end up with the same
kind of treatment system as gary mere
but there are other options we should
explore such as connecting to the oxford
rural number two scheme
uh so that the budget is based on that
um design in the next financial year in
construction the following year but
there is also some budget we're
requesting straight away which is to do
the initial options assessment which
will tell us what type of upgrade we're
designing
which we'd like to do this financial
year
and also to put in a chlorine analyzer
and alarm system
which is quite essential because the the
supply essentially has one barrier at
the moment which is chlorine but
um so that if um
if the chlorine system were to fail we
wouldn't know about it until an operator
goes on the next weekly check of the
plant whereas
all other
suppliers will have an alarm that we'd
know within minutes of something going
wrong
so that's considered
an urgent requirement and
um
yeah it's i think it's quite clearly
needed with under the water services act
as well as needing to meet the standards
that any supplier has the obligation to
always make the water safe which is the
overarching principle
um
so i
yeah the the rating impact is outlined
in recommendation f which it was
proposed to be funded from the general
rate which is consistent with the rest
of the reserve area and given the
reserve benefits
the whole district
which would um
increase that from
oh the increase would be a dollar and
three cents in 2020 to 23.44 and 24.25
happy to take any questions on that
thank you chris as uh your name is on
the report as well do you want to add
anything
no
thank you questions of colin
councillor redmond followed by stewart
uh thanks kong uh when does this work
have to be done to comply with the
legislation
well it
it had to have been done on the 15th of
november last year because there was no
lead in time for it so um it's it's
unusual when the health act required
changes
back in 2005 there was a certain period
of time small supplies must comply by
the state and others by the state but
the water services act
simply requires all water supplies to
comply with the standards and doesn't
mention anything about by the date so
it's
it's effective immediately
counselor stuart
i'm just
going to reread it to see if you'd
covered whether
with ashley gorge and potentially with
the other ones that
you're talking about
connections is the opportunity to bring
in rural suppliers
that are on their private supplies
to join into this if you're
if you're going to put pipe work in and
spread the cost and deal with some
private suppliers there is
there's always that potential in general
with this case there's um
a couple of k's a pipe from the end of
the oxford rule number two scheming to
the to ashley gorge so it doesn't and
it's basically one large farm on either
side of the road from what i recall it's
not there's not many properties there
so it's
it doesn't have that much potential it
would only be if one of those properties
were to subdivide down that that there's
a real opportunity to share costs um
the the real question on this one about
whether we can join to oxford rule
number two
is whether that scheme actually has the
capacity because it's right on the edge
and it's quite small pipe work
the cost to just extend that pipe work
would be quite low but then it may not
be big enough in the first place which
could
um
trigger much bigger upgrades but um yeah
definitely with the airport there's a
separate report considering the airport
and development in that area and
servicing so that does talk about some
cost sharing there with the developer um
and the other one considered was wooden
beach
these are the everything's especially
gorge only the supplies only need to be
registered within four years and they've
got more time to comply after that so
these aren't
immediate issues but i think it's part
of your question so wooden beach there
would be some definitely
not so much properties along the route
but the wooden beach community itself
there's a
you know there's a decent amount of
properties there that would benefit from
an upgrade so that would need to be
explored with that supply and how would
you do warren reserve because that's out
in the middle of nowhere yeah we have um
i have been working with the faces team
a little bit on that
there's very low water use there at all
currently what we had talked about
um that one thing that was needed was a
tank upgrade that the tank was in quite
poor condition and that was replaced at
the end of last year i believe or at
least a contractor commission to do that
and then the well would need treatment
as well or it could actually be if
demand is low enough it might be more
cost effective to fill that tank by
water tanker from a portable supply and
that so that's the plan a is do that and
monitor the frequency of bringing in a
tanker so when you do the detail of this
you're going to look at any economies
that could serve a wider purpose yes
yeah in doing it because certainly
that's where i'm coming from definitely
yeah
okay cool all right further questions
council williams you're indicated you're
prepared to move before someone prepares
a second
uh councillor brian
would you like to speak
yeah i think it's important we um
carry on with our
best water supplies in the whole new
zealand and i think um
we're um we're a leader and keeping our
supplies
really good and compliant so this is
imposed on us what we have to do anyway
so
i think it's good to show the public we
care about the water and um
this is a small cost we've got to pay
for it but um
there's nothing more important than
keeping our water healthy
thank you
i speak further speakers
yes council steward and council meetings
yeah just further to my questions i
think this is an opportunity
to
spread a good water supply into areas
which
perhaps
don't have and i'm talking about private
supplies
and unfortunately i don't think we've
got the data to
right at the moment to know
how many
properties are serving with their wells
serving more than two properties
therefore they're going to be captured
by
exactly the same sort of requirements
so to me this opens the door to
perhaps canvas
within a um
well
canvas the locals to see who would want
to join in and contribute
um
to having um
very good water monitored well as we
know all our supplies are so
really encourage this um
this opportunity uh to do exactly that
thank you council meetings
just want to say it's an excellent
report and i commended the proactive
stance that you're taking with this and
again it is in keeping with with this
council's proactive stance with our
water
and i just wanted to point out on your
sustainability and climate change
impacts thank you that is precisely what
i'm asking for
where it says
with climate change the frequency and
scale of these events so it's likely to
increase et cetera um
the whole purpose of that line and our
reports is so that we as council see the
risks that we are actually taking on and
can manage those well and that's exactly
what you've done so thank you brilliant
about it
just one quick comment for me because
everyone's covered it i would really
like to see the option of connecting to
a water scheme rather than being stand
alone having known the problems we've
had with places like garameer and the
costs become prohibitive as you go
forward so even if we could look even if
that works out slightly more expensive
it would be good to see the the 10 year
in the 50-year cost thank you
okay
write a reply council williams i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thank you
so um we'll come back to the budget
papers now colin pages 57
sorry pages 56 through 127. is there
anything you want to highlight in these
oh
i was planning on giving a little bit of
an overview to start with and then take
questions
so
um so yeah as usual
to try to adopt the long-term plan
figures and only change when necessary
as you're
well aware have to has we are operating
in a rapid change so there have been a
few changes that have been necessitated
these are driven by
two key things really which is the key
one or a key one being growth
with the new district plan coming into
effect
la or being notified last year there was
really
a really high rate of subdivision
applications immediately prior to that
and this has triggered some
reasonable size subdivisions being
consented on oxford rule number two
summer hill and gary mayer scheme so
we've had to respond to that by bringing
forward some growth projects
um
in terms of compliance there has there's
also an estate of record change there
which i'll talk about a little bit later
and the other change
not so much to budgets but to rating
impacts as the interest rate increase
has
affected scheme
across the board as you would have heard
earlier but
in particular some schemes that have
higher
ratios of loans than others are impacted
more than
you know some schemes are impacted more
than others by that as well
so table one outlines the proposed
changes and individual scheme rates
i did want to talk to the would end rate
a little bit um following a question
from a counselor in recent days so
that's currently showing as
about a nine percent increase
um there had been some changes to
operational budgets that had triggered
that um
and also there had been some smoothing
done last year so discounting last year
effectively which had meant that this
had come up this year
as a result of that but we've had a
since this was published just yesterday
we had a closer look with finance at
whether there was any opportunity to
change that and
we think it can be um
it can be smoothed down again to some
extent because
over time there is all that growth
happening in the ravenswood area that is
forecasting rates to come down so rather
than sharply go up and sharply go down
we can smooth that out um the
proposal from
finance is we could adjust it to a 6.4
percent increase on wood end which
although higher when
looking at water in isolation is higher
than the average rate increase that
because of other changes to the wider
rates that would mean that
the rate movement for the average wood
end rate payer would be in line with the
district average of 4.3 so that was
that was the
finance team's recommendation of how we
could adjust it but we can really we can
be flexible with that smoothing of if
the council wishes to do that
the other i thought i'd talk through the
key issues to consider a little bit um
which i had written in a bit of detail
so really the main thing
area of uncertainty and change
aside from growth is around the drinking
water standards and chlorine exemptions
so
drinking water standards
here at the time i wrote the commentary
had not come out for consultation yet
they have just come out for consultation
in recent weeks and the indications are
their expectation is for them to be
effective from july this year
although
in response to queries from us
or from a number of councils that
there's still uncertainty
although they'd be in effect whether
there'd be some leniency given to when
you actually need to comply with because
it's um
that would be an incredibly quick
turnaround to
consult on something and then get
feedback and then actually all councils
having to have implemented changes
within a few months
um but regardless that change is
signaled to be coming quickly and then
mandatory chlorination
the expectation is all suppliers will be
chlorinated by november this year unless
an exemption is gained
so both of those
things create some
uncertainty both in terms of what the
final standards will look like
and
um and how quickly we'll have to adopt
them and react to to what that triggers
and also in terms of the chlorine
exemptions we that
the outcome of that process creates a
few permutations in terms of
how we respond to other parts of the
drinking water standards
um
so i've tried to
introduce budgets where there's a high
enough degree of certainty about
where things are headed but also push
out some budgets where we don't have
enough certainty yet to say we
definitely need to do this
uh and that's detailed in the commentary
but i cannot answer any specific
questions on that and the other thing
mentioned is the fluoridation
bill recently became the fluoridation
act um
which gives the director general of
house the ability to require drink water
supplies to fluoridate their water
we
we have got an initial request from the
director general to provide costs on
that which we are working on preparing
but we haven't
allowed for those costs in our budgets
yes
so that if we are required by the
director general to fluoridate supplies
that would be a further change in the
future as well
um
just got a couple more points here
on page 67 there's mention of budget for
three waters reform
that so provisional allowance at this
stage to respond to the reform
and it was prepared on or assumed that
that would be offset by
the no worse off funding but
i just wanted to highlight that that is
definitely a provision only and we
wouldn't have an intention to spend that
until
we get
well until we get specific council
direction
after getting more information from
government and making a conscious
decision on
how we respond to that
but regardless it's got no
rating implication because it's an
income
and there's an income assumed and then a
cost assumed which cancel each other out
and then finally page 67 has a breakdown
of capital key capital budget changes
as i mentioned earlier these are mainly
growth driven
um
and then finally i thought i would just
talk to a couple of other points about
capital budgets which were
also some things that we'd responded to
counsellor questions on i just wanted to
correct one was about um
a waikoku beach renewal budget asking
what that was for the answer provided
was that it was to do with the
campground headwix upgrade which was
and not accurate the the budget was
actually pipeline renewal on uh kings ev
and queen's ave so that that point isn't
the specifics about waikoku beach is not
in the commentary that was
in a response to a counsellor question
and the other
uh
response to just correct was there was
the question about how many below ground
boreheads we have
in the district uh the answer given
previously was just about the kaiapoi
warheads of which there's four below
ground but in the district in total
there's nine
of our 32 primary whales have below
ground warheads
um so that's all i wanted to talk about
but happy to take any questions thank
you any questions of column it's very
extensive and you've covered it really
well so thank you
questions counselor
and this is a question for you colin but
it's also kind of a general question i
think for jeff
in terms of when we build things for
expected growth and i'm looking at some
hill scheme because there's one there um
i would have thought that would have
been offset by dcs why is it that
current ratepayers end up paying more
before the properties come online for
growth that they didn't have any benefit
from
i guess the way that we with any growth
project either
that requires new infrastructure
either the developer essentially builds
everything and pays for everything or
the council builds and recovers that
cost through development contributions
so
with the case of the summer hill scheme
the
it's not simply just extending a scheme
out which would usually fit the bill
more for a developer just a bit but it's
also it's actually upgrades right
from the davis road pump station and out
west and east so it's renewing existing
pipe work so it's not
purely um there's a renewal benefit and
a renewal funding portion for that work
and also because it's um
it's essentially modifying trunk mains
throughout the scheme it's it's
modifying the existing scheme so that
those are the cases where it's more
common
for the council to lead the project and
then recover the growth portion from
developers through development
contributions
so that's that's um
pretty
standard in terms of how we deal with
growth across the district and there is
always
a balance of risk
of not recovering costs
um i think at this point in time that
risk is
a lot lower than usual because there is
such
high demand for
um
four new sections developers would be
extremely motivated to they've got the
consensus they'll want to
do that as soon as possible to sell the
lots to make the most of the current
market so just to further answer that
question perhaps exactly hopefully
hitting on the point
um i
by and large
the the um development is very
beneficial to
current rate payers um there are times
correct eventually so there are times
where they may be front loaded with a
bit of
additional capital expenditure really
good example is ranger or water
and on the bigger schemes it's easier to
spread it when you do get some of the
smaller schemes it does become a bit
more lumpy but
we
if you just have a look back over the
last decade or more
or i would say all of our suppliers have
benefited from growth
including the likes of summerhill
because it does actually help offset
some of those costs of
upgrades by first of all sharing and the
capital cost um which we accept that
existing ratepayers have to pay for that
initially um but then that's loan funded
and paid for by development
contributions but then also they share
the operational
costs going forward so it's a really
good question and that's the way we
approach it and on the whole um it's
very much to the benefit of the existing
rate there
give a comment yeah
you know develop contributions
has been around for quite some years and
it's been tested
thoroughly
but if you still look at it in terms of
development
development sure
development can you try and contain it
but with development contributions for
this fight
we expect the development to occur over
a 10-year period because that's what
contributions are for
and so get back to paul's question
before how do we know that we have
chemical
and
as well as the current and so
we've put the line over 25 years which
is longer much longer than the growth
intended
and on top of that we do an assessment
on benefit versus costs so where does
the benefit actually lie is it is it
with current or future act and that
comes into the actual funding
formula as well
and also pushed out so there's a bit of
a midway approach between
funding dc's over 10 years but we
actually pushed the loan out over 25
months which is quite a
long period to capture that growth
there's economies just in jewish is
saying
there is benefit current rate powers and
by taking that approach it not only
reduces the development contribution but
it helps the development
occur
uh we
if you remember quite some years ago
i guess the question i'm asking is that
obviously some hills becoming one of the
most expensive schemes in our district
which has been raised before
and there is inequity showing with
points road paying a lot less and we see
it in playing a lot less on the same
scheme
what it i'm going to ask this question
every chance i get what is being done to
address the high charges for that one
scheme when it's connected with those
other two schemes
which have received one has received
subsidy yeah i think um
okay no conflicts of interest no
conflicts of interest at all
but just just for for the benefit of the
residents in the area yep yeah i think
one way to look at it is
you i think
the implic or the concern is the gap is
widening or getting worse if you look at
the percentage increases in table one
summer hill's got a two percent increase
points road twenty percent and western
five percent so the summer hill increase
is less than the rate of inflation so in
real terms it's actually a decrease
and then point threat and we said in
greater so that is actually closing the
gap albeit marginally on the case of
point somehow when we step in it's only
a couple of percent difference but it
it's heading in the right direction
for what what you're hoping to achieve
which is more equity between the schemes
um
and in terms of anything further you
know what can be done about it to close
it more
but we still have a targeted rating
structure where
schemes cover their own costs and
and to change
to to close the gap further we'd have to
do something different with that you
know points road i think you're
highlighting is an exception where they
got a government grant
which is true but that that decision was
made and there was a report to council
following input from the advisory groups
on there and that decision has been made
so we can't we'd have to retrospective
well we can't give them up the grant was
from the government and they funded that
project so
we can't change it through that stimulus
program or funding we it would have to
be changed through a change the rating
policy
um just just the final question just to
clarify about the water connection with
the problem we're having with building
materials and the delay in building
for people who are buying sites
the water rate is charged for the
connection
even if it's not being used by property
as yet is that correct yes that's
correct thank you
thank you
council redmond
and follow back out some meetings
uh thanks colin
i was the one who asked how many uh
below ground warheads we have um
christchurch city have been running
around raising their boyheads
are you saying on page 60 that we don't
need to raise
boy heads
and we can still
apply for a chlorine exemption
and those warheads will still be
compliant i think it's it's said
it's just that our chlorine exemption
approach is a little different crushes
cities as i understand it is to get
their ball heads
um
to a standard where they can argue we
don't need any treatment whatsoever
which i whereas our approach is to
to treat to regardless of our warheads
below ground or above ground to then
still uv treat the water as part of our
chlorine exemption application which i
think is a more
i think our approach is more in line
with the multi-barrier approach that
and the water services act is requiring
but um
so it's there's no there is no chlorine
exemption criteria this is what you have
to do to gain an exemption um
but we've just approached it in a
different way which i think in terms of
confidence of the quality of the water
leaving the treatment plant i think
having um
our blow granble heads which have been
upgraded to a higher standard
anyway in recent years to get secure
application secure status under the
current standards
so that i think we have good below
ground ball heads and then we would be
proposing to put uv treatment on top of
it crash it cydia trying to go for an
even higher standard of forehead but
then with no treatment so
it's just a different approach and
i'd say both i have high degrees of
uncertainty
associated with them not necessarily
because of the forehead but probably
more so because of the reticulation and
how that gets assessed which which is
why we haven't committed to doing one or
the other year because it we really need
to know the outcome of that reticulation
system assessment
from which um
it's just based on a apply and will tell
you whether we accept a sort of approach
i think you're just just relating to
that approach
given that obviously it's fairly it's
very important to us that application
that approach you're considering putting
forward would you get that peer reviewed
to make sure that that's sort of had a
second set of eyes over there
uh do you feel that's necessary
i
well we are working with becker on some
general chlorine-free advice at the
moment that was more about the
reticulation system but we can
definitely include that and i think
jared's got something to say i do and
it's perhaps going back to the initial
earlier question
perhaps hopefully will allay some of
your concerns it's not just because we
want to do something different because
we think that's a different idea
our approach is more based on
we've got a different system to
christchurch largely so predominantly
our supplies are
you can almost think of them as single
sources
we bring our you know even in kaipur we
bring our water into two
major headworks and most of our supplies
will either have one or two
main supply points
christchurch then network
they've got a lot of wells um that are
just within nodes within larger networks
so they've actually got some
characteristics within their network
that are different to ours um
that would have helped guide them in the
direction that they are proposing to
take um so
it's not just as simple as
personally comfortable with the
direction you're taking i just wanted to
ask that question but i think and then
also maybe to expand on a little bit
more
yes i suppose we are getting some
expertise but
this is a new ground for everybody and
even the regulators i don't believe will
know exactly
what bar we're going to have to jump um
it's a good conversation because this
calendar year it's all going to come to
a head if we don't have chlorine
exemptions by november
we will be required to turn on the
chlorine on our non-chlorinated supplies
and
it's it's we are operating in a very
uncertain environment i think you can be
assured that colin
and kelly are doing a lot of work to
make sure we're ahead of this as much as
possible
and taking on the expert advice when
they
think it's necessary thank you
council meetings
i just wanted to just
query a couple things in your table one
when we're talking about expensive
water supplies
you all might note that a hookah is
listed here as the most expensive water
supply
um it says per two unit connection on
that table
um
sorry can you explain so
that's not the unit price that i'm aware
of so can you please explain where this
numbers come from
um as you know there are some 19 unit
connections and what not historically
and yeah that's a scary number if that's
a per unit no it's a it's a three
percent increase anyway so i suspect
what i've done is put in the 19 unit
charge but said per two units
uh kelly's just got it for me otherwise
that looks terrifying yes yeah so it's
uh
the rate per property
is
12.30
and the amount per unit is 23. this is
on page 94.
um
so
that is um well for two units it's 12 30
plus 46 is um
1276 i think uh whereas for 19 units i
think that seem i think i have put in
the 19 unit amount in that table so
thank you for picking that up thanks for
that i like i said i just looked at that
one that is truly terrifying and
knowing someone who is a 19 unit
connection
um yeah
also
i presume as we've just been discussing
we were slated to have a 9.84 reduction
and i presume that's because that
subdivision out the back has not gone
through as quickly as anticipated
that
accounts for the 3.3 increase instead of
the reduction
uh the
forecast i've got so sorry that's on
page 94. oh
on the table oh sorry so so it was meant
to be um it was it was long-term planned
forecast at nine
nine point eight four percent decrease
excuse me
and it will now be a 3.3 percent
increase due to
the
lesser realization of development yeah i
think actually that um
it's
and i i'm gonna struggle to explain this
that first yellow
row you're looking at that has negative
9.84
is
not actually what
what the race gets set on but i'm not
quite sure what that represents because
what the rates are set on is every
property gets the per property charge
which is in the second yellow box
which was always forecast at three
percent and the third one is the per
unit of water charge so you you pay one
charge per connection and then the per
unit charge times how many connections
you've got
um
so i'm not i'm not 100 sure what their
first box is but i think the reason it's
fixed at three percent i think this
decision was made
several years ago when the development
didn't happen when expected that um
the rates were fixed at three percent
to basically ensure the scheme didn't
jump up prior to that development and
then plummet again after
um but i don't i think there will come a
point in time where we don't need to
sort of artificially fix it at that and
we can um we can rate for the true costs
but i'm not sure okay if um
yeah and i think that's that's what
comes into it because usually those
boxes will line up okay because yeah i'm
aware since 2013 that we have been
paying for infrastructure that hasn't
been realized yeah but i think the key
point sorry is just that the rates are
as we had consulted on that like in
terms of what each property would
actually be charged we can the long-term
plan had a three percent increase and we
still have that three percent increase
even though that table out of the
budgets which is definitely misleading i
see there's 13 less properties than
anticipated so i think that
picks it up but yeah okay now thank you
i think that answered my question it
just yeah particularly that two-unit
connection that i wanted clarification
on thank you
thank you know any further questions
thank you colin
i appreciate the work you're doing in
that space thank you
all right we now come to wastewater 128
to
177. i'm just checking if we got
any reports
no waste water reports
no sorry there are no no that's right i
was just double checking that we didn't
yep
okay
uh kelly you're leading us net thank you
colin
yeah so just to highlight thank you mr
mayor just to highlight a few points
regarding the wastewater commentaries so
first of all
in relation to the
impact on rachel note that the ahoka
utilities connection loan rate has got a
11.9
rate increase at the moment we've had a
closer look at that in relation to
in response to a counselor question um
the account is currently in deficit by
four thousand dollars which we were
seeking to recover in the 22-23
financial year uh but what we've looked
at doing um in collaboration with
finance team is to actually add that to
the loan uh so that will mean that the
um the rate will actually reduce
slightly
rather than it going up to 375 dollars
it will stay at about
325 dollars
so that will avoid that and i shared a
question in that and highlighted it here
too
because um you know putting it up that
much
was
when we've got growth and other things
that are slow to come on stream if it
can be recovered over a longer time i
think that would be preferred if
possible so you've worked that
you've made that work yep so that's
already been added to the um draft
budgets
thank you
there's the second change is an error
that's been identified by the finance
team and uh that relates to income on
the rangiora scheme if you just give me
a second i'll find the page to have a
look at
so it is
um
page 142
in the budget sheets
uh under income right at the very top of
the page
you will see there is a third item down
miscellaneous recoveries
and it shows an income of 240 000 there
so that was for income related to this
the new septage receiving facility at
the rangiora wastewater treatment plant
and you will note that we have deferred
that budget
by 12 months so that should actually be
removed as income
and we should not be showing any income
until the 23 24 financial year so that's
a change we haven't signaled yet but
it's been identified by the finance team
so jeff
and what do we need to do do we need to
adjust anything there or that just be
dealt with internally
so we don't need to do anything
thank you
and the final thing i just wanted to
highlight in the introduction is the
capital works program so under section
three in the overview
we have made some changes to the capital
works program for next financial year
predominantly based around
resourcing for delivery
so the key project there is the central
rangiora
upgrade stage eight so that effectively
takes us further up along
king street between queen street going
past the town hall
through past the petrol station and up
to the northern side of blackett street
so
quite a key area in terms of impact and
making sure we're
consulting well in advance so
um but combination of resourcing and
also the importance of that project
we've pushed it out by 12 months
so happy to take any questions thank you
yeah the ocean out for the the
um
ponds and all that drama i know we're
meeting our consents etc
have we got enough
budget in there for our consent's going
to come onto us
reasonably quick for the amount of work
we need to do to um
possibly get it upgraded and what have
you have we got enough budget to
actually
so you guys can inform us what we need
to
do for the the upgrade that's probably
going to be coming
on that because um
we've had a lot of voters from there
lately and
a lot of discoloring of the waters and
what have you
i'm just concerned we haven't got enough
budget sitting there to
to act when the time comes to
needing to act so you can inform us what
we're
going to need yeah that's a very good
question and there's probably two
parts to that in response um
first of all uh
we do have issues at the moment with the
kaiapoi wastewater treatment plant
particularly through the
summer months where we do get warm
temperatures within the the wetland and
that adds to
the algae growth and the odor issues
that we experience
so in terms of addressing that
we are doing some work at the moment
looking at a range of different options
we haven't included any additional
budgets to address that at the moment
but we do have quite a significant
budget for
d sludging in the
outer years the 25 26 financial year and
i believe it's in the order of about 1.2
million dollars
for dislodging so what we will look at
doing
once we identify the proposed solution
which is probably likely actually going
to be some
more regular de-sludging around the
perimeter perimeter of that wetland pond
what we'll be looking at doing is
reallocating that budget in future years
to account for that
uh in relation to
the future renewal of the consent that
is due in 2039
and what we have identified is that we
will need to start
effectively a 15-year program looking at
investigations re-consenting and then
implementing the upgrades prior to the
um 2039 so
the there is allowance within future
budgets to look at those initial
investigations but putting in some of
the bigger budgets for
the more detailed design
and detailed investigation and design
work as well as construction works that
would be addressed in future long-term
plans
thank you
that de-sludging that that would
actually help the discoloration of water
that's going out the the
ocean outfall as well would it
uh yeah the the discoloration occurs
because of the algae growth within the
water column so actually
removing that sludge will help with
giving a deeper water depth which is
going to minimize the amount of it'll
help with the temperature and minimize
the amount of
algae growth so yes
thank you any further questions council
bonus
sorry kelly i didn't quite understand
what you said about the ring you're
aligned but i'm just looking on page 139
of our budget in the eastern sewers
loan repayments
that right down the bottom
we jump from 2.2 to 4.3 just querying
what that was about
for why we principal being repaid faster
on that account uh yes so that was a
question that was raised um and just in
response to that what has happened this
year is that our finance team have done
a detailed review of all of our
development contributions
and what they have identified is that
they're
for both the east
rangiora
development contribution area the west
rangiora development contribution area
as well as the structure plan area
within west rangiora there have been
capital works expenditure that have
occurred in the past under the rangiora
account
and what didn't happen at that time but
should have happened
was that that ex there should have been
a transfer from the dc account
into the
scheme account to account for that
expenditure
so there's been a correction undertaken
and what that effectively means is that
there's money coming from the dc account
into the
rangiora or eastern district steam
scheme account and that actually means
the amount that can be paid off the loan
on the edss this year so it's actually a
benefit for
the loans getting paid off i can
understand the explanation thank you
thank you any further questions
thank you kelly that addresses the
wastewater
budget so we now come to item five which
is drainage
so just so for drainage
so
um
there's no easy way of doing this apart
from going into px and then coming out
so
uh i was hoping we'd do be able to do it
all at once but we'd have to align
staffing for that so i'm going to move
that we go into public excluded for the
reasons
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
all right so we're
um
drainage
they're already done
because pro forma is already yeah no
good good move
let's get myself back on the right
agenda
so we're now uh we've dealt with waste
water we're back into
drainage now so that's item
178.
and
mr mead there's also another report item
4.1 oh we might deal with that first
thank you
so that's um pages 16 to 24 cowboy
stormwater and flooding improvements
kelly
uh thank you mr mia so
this report is a follow-on report
relating to
the
report to council in december
uh last year where you approved an
additional four point one seventy seven
five million dollars for the shovel
ready kaiapoi stormwater and flooding
improvements project uh that also
included a scope change
to remove some of the works and allocate
funding to the macintosh
drain pump station
so this report effectively um
is looking for approval for the funding
sources for that additional budget
and what is proposed is that
part of it 705 000 will be assigned to
the north east kaiapoi development
contribution area
so that will increase the stormwater
development contribution to sixteen
hundred and forty five dollars per
property
and that the remaining 3.47 million
dollars
is uh funded from the district drainage
account
um so that will
increase the district drainage rate by
approximately 8.22
bringing that rate to
28.12
um under recommendations see you can see
that there is a
multiple change of um both new budgets
as well as
shuffling of budgets um
from different projects
but the the net effect of all of that
adds up to the
4.175 million so happy to take any
questions thank you
questions i've got um one from
councillor duty
um she texts me she's going to try and
be here this afternoon
so she wanted to know um if york street
diversion campex program goes ahead
so i'm trying to make sense of her text
here the transfer of stormwater for main
street down york street instead of over
loading tara alone and into flanigan's
drain is that
that makes sense to you
could you just repeat that again yeah
i'm sorry i'll
maybe i'll wait till we finish here
because i i'm trying to it's um it's not
really relevant to this current report
oh sorry sorry i'm sorry i've got myself
confused with the overall drainage
budget i'm sorry excuse me
um right any questions on this
yeah this is the um 4.1 cowboy
stormwater any questions on that
moved by councillor atkinson
seconded by
councillor brian any discussion
we've done this really um and uh it's
just making sure that it gets in there
and it's absolutely necessary to uh to
get the result that's required down
there
okay
any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carriage
now we come to the drainage activity and
maybe that question of council duty if
you um have an opportunity to
but you could cover that in your
commentary
pages 179
pages 178 on
uh thank you mr mia so just to highlight
a few things from the drainage
commentary uh you'll note the district
drainage and kaipoy rates have um
reasonable increases in the order of 20
and 27
they're predominantly driven by the most
recent report on the um shovel ready
works
um
so the reason that even though kaiapoi
is not
funding any of the additional um
4.175 million there is the value of that
infrastructure coming across
increases um the depreciation amount so
that is one of the main drivers behind
that increase in kaiapoi um also the
uh interest rate increase has meant that
the um the workshop already works kai
poi urban as funding
the loan repayments have increased for
that
um
oxford
urban has a 13 increase and there has
actually been a correction to the number
of rateable properties here that has
meant that increases higher than
expected
again both globally and cust have had
higher increases
no significant changes have occurred on
those schemes they're just
very small population numbers and any
small changes hasn't
has a bigger impact on rates
in terms of capital works program
so we have again gone through and
done a thorough review of projects
uh in wood end we've deferred the
construction for the school road and box
drain improvement projects
within rangiora
line side
upgrade stage 2 the construction has
been deferred
we've started design work on that and
that is a project where we may
bring the budget forward if it's going
to be beneficial with
aligning that in with the
south brook road roading upgrade works
palmer church street that has been
deferred
predominantly due to
aligning their works with the kerbin
channel
works that roading will be undertaking
and then in rangiora at the middle brook
treatment project so that is one of
we've got a few projects coming up that
is looking at improving our treatment
performance in advance of 2025 as part
of one of the measures to
meet our network discharge consents that
project there has been deferred because
it needs a bit more
uh scoping there's potentially land
ownership issues so that was one of the
projects that we didn't feel we were as
progressed on
the final thing in terms of just the
budget overview section five
is um new fees and charges that we are
introducing relating to our network
discharge consents and in particular
medium and high risk sites and
processing application
approvals for discharging into our
stormwater system so that is something
we haven't had in the past
but it's a new role that we're taking
over
um in terms of providing consenting
where the discharges into our
system rather than into the receiving
environment
so happy to take any questions thank you
so that question i had at the start um
oh yes misaligned with um
york street i assume that's oxford the
diversion capital capex program is that
that's proposed to go ahead is that
correct uh yes it is so that was one of
the projects that was included in the
wastewater and drainage reticulation
package that went out to a consultant so
we have had a consultant
working on the design for that we
we're at discharges at the end of york
street
it crosses hayward road i believe it is
and then
through private property we have
gained
a positive support for the project from
the landowners so
um the
the hurdles for that proceeding
next year are being addressed thank you
and
just another just for clarity
waikoku we had public meetings last year
there were a range of and swindles road
flooding etc
are we what is our proposed program down
there and
by way of
addressing certainly the concerns that
residents raised around the speed of
that program and have we capacity
to get that investigation work done
completed
so in
well
since the 15th of december flood event
we've actually
revisited
the speed that we were getting through
addressing all of the service requests
and the follow-up investigations
and also with the additional work coming
out of the 15th of december flood event
we have uh sought
support from external consultants
so we have two people
consultants that will be working in the
office uh three to four days a week
um and effectively we're setting up a
mini flood team that will actually
work through that program of works um so
that is expediting getting all of those
investigation works um completed and
undertaken
i'm probably just a follow-on comment to
that it's worth noting that those
investigations will potentially may
recommend upgrading works
we do have some limited budgets for
improvements
within the waikoku area but any more
substantial upgrades
that would actually be a report back to
council seeking additional budget so we
specifically haven't included any
larger budgets
for any works that can identify because
we haven't completed those
investigations yet so um going back to
residents so they clearly understand
this how we propose to do that because
we had a really good public meeting down
there
and so and the expectations i thought
were well managed
as a letter out to residents because
it's not a big particularly big area is
that something that we've considered
doing
uh
yes i know i think it's probably
actually going to be more targeted we do
have discrete areas like um swindles
road in particular uh kiwi reserve as
long as residents know because we had
bigger tenants down there obviously so
it's making sure that we i don't mind a
fly drop goes right through the your
work with comms around there we won't
design that by committee for you but um
some communication back to those
residents would be helpful agreed thank
you further questions council atkinson
you just page 211 kelly i just noticed
um
in the
kuiper area age drainage we're talking
about developer contributions going from
from a forecast of 82 867
to
169.03 what is that where is that from
is that is that by any chance beach road
beach grove sorry
moving ahead quicker than was predicted
but
it's 90 000 difference
sorry i'm not on so page 211 211 top of
the table
development contributions
the forecast was 82 867.
the annual budget for 2223 is 169 304
uh i believe we got the windfall for
yeah
um i believe that relates to the fact
that we are now increasing the um
development contribution for
the
in relation to the shovel ready project
but i think probably the question is
whether there should be any income at
all
from that area i just need to go back
and double check exactly
which
development that is actually predicting
is going to be contributing to that well
the reason for my question really is if
that's wrong that has a direct
effect on rape
okay so you'll check that and come back
kelly yep
and perhaps before we can how so how
how soon could you get back to us about
that with that i can look at that um so
that it comes early afternoon thank you
further questions
council williams
i think kelly knows where this question
is coming from
um the maintenance on some of their
product have we got enough money in the
budget for maintenance because at the
moment the maintenance on some of our
drainage systems is
not wonderful and um
and also the maintenance on and keeping
clean some of the pipes and whatever on
the on the new projects we've got coming
have we got enough
money in the budget or do we need more
budget or have we got enough budget
well i am i i am actually sorry answer
that but
at the moment no no we don't need a
speech with it so you've asked the
question so yeah yeah and i think um
particularly for our
coastal uh both urban and rural drainage
areas um
because of the flooding both response
and also the following maintenance that
we're doing we're likely to be
overspending our current budgets just
given that we've uh with the work
following the may event last year and
also the december event
um
we're
having a closer look at the standard of
maintenance that is undertaken
and we will increase it and raise that
where that's appropriate
i think in response to having adequate
budget to keep up with that our um
our plan to address that is to actually
uh to to do the maintenance work to make
sure we're meeting that level of service
and then to adjust the budget based on
historical spins to to ensure that we're
we you know
we're budgeting correctly
so i think in response to your question
it's more about
um
making sure we're doing the maintenance
and achieving that level of service and
then the budget will follow accordingly
unless there is a specific step change
sometimes looking at historical spin for
drain maintenance sometimes we have
periods where
we spend under the budgets and then we
have particularly
wet years or even
warmer wet years where we get a lot of
weed growth and that means that we spend
a lot more money so we do have unders
and overs and we constantly review to
make sure um you know we've we've got uh
adequate budget and we're not eating
into deficit
so will the unr committee get a bit of a
report on the progress on the
maintenance on
some of these um drainage coming up
or can we have a
a bit of a report on it
[Music]
uh yes you will be getting a report on
the
december flood event and
we'll make sure that the maintenance and
status of maintenance is addressed as
part of that report because there are
some items that some colleagues have
been out to see that we're concerned
about so that'll be picked up as part of
that briefing and report thank you
all right any further questions
thank you kelly um and you'll come back
on that other item that uh deputy
americans have asked
so that's your
uh the stock water um yes we're gonna
come to that now so just i'm taking one
off of the time
so stop water races you're dealing with
us as well kelly 233
um to 240
this
yeah so you'll
nothing really of note
um to mention in terms of stock water
change there haven't hasn't been any
significant change
um you will notice under the uh
long term plan issues there are there
are two um matters there that are that
are noted that were also mentioned to
council when you adopted the latest
bylaw earlier this week
that's right
any questions of colleagues
there's no
white pages that go with that so
thank you thank you kelly we appreciate
the work you and your team are doing
thank you
um
uh now jared we come to your overheads
page 214. one two two fifty
okay so this um
budget is to to cover the
the
utilities and roading department
overheads uh
salaries um and also there's allowance
for asset management and projects that
are not necessarily accounted for in the
unit budgets
it is worth saying these budgets have
been prepared on us continuing as
per normal so
putting then we're not making any
assumptions about the future of three
waters in the preparation of this budget
if that was to come to pass then there
would be a have to be a substantial look
at that um it has
allowance as made
can see for some staff
changes that have been signaled in the
long term plan happy to take questions
thank you questions
thanks jared
it's probably your easiest overhead
you've got through but it's it was
really clear what you were looking for
so thank you and thanks uh
thanks for you all the work you're doing
in your space particularly um your
leadership with your team on three
waters one of the most difficult issues
that we're dealing with so we appreciate
the work you're doing along with the
team so thank you
all right yes
um we can have kelly lively now it's
pretty pdu
so um kelly has got a development
contributions report yes um so if you're
happy to take that before the uh that's
just that's px
that's public
so happy to do it anyway if you wanted
to uh no no i will do it that way let me
just catch up to that
so i've got bits of paper everywhere
here trying to
stop between various agendas remind me
where that is in their agenda
oh 4.4 pages 55. so if we go into our um
uh
tab six
so pages 55 to 113. welcome kelly
thank you mr mayor uh so this report
seeks approval for both the draft
development contribution schedules as
well as the policy
um the policy had some minor changes
that really came out of the hamilton
city council high court decision on
development contributions and just
sought to clarify
in particular that
development contributions projects or
projects that are included in the
schedules are not necessarily
within the map area for development
contribution areas sometimes the
servicing requirements fall outside of
those those areas so we looked to
clarify that in the policy
in the schedules there have been
several
changes most of those are due to either
interest accumulation changes in growth
numbers or changes in
in budgets
there are some large changes in
in some of the
development contribution areas and that
is really based on
some
more work that we have done on servicing
strategies for specific growth areas and
work with developers as to how we were
likely to
look at sharing costs
there are two changes
to corrections that need to be made to
the schedules that are in the report and
that's to the district
roading
development contribution
16532 as shown in the report
because of these
changes that need to be made
we need to add a recommendation h to
delegate authority to approve these
minor amendments to the dc schedules to
the chief executive so that they can be
addressed prior to publication of the
consultation document
um
happy to take any questions thank you i
think
so h delegate minor changes have you
picked that up
yep
so
questions
all makes perfect sense to me
so
some are prepared to move
move to council redmond with h
you're happy to move the h is second to
count the award
would you like to speak
uh just briefly these are fairly
sensible updates to the policy to
reflect that court decision so i don't
think there's anything too significant
otherwise so happy to support it
it's okay
welcome council duty
uh
secondary
no
yep so any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye contrary to clear
that kerry thank you kelly so if we just
come to your your white pages now page
251 so we're on the
uh project delivery unit budget
council duty so page 251 in the folder
thanks kelly
okay thank you
a couple of things just to highlight
with the pdu
proposed budget so
pdu derives all of its operating income
from fees charged to clients for
projects completed as well as
resource consents that we work on so
we're a fully cost recovery unit
there is a proposed increase in training
budgets to restore them back to
pre-covered levels
and this is to address and ensure that
staff members are undertaking mandatory
training for their roles it is fully
funded through the charges and fees so
it doesn't have any rating impacts
we will be looking at an hourly charge
rate increase for internal clients
however our rates are still
substantially lower than market rates
for similar services
the only other thing to highlight is i'm
anticipating that resourcing is likely
to continue to be an issue into next
financial year
given the
market that we're in right now it's very
challenging to attract and retain
engineers and i expect that that's going
to continue to be an issue for us
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you questions
thanks kelly um and we appreciate the
work that you and your team do uh and um
and that alignment with the last report
made a lot of sense so great work thank
you
well we've now i think we can now
adjourn for lunch you've arrived at the
right time counselor judy
um
we aim to be back at um i'll give i
think we need time to have a bit of a
break so
we're back at 20 past one um uh back
here and we'll start with chris's
budgets uh
at 20 passport
sorry
well i don't
sorry but that's
well
how long do you need sandra
well i'm not giving you an hour for
lunch i'm sorry
yeah i'm sorry but we've got to keep
going so
yep okay thank you if there's anything
you want picked up through that time let
us know
thank you we had signaled half an hour
for lunch today so it's it is half an
hour okay thank you
[Music]
so
oh yes
is that the young boy's book
yeah yeah
now it's my book
[Music]
now the uh
libraries budget pages 260 to 271.
so thank you paula chris
um
look forward to your commentary and
assume that we've read that through
because we have
and if you just want to highlight any
main points that you've got there thank
you
thanks mr mia um kia ora and happy new
year everybody
um
there's very little significant change
to the library's
report just a couple of points to draw
your attention to from a risk
perspective
we've had it confirmed last week that nz
lpp funding which was rumored to
potentially be extended for up to six
months will not be
so we now know it's definitely finishing
30th of june 2022.
as we know from reporting nzlpp has
enabled us to address and support
community outcomes specifically social
and cultural well-being at a level that
we've never been able to pre this
funding um the library's leadership team
and i are looking to address how
the staffing reduction so that's three
ftes
can be absorbed but more importantly the
services programs events and learning
support that have been offered to the
community
particularly in oxford as we've had the
capacity so just flagging that as a risk
and also fines free
that we have coming to
seven months with that
timing couldn't have been more perfect
incredible feedback very positive for
the community community engagement
especially during covert times
it's now reflected in our budget as the
income levels are lower
so i'm just flagging that
as well that's all i've got
thank you um any questions
there you go
done
thank you not every year is as easy as
that so take that while you can
thanks paula we appreciate all the work
that you and your team do thank you
um aquatic facilities matt
pages 272
to uh
83.
thank you uh the so the key issues for
us uh the just ongoing uncertainty
around covert um this budget was
prepared assuming that
based on the incoming traffic light
system that things would largely be
returned to normal however as you know
with new strains and variants um that
could have any number of different
impacts
and as with previous years any any
impact income will be offset against a
covert loan and reported to the council
for a council approval at time at the
time
we've got a three percent increase
across most fees and charges and uh
increase to staffing budgets happy to
take questions
questions
thank you matt
oh sorry
so matt just um your projections if
covert is ripe and we sort of have to
shut down or anything what that'll all
come out of the covered loan is that
correct
thank you
yes council duty
matt
with
the ongoing situation with oxford has
that settle down and have you do you
have to
do you need
any more ftes or anything like that or
you've got to
the the staffing issues um it hasn't
settled down it's if anything it's
continued um we've had more movement um
we've we've reached out to sarwin
christchurch to see if they have staff
they can lend us um we're we're coming
up with as many plans as we can to keep
keep it um keep it open and keep it
running to full capacity um we have seen
lower customer numbers just just through
covert and
red light settings and all of that but
i'm trying to make sure we can keep it
as as available to the community as we
can okay thank you
all right no further questions thank you
mash we
again um doing an excellent job there
with our pools and your team so thank
you
community development let's see if this
can be a role
come on come on forward
so that page is
so i don't want staff to think that we
haven't gone through these thoroughly
in fact there isn't questions but we
have had a process of
sending questions in advance we've done
a ton of briefings before this year's
budget so we're well versed so
in your hands tessa thank you
thank you um i will take the budgets as
read but just would like to highlight
some operational cost adjustments
these ensure that we can continue
mainstream community development
alongside the development and
facilitation of larger long-term
projects
and these have resulted from our ongoing
and increasing
need to respond and recover from
pandemic and disaster events across the
district and you you will be
aware of the impacts on the social
well-being of our residents
so this provision is necessary to see
our rapidly growing and evolving
district into the future
these adjustments also relate to
necessary salary adjustments and
alignment
to a line community team remuneration
with the recent council-wide strategic
pay review which you will be aware of
happy to take any questions
thank you any questions uh kirsten
sorry councillor barnum
and just following up tessa on the safer
communities question that i asked
we were saying that grants seem to be
not keeping pace with the costs that
we've got going forward is that going to
is that percentage going to keep
increasing or is that just a one-off for
this year
from ltp
page 291 of our budget grants okay in
the safe communities area
so um and in terms of grants
that is something we apply for as
required and you'll be aware that
in the last two years at least a lot of
our projects um have had to be modified
under the increasingly
online environment that we're operating
in
so our need to source external funding
for the project costs
associated with those has been less
okay
all right so any further questions
so thank you tessa and uh you heard what
i said before same implies um
tim are doing awesome work and good to
see some of them back here too rachel
and co with respect to the work that's
going on with the community hub so thank
you
all right um
grant come on up
green space
293 you're wearing a tie again today i
thought it was only tuesday
no it's hey it's a special week
missing the sheep toe the boat's on the
bench actually matt's got one on too
good
so it's chris so you don't normally see
him in the tire anyway sorry i'll i'll
i'll stop my obsession with the tire
carry on
so page uh two nine three two three
three seven
and we've we actually got some
we're going to deal with the community
hub
first
so that's actually
duncan and rachel so sorry so the
community hub um the money for that is
actually in the earthquake area so i
should
wait till then
it's been included under the community
and recreation okay that's fine let's
hold it off
um
well that doesn't matter if it's dealt
with here
we can deal with it yeah we can do it
now i just think we might as well deal
with it in order
to come forward rachel
thank you
so do you wish to speak to this report
rachel yeah just briefly yep i was just
checking which staff member was speaking
to that so
everyone got the report up there thank
you thanks rachel
the purpose of this report is to provide
an update on the progress and seek
additional budget allocation for the
development of the kivway community hub
the current council budget provision in
the
2012 year is not sufficient to enable
the development of the site based on
most recent cost estimates
the reasons for the increase and
benefits of the project were covered in
the briefing yesterday so happy to take
questions
thank you any questions
yep so hi duncan do you want to cover
anything
excellent uh moved by councillor
atkinson secretary councillor do you
wish to speak
look i think the briefing did draw out
the questions on the
in and the answers that we required
yesterday this is a very worthwhile
project and i'm looking forward to
removing here and well done to all those
that have worked on it
any further speakers
you wish to respond to yourself
it's right of reply i mean in other
words so all right i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried so that's
thank you rachel and duncan so the next
is uh on reports is the
rengara airfield so that's grant and
ryan
it's just just you grant just me thank
you
um
so i'll take the report mostly uh as
read i guess just a couple of the points
that we wanted to um
make there is really around the fact
that the water is uh now considered to
be a public supply hence why we've
proposed the structure of the water
as we have over the two years
we've also got in their
budget around resetting of the runway
this is probably the main area that we
actually get feedback and complaints
about
what's happened in between
the ltp and now is that we've had a
trial actually done by a grass scientist
and that's actually gone really well so
we'd like to look at doing some
resetting of the runway to occur
which will help us to actually kind of
front foot some of the discussion around
how we improve that surface so that's
why that's in there
the other one is the gates
at the moment we've got 22 23 gates on
the airfield
one of the things that we have been
instructed
over the last
few months just around safety and with
our safety officers standing down
caa are really keen to see us limit
access into the
operational airside
part of
of the aerodrome as well um and i
believe this has been raised adored and
risk as well um and the two councillors
that are on the um the portfolio group
have
raised this too so there's a
vulnerability there that we believe we
can manage by the installation of two
gates versus 22
and we can actually start to legitimise
the use of the aerodrome side of the
airfield as well
happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
councillor williams
yeah um with regards to the gates i know
it's quite important um
surely it should be just about a use of
pays for the gates considering we've
actually caught
people cutting the locks and the gates
so
i'm a wee bit concerned about putting in
these gates specifically for the people
here that's been
either too lazy to close gates
or
when we close them for them and put a
lock on them they cut them
surely we should be
i i personally don't i wonder what you
think that where the rate part should be
paying for
what
comes down to basically vandalism at the
airport when it's actually some of the
tenants that doing it
it's the first question
yeah that's a it's a good question um
council williams i guess one of the ways
that we're actually approaching trying
to put some enforcement and control
around that is through the lease that
we're putting in place with everyone
so the base lease that we're going to be
negotiating with each of the
leaseholders on in terms of renewing
would look to address that
we've also spoken directly with the
people who we believe have been
implicated in that
um the gates go beyond just kind of
controlling the behavior of one or two
tenants that are on the airfield it's
actually also about restricting the
access of the wider public as well
um at the minute we get some unfortunate
kind of access to it just in terms of
the fact that we've got the fuel there
so people need to get to it
but we've also got cars that are driving
over there that just do not need to be
there
that's also creating some buggy areas
and some other things around the
airfield we've got car movements we just
don't need there
look at us
we are managing an aerodrome
with that comes quite a responsibility
uh back to council offices in terms of
what we do to mitigate the risk there
this is actually quite a simple step
forward for us to mitigate quite a large
risk that we're currently carrying
the second question is about the cost of
the water and all this development there
apart from the
atc club which is a community
organisation which is really good and
probably the crack aircraft
a lot of those places are commercial
places
are the council looking at increasing
some funds they actually help pay for
this or the burden going to be fully on
to the ratepayers
sorry there's a delay on the button um
the majority of it's actually been done
through development contribution because
of the fact that this is a growth area
so
look what we're doing is because we've
been identified as a public water supply
we actually have to look at it as the
public has access to that water
the short answer is no
we haven't in the interim looked at okay
how does that cost only burden the
current users of the airfield
uh the only way that we could really do
that is to take
get field um reality is there's a lot
more people that utilize the airfield
than those tenants
um
it's just not something that we've
calculated at this point in time um
based on the fact that it's seen as a
district-wide asset and it's something
that
we see as a compliance matter
so will you bring a report to council
regards the
costs and running of the airport
reasonably soon if it's possible
yeah and look that's part of the what
we're getting the master plan to look at
as well with the amount of development
that we've got going on out there and
the rising expectation with it now being
designated
um
there's i guess an appetite from some
people to remain with the status quo
there's also quite a large appetite from
a lot of people that we're going to
become this
all being all seeing
general aviation airfield
we need to make sure that we find
whatever balance is correct for the
majority of users
there is going to definitely have to be
workshops
and a lot of feedback around the master
plan on what it is exactly that we're
willing to do as a council plus also
look at what it is that the general user
of the air field is wanting out of the
master plan as well so there is that
process there for that
as well
you'll be aware of the process that we
went through
a few years ago to set both the landing
fees and also the the lease fees as well
and we do have some different categories
of lease fees in there as well it wasn't
an easy process
it wasn't an easy process to do either
of those two
and if we do want to
embark on doing that again based on the
fact that there's additional cost being
paid for by the ratepayer for those
airfield assets
then it will be a long and difficult
process again that will take quite a lot
of staff time but also quite a lot of
community
input and counsellor involvement in that
process as well so not saying we don't
want to do it um just saying
that it isn't a short process
um
being on the committee as well is it
isn't it is it um
true that um
that we have found have you found
from tamaru's experience that when you
get a full-time part-time safety officer
designated to the airfield that a lot of
these problems
disappear and go away and are resolved
so that's not something that we've
actually specifically covered in this
report um
that'll come up in the commentary in the
community of creation
the answer is yes yes to to your
question yeah absolutely i'd just like
just the counsellors to understand
an example where they've had similar
issues with us over a long period of
time slightly different airfield of
course more complex but when they did
put resources into having a
airfield manager
they also have a separate safety officer
as well
the majority of the issues went away and
that's because they had someone on site
who was there to to manage these sorts
of things and um i i think it's worthy
to note isn't it um that we we're in in
the process of of of of uh master plan
right now
yes yes yes if you if you could confirm
that we are in the in the process with
the property developer there's a lot
happening and um it will all evolve
yes you can confirm that your statement
is correct
it will evolve appropriately very very
well framed here council award
excellent question councillor barnard
and blackie
you're fine
um mr mcleod
um i'm one of these counselors who very
much dislikes increases in the first
year of an annual plan
bearing in mind there are there are some
cost issues and other things but they do
seem to be quite a lot of budget items
have been added which potentially were
already
foreseen why wasn't the seating of the
runway put into the ltp and put through
as an ltp item
it's a it's a very fair question um
councillor barnett
because of when we were doing the trial
we originally thought we were going to
be able to do it at a later time um
our grass expert has come back now and
he's very firm in the fact that autumn
this year is the best time for us to
actually run that trial
had we foreseen that year we definitely
would have put this up sooner into the
ltp
we appreciate that it's a difficult
position that we're putting you in to
say we need to do this
some of the other issues are more
compliant that we didn't realize we
needed to do the water supply is
probably a good case in point for that
um the gate issue is something that's
really kind of come on in the last
couple of years
we possibly thought that we could have
addressed it more towards the end of the
master plan
with the acceleration of the development
next door and also with greater interest
i guess from
outside influences
just in terms of regulation for us
it's kind of becoming more and more
prevalent
we also feel that
i guess some of the liability that
actually sits with officers we kind of
need to bring this forward and actually
start to look at controlling access onto
the side sooner
but yes i take your point
these are things that we could have
foreshadowed prior to the annual plan
to add to that when we when we were
preparing the long-term plan we sat and
had discussions around
the airfield and around the things that
we needed to do there and the decision
was made to ask for the thirty thousand
dollars to be able to do the master plan
um we all knew that um if you do a
master plan it's likely that you're
gonna need to come back at a future ltp
to ask for some money to do for some uh
some development um so we had that
signed off and we started on the process
and then and then daniel smith um turned
up saying hey look i want to do this
this development we said wow we haven't
really anticipated um that as as part of
that thirty thousand dollars um and so
that's um uh sort of stirred the pot at
the airfield we also had the safety
officer leave as well and then i started
to identify some significant safety
issues which the safety officer um
i had been talking about for a long time
um and so now we've progressed with
daniel smith to a certain point where we
actually have a plan which has been
reviewed externally we know that these
things can be done and can be done now
and are going to be
significantly important from either a
level of service or health and safety
point of view for the airfield
and just sorry it's just subsequent to
that if i may um obviously very very
excited about the prospect of
development i think that's fantastic but
as we all know it often takes longer
than we expect how high has your level
of confidence will be delivered in the
22-23 year or needs these services in
the 22-23 year to provide for the
development
so the money that we're actually looking
at for next year is
really some of the engineering planning
and the the forward planning into that
it is a growth uh project which is being
dictated by a developer's timeline yes
um so as much as we can always have
confidence in what we're going to do
sometimes
it doesn't necessarily follow the
timeline that's required but we do
believe in this instance that there's
already action happening down there
there's already plan changes lodged
right we believe it's going ahead as
much as we can thank you
thank you
question council award
if it's not you can wait you can hold to
debate which is coming up shortly
if you've got a question that's fine
just pose it accordingly
do you know
that
it is it's come to my attention that
part of the gate problem has been a lack
of communication to the holders of the
leases at the airfield
and more more communication is really
required when any changes happen to
those people would you would you agree i
think is the point that's been probably
missed there
uh yes and no
right um we're certainly improving the
way that we communicate okay we're at
4.6 i'm going to move it from the chair
is eric is there a second
second accounts award can i just say i
think you guys are doing a fantastic job
meeting with
i think developers expectations
uh and then a community overlay uh
making sure that we're getting the right
outcome the master planning exercise the
work that's been done before
in terms of our
noise contours and all that work that we
did around the designation
um
and answered the council the barnett's
point um if it was up to the developer
this should have been done last year um
we will never move at the pace and i
have huge admiration for daniel smith
and what he does but he would like this
done and dusted so i think
from where our process is rest you guys
are working
at an extraordinary rate and the things
that you've put in here are much needed
and i fully support yes there's always
issues of timing but
i think you've answered those well this
is a a pr an absolute amazing asset in
our district we need to make sure that
we continue to invest in it but also see
the future potential which is through a
developer because there's huge
opportunity and people are really
excited about it so
i'm really fully supportive of what's
going on down here and thank you for the
work that you've done and bringing it
here
council award did you wish to speak
i see a huge potential i see huge
for our district and this is an
opportunity
that that doesn't come along and having
someone like daniel smith who who has
the finances that we don't have is go is
a huge asset in the fact that he's doing
the prize road
um and sealing it and he's going to make
a wonderful job of the whole development
and
with her
ownership of the airfield and the
opportunities of enlarging the um the
runways
the future is it could be really amazing
for ranger airfield
as a light aircraft destination for
engineering
tutorship and for
a stopover
for flights from the north island
through to queenstown wanaka
um as a base
um it's it's huge and i tell you what in
the next 10 or 15 years we'll be reaping
the rewards
thank you councilwoman did you wish to
speak yes
yeah no i think it's um we've got to
take this development by the um
the hand and lead it through because
it's going to be a good thing um long
term i
i do believe though we need to start
looking at trying to get some cost
recovery back because
really the whole airport is a commercial
concern apart from the
uh the crack club and the atc people
most in there so um the other one is
going to be benefit long term so there
needs to be a cost
return somehow on it so um we need to do
that i would actually hate to see
the um the runway get re-seeded and
sorted out
and then afterwards a trencher comes
along and put a trench across with a
sewer and water line so
i think we've got to be very mindful
that the
the water in the silver line goes in
first and and then the um service gets
reseeded and all that
so apart from that it's it'll be a good
asset for the community but i don't
think the ratepayer should be funding it
fully and we need to be mindful that
place should be turning to a break-even
situation rather than
rate pass funding it all the time
council
yes what's interesting to note that this
report is totally about the rate payer
funding it so um we are actually
approving quite a lot of extra
expenditure today to make the
investigation happen um but i i totally
accept i just wanted to clarify the
level of risk um the fact that there is
a single developer makes it brilliant um
because it does lower the risk for the
council
and
it's a developer with a track record so
who we work with so
i'm quite comfortable with how you've
set the budget up with a small proviso
when i looked at the overall community
recreation budget and i also factored in
the community and recreation projects in
the earthquake regeneration space it's
40 of our budget
and it's increasing and it's increased
from the long term plan quite
considerably
while those
projects are all totally valuable
we have committed to our community to a
long-term plan which said the budget
should basically stay similar for the
next three years with a few alterations
and changes
in this space i feel like there needs to
be a bit more prioritization of projects
so that this one is really important and
has to be done ahead of time something
else should be pushed back
so therefore i think we need to do that
in the community recreation exactly the
same way we've done and all the other
capital projects and i don't feel that
that's being done particularly well at
the moment
we seem to respond to
sometimes the loudest voices
and we need to get a little bit better
perhaps at prioritization in those
spaces it's very hard to turn down any
requests from the community
but going forward i do think we're going
to have to do that to keep our rates
manageable in this space
having said that the report i totally
totally support i'm excited about the
earthquake at the earthquake the airport
development um i hope my father can fly
in and see me at some point from nelson
and i
am very interested in hearing what's
going to happen in that space
but like councillor williams i do want
to see a bit of cost recovery if we can
but i know we have to do the initial and
we certainly have to do the water
we don't have a choice in that at all
so well done for bringing this to us
at this appropriate time i really do
appreciate the agility you've shown in
doing this we've we've always said we
want to be an agile council when it
comes to development and although we're
not as agile as the developer may like
this is actually quite fast-paced for us
to brought this forward so again thank
you for your work thank you to the
um the people involved in the airport
committee and i really really hope that
we see some exciting developments down
there very soon
thank you any further speakers
um i'm going to put the recommendation
all those in favor please say all right
contrary to clear that carry thank you
sorry did i hear
oh
sorry
i thought there was a latent uh no or
something or other so i just want to
make sure i got it right
okay so that's ring your airfield i
think that's all on the whites on the
budget surrounding the reports that you
had chris the sme
uh does that come under the green space
it is because the budget was transferred
it's item
4.7 page 144
on my oh yeah it's under dpnr yep so 143
to 147 so that's tab um tab 9.
thank you do you want to do you want
who's going to speak to them i'll speak
to that okay
um
so the purpose of this report is to
outline the need for existing um for the
existing rates growing up hundred
dollars per radial unit with a
significant natural area
um to be amended to improve its value
and equity at the moment 100 is given to
anyone who has an sna and whether that
sna is two square meters or um 200
hectares there's no difference between
all of that
um so to
better reflect um the fact that people
are essentially having pieces of their
land locked away without them being able
to do any development recognizing how
significant they are
we are proposing that we give 155
dollars per ratable
unit plus a 30 per hectare for
um and this
based on the currency we have in the
district plan would come to fifty
thousand
um and uh fifty dollars so that is an
increase we did have a budget of
approximately ten thousand uh exactly
ten thousand um two hundred
um
and uh so it's an increase of forty
thousand dollars the
um
uh
a couple of things to be aware of um
there are some scenarios which haven't
been identified at the moment and when
the national policy statement for
indigenous biodiversity is implemented
it's likely we will have to identify
those specifically in our district plan
which will increase the number of smas
we have
and therefore
we would require more money
in this budget to be able to offset
those rates
there were many many different ways we
could cut this we tried to get
a balance between affordability
um for council moving up to fifty
thousand dollars and also something
which was
um uh significant enough for people to
feel like they were actually getting
some benefit in having that sna by
having a meaningful reduction
in their rates i'm happy to take any
questions
thanks chris i see tracy has joined the
meeting tracy do you want to join
anything to this report on ec nas
okay thank you so um questions
it's pretty straightforward we've you
have to move uh counselor bar that's
moving seconded by uh council stuart do
you wish to speak just very briefly it
was discussed that length and dpr we
thought it was really really important
to acknowledge the landowners who are
contributing to snas in our district and
that the rate was way too low so this is
something i 100 support needs to go back
into the budget
thank you council stuart
i endorse what my colleague has said
i think it's really important
to follow up um what
the
concept one more than the concept that
these areas of significant natural
indigenous vegetation
are dwindling in front of our eyes and
we really need to put a value on them to
the property owner who
who is effectively
as chris says not
developing them
and preserving them for
the long term environmental and public
good
and we need to acknowledge as accounts
on behalf of the community that these
are in fact assets to the community
and
increase
um the public what is a public grant
through a rate remission
to these landowners
and i would like to see it increase
uh in the future and sort of
echo that this only deals with what is
on in the draft district plan and we
will
have some more
to come
thank you thank you further speakers
do you wish to respond at all council
the ballot
i'm going to put the recommendation all
those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thank you
so now we come to the green space
pages uh pages 293
is there anything you'd like to cover in
here well sorry
your commentary grant would be
appreciated
uh yeah thank you uh
thank you there then um
look i think we've covered a few of the
main points there just in the
discussion that we've had previously
just through the last couple of reports
i guess one of the things that i would
like to just draw your attention to is
the increase in vandalism across the
district
there's been a few questions just around
that in terms of how we can
address this or is there something that
we're maybe missing that we're not quite
doing
um
we've actually found that
i guess post
some of the issues that we've had over
the last few years we're actually
starting to see quite an increase in
vandalism especially around some of our
dormant
assets and what i would say there is
that it's really around public toilets
and a few other things
people seem to be getting into the habit
of
i guess just kind of
not doing a little bit of damage but
actually doing quite significant
vandalism to the assets that we're
putting out there for the general public
um
it's a real shame it's something that
we're keen to work with tessa's team on
how we might redress that
and also working with the local police
as well so a couple of things that we've
got on the cards that will help with
that are the likes of the security
network camera plan
plus also some of the work that we're
going to end up doing through
with tess's team's
guidance because
you know when social issues occur that's
the team that we lean on to to get some
really good intel as to how we might
approach that
um
that's probably one of the more
significant areas that we are seeing
some costs and the sad thing is we're
not improving assets by spending that
money
it's actually just responding to things
that people have decided to do in the
public realm
it's certainly not ideal and not
something that we hope continues but it
is something that we're having to
address
so look i'm i'm happy to take any
questions that you might have
thank you questions
council williams
yes um with the pegasus lease for our
community service
is it
viable have we looked into a viable um
situation of actually buying that whole
block because the lease cost would
probably just about and my thoughts um
cover that we get an income from the um
shoppers um you know the retail
activities as well
have we yeah we have um we've been
approached by templeton over
um a number of years um where they've
asked us to have a look at purchasing
the building um we've explored um what
that purchase price might look like
versus what we could do elsewhere and
we've also looked at the viability of
the tenants in the building the market
in terms of attracting tenants to that
building
noting that we are the only long-term
tenant in the building everyone else is
on a month by month lease and also
if we purchase the building what we
would have to do to bring it up to a
standard that would be suitable for a
community facility
things like the fact that it doesn't
have a lift to get upstairs et cetera et
cetera
subsequently templeton group are
actually doing some work on the building
themselves and it isn't on the market so
it's not available for us now but the
purchase price was never suitable based
on all those other
factors that we had to consider as well
we have
been working
with templeton on
where we may be able to secure land and
then build our own building um so that
we can have and that money is in the
long term plan um and we would like that
to progress as fast as possible so we
don't have to keep paying this lease fee
and we can start to have a loan of our
of our own and service that loan which
is
likely to be cheaper
thank you for the questions council
thank you in the report on page 297
it says
under the south brook sports club grant
it says a report will be provided to
elected members where is the report
uh so that's actually going to be coming
as a staff submission um councillor
barnett we briefly talked about it at
cnr last year we received the report in
december yeah
we got the report in december it's
actually relatively comprehensive and
it's a good report in terms of offering
us some guidance and direction
what we would like to do is actually
kind of summarize that into a report to
put in front of counsellors so that you
can
appreciate
where we might need to head to with that
so are you looking at taking this budget
out at this point well because we
haven't had
from the long term from the annual plan
and adding it back adding it back after
we've seen the report
no we're not proposing to take that out
regardless of what happens you're
putting it in at extra it's extra to
that launching plan regardless of what
happens um
the report which we've seen
isn't going to solve any of the issues
in regards to the south brook sports
club being able to pay their operational
charges over the next financial year so
when we bring that report back
we'll be recommending
in line with what we've put into the
annual plan that we cover those
operational costs as we have done in
previous years we won't be able to to
move the club we won't be able to get
them any additional funding to support
themselves operationally um between
um now and the end of the next financial
year so that's why we've lifted it now
and we'll bring that report back to
council as a staff submission if council
choose based on that report to remove it
at that time then um that then that
would be what council can do this has
come to us several several times and
every time it's been said it was the
final year that it would come
and that other solutions would be looked
at
why would we include it at this point
when we haven't seen any information to
clarify what
what the council position is on this
report um
because you are right it has come many
times to council it's not an easy
problem to solve for the south brook
sports club
they're in a situation where um
and i've mentioned this in previous
annual plan and long-term plan
discussions as well um uh if if there
isn't a solution um then they're in a
position where they would have to um
close as a club and transfer the assets
that they have to council
if they were to do that
then
we'd be in a worse financial position
then having to own and look after the
building
ourselves
so that needs to obviously be considered
the report which has been done looks at
lots of different options and it is a
very comprehensive report
but the results of that report
regardless of what option council uh
chooses um is not going to solve the
issue for the south brook sports club in
the short term
so there will still be a need for them
to have operational support from the
council if we don't give that
operational support
then like i mentioned previously they
may be in a position where they have to
hand over those assets to the council
which is what we're trying to avoid
so are there other sports clubs in this
situation or the other sports club
needing our assistance at this point and
have they been considered
there's lots of different sports clubs
which um
are in various um different positions we
continuously look like the gymnastics
club for example yeah we we continuously
work with various different clubs
throughout the district to look at their
needs
you know ice trampolining and the
purchase of the edward street building
tennis where the council's put money
into that um the the kaikui croquet club
um the rengar koko i could keep going
and keep going and and and we do a
sports facilities plan um which uh
informed us for the long-term plan about
where council would be sensible to spend
their money to be able to make sure that
the sports clubs in our district are
able to be um
uh sustainable long term to make sure
that they can provide um services and
assets for for our community um south
brook sports club um is is one of our
probably they're probably on the highest
cliff
closest to the edge of it
compared to a number of other sports
clubs that we have
we always
work with the likes of sports canterbury
first to try and build capacity within
the sports clubs
and we look at external funders to help
them as well
so we do that with all clubs and there
are some other clubs um who are
struggling as well and we work with them
very closely okay that's very it's a
different different topic mr mayor if
that's right one because there's quite a
lot in this report of increases um the
rangiara town hall centre which we
discussed yesterday
um
given what i said about the
prioritization and the fact that with
covert less and less people are going to
the cinema
would it not be prudent to actually push
this out for one year until we're aware
of the
the trends that are going to happen in
the next financial year
um
andy's here if he wants to if you want
do you want andy to just oh i can start
if any has anything to add then um
we've received um information which has
been circulated to councils i believe
regarding the um projections for
um the rengar town hall it was put in
it's in diligent it's blank oh okay
sorry so we haven't seen it okay well
what we resolved yesterday was that that
was to be
manager of climate change
and and cnr to to consider that
and to report back to us so very
effectively it's putting a holding item
in our budget but it will come back to
us
um around uh whether they're sustainable
or it's feasible uh from the financial
projections of the i didn't realize that
that hadn't been an update and now sorry
mr me the the motion actually said
council would consider it council would
consider it not seeing that today
the motion was counted
double check what that is
between the report yesterday and today
me and jeff haven't had the opportunity
to sit down and actually do that as you
can
as you can imagine
um yeah i mean
absolutely happy to do that with jeff
and leave this one sitting there for
another time um i have had a good look
through it um it's very difficult for
uh for me um not being a cinema expert
um to actually um
uh anticipate what um cinema
what how many bums are gonna be able to
put on seats they've expected a 10
percent
increase in their financial forecasting
but the experts are saying that it will
be a 10 20 increase and the reasons for
that are not necessarily covert related
but more that there's a huge backlog of
blockbuster films which have been
created in america that haven't come out
for a number of years they're expecting
that in the later part of this year
they're all going to come out
and people are making films in the rest
of the country where lockdown provisions
are a whole lot less than
they are at the moment the main issue
that they've had over the last couple
years other than lockdowns where you
just cannot go in the building is their
content they just haven't had a lot of
content
that content is coming on board so
that's based that that feeds into those
projections but i'm not
i have to go on the figures which have
been put there and the advice um that
they have given to us at the end of the
day when the the financial information
they provided us was very very i wasn't
expecting they've literally
listed every single thing that they
purchase and how much they pay their
staff and
how much they make through food and
beverage and absolutely everything
they've been very very open and what it
shows is that
on a good year they make a good profit
yes they do they make a very good profit
which means that they do have wriggle
room to make sure that even in the bad
years they can still actually pay us the
additional lease fee that they should be
paying us so
i have confidence that they they still
should be able to pay that lease fee
which we have
[Music]
been flexible on over the last two years
but i believe they should be able to pay
that going forward but you're absolutely
right i can't say that as a fact because
we don't know
what covert is going to bring in the
future so chris just to move this
forward
with a staff report coming to our tweet
to our meeting on the 22nd where we
adopt this to go out to
to the public would you be able to have
completed that in time for that yes
so um uh is our colleagues happy to
leave this in here for the for this
for the moment
noting that it will come back as a on
the 22nd of february and if we choose to
remove it at that point for whatever
reason we can do that unfortunately i'm
an apology on the 22nd okay well we can
get you briefed beforehand if
if you're comfortable with that
direction are you comfortable with that
direction counselor
i'm actually not because really this
should have been discussed before today
and it should have come to us a lot
earlier so that we could have read it as
a report okay as a council
okay well
if we make sure you're briefed before
the 22nd and your views can be taken
into account it's just that it's sitting
in here as a line item now the other
alternative is it's just removed all
together um but i
if it's coming back on the 22nd um
there's an opportunity to to address
that at that point without it being
removed yeah i'm just looking for a new
testament
further questions councilor williams
followed by council duty
um i'll go back to the south brook
sports club operating grant
have we actually and it's coming year
after year
we'll pay the insurance and bits and
pieces in albuquerque
and i know people have been wanting to
rent that building for different
community events and what have you and
they've been turned down
what would the response if the council
did end up taking it over
so we could actually utilize it and
actually
get some income from it which the
present people aren't don't seem to be
getting the um i think they'd be
delighted
and that's what i mean have we actually
explored that situation could we run it
better than what it has been now
efficiently
i could go into quite a detailed answer
but the report actually identifies that
we will bring back and prior to the
senior plan being
signed off
it identifies the income they get it
identifies the groups that are currently
using the building but it also
identifies the issues with the building
in terms of it not being multi-purpose
and not being able to actually provide
for some groups they have to go and
light the fire two hours before a group
actually comes just to get the building
up to temperature um you know that does
restrict um with the lack of volunteers
that have the number of people who they
can actually have using the building
just quickly the other thing is
we would have to align that building if
we owned it with our other community
facility fees and charges
we are the cheapest community facility
people on the market
so
all the clubs that use the building at
the moment will be absolutely wrapped
because they'll get a significant
discount
and we're unlikely to be able to fill it
um to actually make as much money as
south brook makes on the building at the
moment because of those fees and charges
that we
have which are very very low for the
community for for many
reasons
okay
further questions
sorry council duty
just going back to the the cinema
if um
we decide not to
do the
the seating upgrade are they likely to
walk away
it's it's difficult to say but i think
what we are doing is hindering their
productivity i think we've got to
recognize that the the theater 3 does
need to be improved um they sell every
second seat and they discount adults by
two dollars and they discount some of
the older children by a dollar
so we do have to recognize that we're
holding their ability back to to to to
generate an income um
i recognize that obviously 150 000 isn't
favored at this point in time but um i
do believe that during the lull of this
this period of this year
we should get ourselves ready for what
will be uh effectively a boom later on
in the latter part of the year and then
there will be we will probably be likely
to be criticized by them coming back to
us saying we've got all these box office
tickets to sell and we can't sell them
thank you very much for your honesty
it's good thank you is there any further
questions but i'm happy at the end of
each of these if there's some general
comments members wish to make
within reason you're welcome to make
those because we did do a catch-all at
the start so and i appreciate these
views there so if anyone wishes to that
i'm trying to keep us moving along but
if you'd like to i'm more than happy to
accommodate that
general comments um
about the green space budget
uh we finished with questions yes
yes um
please don't think that i don't think
any any of these projects are worthwhile
i think every single project is
worthwhile and i would love to say yes
to absolutely everything but we just
don't have a limited checkbook i i don't
think so
unlimited i'd love to have an unlimited
checkbook um
i i've just looked at the
the creep in this budget
past ltp second year i expect quite a
few increases but first year i expect it
to stay pretty much close and a lot of
the other budgets have apart from things
like interest rates and um shovel ready
projects and those sorts of things um
and unexpected developments but this is
a little capital project that's a great
idea but it doesn't have to be done in
2022-23 necessarily it could be done the
following year could be brought to us
with a more comprehensive report so that
we can see it um it i i totally
understand that you're trying to be
flexible and everything but what i was
trying to do was to try to compensate
for some of that extra expenditure we're
spending on the airfield to try and see
if there's something else we could save
somewhere else so please don't take any
of my comments as a criticism i love the
idea i love going to the cinema i
support town hall cinemas but to be
frank i'm not keen to sit in a room with
a hundred people at the moment
and probably won't be for the rest of
the year
and a lot of other people are feeling
that way and cafes cinemas uh
restaurants are all seeing this downturn
because of that perception even if
covert does disappears and the tail
starts to calm down
i think there'll still be some
hesitation for people to go back and
there's been a huge influ increase in
netflix subscriptions in neon and apple
and in 101 different things that people
can watch at home and people have set up
all their homes theaters now so i'm a
little bit nervous about this projection
of increased income for the cinema
industry until we see some clarity over
the covet situation and people's
expectations of returning back to those
closed environments
i'm good i'm going to support these
items remaining and i do want further
explanation on on to come back once our
staff have looked at those particularly
with regards to the cinema but i i've
spent time with andy he's briefed our
account our community
community recreation committee i was one
that wasn't immediately in favor of that
expenditure as you know because i like
the flexibility
of that facility but i listened to the
argument that was put forward
and also the feedback that's been coming
from users which don't like the current
seating in fact it's actually
preventing them from using
that facility it's also when the
analysis comes back i understand it's
almost an in and out and that's what we
just need to make sure that the business
model uh aligns with that
so that has that changed my opinion also
talking to andy went and talked to julia
holcroft who was very much
in fact well she was a very strong um
person that got us that face that
proposed that facility in the first
place and julia supported uh that change
in seating so with south brook
southbrook
it's a really difficult situation there
i think we do need to keep that budget
in there because we will end up taking
responsibility otherwise they're in
they're in a really difficult financial
position the feasibility study has been
done and yes we need to have that back
here and consider that but it's this
chris is rightly observed it's not going
to have the silver lining we might hope
for but we've got to work with that club
and give them hope we do not want to
lose that committee that's there because
they're the only hope they've got at the
moment if they walk away we're left with
it so
in its entirety so let's that'll come
back to us in time for the 22nd and we
can consider that further it is a big
budget but we've got big expectations in
our community our communities are around
home now
people aren't traveling so i do support
where we're heading with this we've
always got to look for savings and
opportunities and i know our staff are
looking
through those but they're also proposing
those to us if we don't like them we can
take them out
at the present time i'd like to hear
what our community has to say when it
goes out then we can make that decision
after we've had submissions
council atkinson
actually was your last point that i was
going to comment on this needs to go out
to the public for for conversation and
that's why i'm for uh
for for leaving it in there i mean if we
take the example of christchurch every
cinema in christchurch is struggling big
time but the reason that they have
the bigger theaters in there so that you
can have social distancing they can at
least keep a business going by social
distance in between unfortunately when
you've got a a movie theater that takes
28 people
cutting that in half to 12 doesn't come
close to buying the fish and chips for
the week
so
um
i'm not a fan i i like dan like the
flexibility of that that particular
space in the town hall and
you know i mean it was built for that
purpose however
i mean if it means that we've got an
entertainment business that needs to
survive in our district then we need to
try and do whatever we can to make sure
that the doors are kept open however
let's see what the community has to say
on the uh on the budget when it goes out
so i'm not actually frightened of it
being in there i'm
not particularly worried about the
report coming back beforehand just put
in the budget get it out there and see
what people have to say about it
williams
yeah i'm not quite so concerned about
the theatre because i think that's
actually going to be a cost recovery
situation so it's not going to be there
but
i do agree with councillor barnett
the costs are getting out of control
and i don't think the rate parts
can afford all these extra costs and
some of these things are really good to
have
are they necessary is the other big
thing and we need to cut our cloth
accordingly um i'll go to one thing
which i actually would like to happen
and it's going to happen is milton
reserve
but there's a flow-on effect when we do
these upgrades and all that there on the
maintenance for years to come after that
um so we've got to be quite
um concerned that the cost of the rate
powers could get out of hand and this is
probably
one of the biggest budgets it's actually
i think it's actually spiraling out of
control with your um costly expectations
for the rate cars
really good projects most of them if not
all of them but it's a concern because
somebody's got to pay for it and
unfortunately it goes back to the rate
power so um
and there's some of these really good
projects have got a maintenance
following on aspect to it for
for the next for my grandchildren etc so
we just need to be careful
i think we all need to be a little bit
um cognizant of the fact that we're a
growth
district council
and appears that the
some of the costs may be growing but our
income is growing as well and we're in a
transition where we're having to give
and provide and create
additional services to meet the growth
demand
and that comes it you have to invest to
get return at the end especially when we
want people to come and live in our
district and to have a wonderful
lifestyle so you just don't stop you
have to provide and that all comes at
the initiating and as the growth stage
it comes at a cost
and so you have to balance out
the growth that we have experiencing
and the rewards that we will get but you
have to invest
so that you can
keep the well-being and you can keep
your community
in good heart
thank you
no further no further contributions rob
you know my observation over the years
is green space is an easy target and
the council awards quite right we're a
growth district there are high
expectations
we've got breeding contractors we've had
reports on on our brilliant con but
their costs are going up there's a whole
lot of things in this field that's it's
inevitable it goes up
and just touching very briefly on on
south brook i don't like having to
put that money in there
um i only got the report to read late
friday afternoon
um it's a three-hour read it's one of
the more comprehensive reports of of
redone as far as a community facility
other than the likes of the stadium is
concerned but a very comprehensive
report um it's coming back to us it may
be slightly abbreviated but there's
nothing in there that's that's secret
it's just that it took me three hours or
just under three hours to fully absorb
that report on sunday
it's very comprehensive and in the
meantime while we make decisions with
regard to the future of that facility
um unfortunately we're gonna have to
hold them up otherwise we we get the
blooming thing but yeah green space has
always been an easy target but people
expect
nice tidy green space
and look at that vandalism i don't want
to go into that
okay all right
we've had a good um some good it's it's
been good discussion it's a it's a very
comprehensive budget thank you grant and
team for that
so we'll take that off
this point
thank you um
come to your overheads this is where we
could make some real savings guys
just kidding chris
uh page uh 338-346
so
main drivers for increases in this
budget are um three positions um the
parks officer the airfield officer and
the biodiversity officer
um i've identified those and given a
reasonably um
succinct
couple of paragraphs around the need and
the driver for each of those the parks
officer is is primarily
to ensure that we can continue with our
levels of service in the district
um uh
we're getting a lot more people and
we're obviously having a lot more parks
and reserves that are being created and
all coming on board it's difficult to
know exactly when the parks and reserves
come on board because of the different
timing associated with different
developments um but we're at a point now
where
our
service quests have gone
significantly upwards and the team is
struggling significantly to maintain
levels of service
and actually provide for the community
the airfield officer um i think my words
in there speak for themselves um
it's
it's a huge risk for the council at the
moment um
and we have a lot of development um
which is likely to occur ncaa
legislation
which
in the in the near future is going to
mean that we are going to have to manage
that airfield in a slightly different
way we don't have that resource there at
the moment and the biodiversity officer
this is in response to the national
policy statement for indigenous
biodiversity
if we were to
identify a budget for
what we are likely to have to do in the
first year to implement
that policy statement we would need
about 220
um so we we haven't done that um because
that's quite a significant portion of
money we believe that um an internal
resource to be able to um respond to the
national policy statement um is the
better way of doing that based on the
uncertainty of exactly when it's going
to be put in place
and
then exactly what it's going to be
what's going to be in it in terms of
requirements for council so i'm happy to
take any questions on
that
thanks chris can i just say that um your
papers and your team's papers
have been absolutely superior and just
looking back on my notes that i i was
going through this it's been really
excellent particularly
the summaries here and the
justifications for those new roles
it's been really well put so
just wanted to pass it on because i
think it really does justify my opinion
the investment so i fully support what
you're recommending here
questions council becky
williams the airport officer um up until
now it's been grant is that correct can
you tell us what what part of fte has
that has been allocated to that
first question and second question
looking at employing another officer are
you talking fte or what proportion and
how are you going to allocate um or have
you addressed allocation of of response
financial responsibility for that thing
from council as opposed to the airfield
entity
uh so the airfield officers will be
broken up um at the moment we have 20
something thousand dollars in the budget
for an airfield safety officer so we
would look to bring that
into one so that the person we employ
becomes our airfield safety officer but
also our airfield manager um to utilize
that funding um hopefully we can we can
do that um as a proportion of um what
what was was craig's job he looked after
the field himself and now grant's job as
the airfield manager
i couldn't tell you
exactly what proportion of the job is
identified for that what i can say is
it's significantly more year on year
with the development with the caa
regulations with more people being at
the airfield um
it is taking a significant amount of
time at the moment a lot of that is
actually shared between grant reboon and
grant mcleod where grant reuben does the
operational stuff in terms of the grass
mowing and all the complaints that we
have around
those who are trying to irrigate and
those who are trying to save water et
cetera et cetera
taking this out of grant rieben's role
and out of grant mcleod's role um is
going to allow them to focus on other
things that they need to focus on at the
moment and ensure that they do the 40
hours a week that they're paid to do as
opposed to
more that they currently do
further questions
council williams
whilst i think it's be a good idea to
have an aircraft manager there
is the consideration talking about the
available time
the two grants will have extra now when
they won't have the airport on their
backs considering
other positions here um
because
i know these three people turn up to the
um
the meetings we have and i know grant
reburn puts a heck of a lot of time in
there and i know grant puts a lot of
time in there as well so surely that's
probably just about one full person
that's going to get freed up
when you do get that
manager job so has that been
that's good it's a good question
yeah it's a good question um so all of
those meetings which grant and grant go
to at the moment um they they still do a
40-hour week
um so those meetings that they go to are
over and above that um or most of the
airfield stuff they do is over and above
what they actually do at the moment so
as that keeps rising and rising and
rising that falls on on grant and grant
to just continually do more and more and
more
there is a real issue with them doing
more and more and more because it gets
to a certain point where they leave
um
and that and at the moment in our
current market um they're not easily
replaceable either
um and so that that's something that i
have to consider when looking at
staffing is how much work they are doing
now
and protecting them to make sure that
they actually have a good work-life
balance and with more and more happening
at the airfield from caa from the
developer from a safety and risk point
of view that's putting a lot of pressure
on those two staff members so yes it
will free them up it'll free them up to
make sure that we retain them but that
we also
have an increase in the amount that
happens at the airfield as well they're
not doing at the moment what i would
consider
enough to be able to
manage the risk that we have at the
airfield in the appropriate way
i can't rely on them to do any more
because they're already doing more than
they should
oh no it wasn't meaning for them to do
more what i'm saying there must be
certain current money in the existing
budget
paying for those staff to do those
things now that can get transferred to
the new
so i'd say that they're just doing over
and above what they should be doing
i know i know myself in dealing with
those staff how how hard they work
and getting responses turned around
that's it's difficult so
um
you know it's
they're particularly hard-working staff
members so that is kind of that's why
that's why this is really important what
chris has presented here today mr mia i
never said that not hard
i know that
i'm just passing on my observation and
that um tell us about it
i think you know what i'm going to ask
chris why wasn't this 300 000 in the ltp
additional 300 000
um
some of these oppositions which have
been identified in the past
and they haven't
crossed the line so what happens is we
we sit down as a management team and
look at the positions overall and
prioritize those positions to make sure
that what we're putting up is going to
be affordable within the envelope the
council is going to accept there has
been
changes
in the operational
side of delta and the community and the
way that they're using their parks and
reserves and you'll note that that's
reflected in the increase in vandalism
the increase in service requests so
that's become an issue which wasn't
identified at the long term plan and
and look it's it's it's
we're going to do everything we can
to try and look for alternative ways to
to actually
limit that sort of thing but at the
moment again i can't rely on the same
staff members to do 20 30 more service
quests and
try and keep the community as happy as
they are at the moment it's just
impossible
they do a wonderful job but they can
only do it to a certain point so that's
the the parks officer the airfield
officer um again we've
reached a point where the significance
of the airfield um is almost at 50 000
landings
once it reaches 50 000 90s i think we're
at
47 000 landings um caas start to lift
their head and go oh
you're an airfield but now we want to
come into an order and actually make
sure that you've got gates in the right
place to make sure that your ear side
and your non-inside are actually
protected where's your your safety plan
your operational
um procedures for your airfield etc etc
it's got to the point where we can't
manage it in a way had we not had any
development had growth in this district
not
progressed um as fast as we thought it
was remembering of course we've had uh i
don't know how many extra properties in
the district it's moving a whole lot
faster than we'd anticipated
and with all of that movement
it just means that this is um when
management teams sat down to look at the
different positions jumped up the list
because we've got a risk sitting there
that we need to address the biodiversity
officer national policy statement for
indigenous biodiversity has been sitting
there
we know that we need to respond to that
we know what the cost to respond to that
is and we believe that this is the best
way to do that in the past we'd had
money within the district plan
to look at consultants being able to do
this like wildlands
and uh this is a cheaper way of actually
making sure that the additional
significant natural areas that we are
still going to have to go out and assess
on site um are able to be done and
should cost us less money than getting
that consultant work through the
district plan
to do that so you mentioned a figure of
220k because i'll note that the mps for
indigenous biodiversity was before the
ltp it was it was part of the eltp
discussion so where's the 220 or 200 so
we've done we did an assessment a couple
of months ago to identify what it's
likely um to cost us to be able to
implement what's in the national policy
statement remember the national policy
statement hasn't been uh you know it's
not
fully finished yet
and they could still make some changes
to it um and at the time the ltp was
prepared we were even less sure as to
the time frames around
what was going to be there we were also
less sure
at the ltp time as we were going through
the district plan how many snas we
actually had out there which hadn't been
assessed as well so we've got that
information now and kate steele has put
that together um and and it's come out
at 220 if we want to do everything that
we're being asked to do i think this is
a better way of doing it and is more
affordable council we'll get better bang
for our buck having this internal staff
member than we would by going out to
consultants and getting the information
this is a lot around
two additional things not just
assessment but you actually have to
build relationships with people
who own these sna's we also are going to
be um
legislatively required um to ensure that
naitu ahudi is brought along on the
journey when um consulting with
everybody around their snas as well so
we don't have the capacity
all the knowledge with the current staff
members we have to bring in that teal
maori view into the sna's at the moment
so we would have to go out and get
specialist help from both wildlands and
then someone else to guide us on
that cultural element as well so
just a question for mr harland actually
relating to the biodiversity space
we've got biodiversity people experience
across unr and cnr
is there would it be perhaps recommended
at some point to try and
work out
overall what is our priority in that
space and where we allocate resource
when it's between two departments
because it seems to be getting a little
confused
i think the key to answer that question
is our biodiversity strategy and our
sustainability approach and that does
pick up a number of departments so simon
hart
is not here but he's the new manager
we'll be pulling together a review of
all of our strategies and where the gaps
are and that'll be part of our thinking
to to ensure that we are aligned across
the departments
just the comment i've got is in the last
three years we've been asked to put on
three extra or half positions and then
an extra position and now we're asking
for another extra position and it kind
of hasn't been signaled that that much
resource would be put into the budget
is that going to improve going forward
well well i hope so but it comes back to
individual requirements as well and some
of that is national work and we don't
know about that so we have to respond
when we
when we get another commitment so
uh first
further questions
sorry council reckinson i just want to
make sure that um if
chris when hiring new staff if you could
just make sure they're named grant
please because it's a lot easier we're
dealing with your department with the
grants you have
[Laughter]
and they have good taste and tires yes
all right
okay
that's um
there's no further questions is there
any general comments anyone wants to
make
thanks chris that sure
overheads excellent as i said at the
start excellent work thank you
um
we've now just come to earthquake
recovery in regen so that's chris and
duncan
good afternoon um perhaps the main
things to note um in the budget and
commentary just regard to regeneration
there's been a slight change to
operational costs just with regard to
staffing
the proposal was to also
employ the current fixed term landscape
architect for a further year as you
probably know we actually lost our
landscape architect from the team
towards the end of last year so proposal
was to
extend that term for a further year
however the overall operational costs
for the year um still reduce with the
other changes
other than that from a capital project's
point of view
the only significant change was the
additional budget for the community hub
that you just considered before so
thanks duncan
any questions
counts about it
again just a general question for the
chief executive if i may um just
wondering with the
earthquake regeneration
budget now becoming predominantly green
space
when are we actually or community
enrique when are we looking at folding
this budget back into business as usual
and prioritizing it accordingly
probably an answer for jeff
a question for jeff i should say
just notice that predominantly most of
the projects fall under community
recreation now um we've done most of the
roading draining drainage stormwater
those sort of projects a lot of those
have been done
i was asking when is the right
why wouldn't we be
bringing this back into business as
usual under green space
combining resources
and then prioritizing the projects
in green space
accordingly through me
um
so we have started to do that and there
are less staff in this area than there
used to be and some of those staff have
moved across into the operational
budgets of the green space area there's
still some uh
projects which are primarily primarily
um delivered through the regeneration
plan still the likes of mahing kai
at the moment in the budget we've got
what essentially becomes duncan's
operational code running out until
the end of the 10-year period however
our intention would be um
that's absolutely going to be needed
until the next long-term plan
but at that stage we'd be looking at
coming back and providing
council with a report that looked to
incorporate most of that into the green
space area because most of the projects
then will be either well underway um
especially mahangakai which is probably
one of the larger ones which is still
sitting there but others will be
complete such as the boat ramp um
car park etc
so for the long term plan we'd be
looking to come back and let councillors
know what we're going to do there
i think
okay thank you um any further questions
any general remarks you'd like to say
something or is another question
councilman i'd like to say something for
sure sure um so just because i won't be
here on the 22nd i do would like to make
a comment in this space because i have a
bit of concern um going forward
about the prioritization of projects in
community and recreation
and
we've got a very big growing area in
pegasus it's very soon going to rival
the amount of population in kaiapoi and
they have far less amenity and
facilities than the kaiapoi area does
and yet we have not very much some
things but not very much in that space
to improve the amenity in the short term
for that very large population area
i would really like to see that we
operate our budgets as a one district
very much so and that all the
prioritization is therefore fed into
where is the biggest need where is the
biggest need for for meeting spaces for
parks for recreation facilities and so
on um i've abs it's been 12 years since
the earthquake and i kind of i sort of
expected things to be a little faster
but i think we've had a whole lot of
reasons for that um but we were always
promised that the the regeneration would
sort of tail off and i know there's a
lot of very significant projects in
there however if you measure it up
against the need in the living pegasus
area in particular and perhaps even in
the rural areas there is actually need
across the whole district that could be
greater than some of these projects and
i really would like to see a look at a
strategic um prioritization of community
recreation across the whole district in
the same way that is done in the the
three waters in roading and in other
areas at the moment i still feel like
we've we're really putting
kaiapoi in a bucket and we treat it
completely differently from the rest of
the district when actually kaipu is
looking fantastic has fantastic
facilities um it's it's a pleasure to go
there there's still more work to be done
but that could doesn't have to be done
straight away it can be done as we go
along depending on where the need is in
the district i'm really concerned that
woody and pegasus has missed out in this
lottery and unfortunately we're starting
to hear more complaints from that area
and as the population grows in that area
it's going to get louder and i would
really like to make sure we start to
look at an overall so i would really
like to see that this budget as you say
gets melded into the whole budgets and
the earthquake recovery we never have
enough money we never have enough money
to keep rates in an acceptable level so
we have to prioritize and i'd like to
see prioritization done as to where we
have the greatest need
go to say that i realize you've held
that view councilman for some time and i
appreciate where you're coming from but
we've actually put significant budget
into the wooden pegasus area
we've
working with
those respective communities we've put
in significant money for land and build
community facilities which we signaled
in our long-term plan so
that's there with kaipui
in rengura
and all across our district things do
get prioritised we still
require the regeneration budget to sit
where it is there will come a time when
it's when we're ready for that to
perhaps come back in but i'd like to
wait for our staff to give some further
reflection and advice to us when is the
right time i understand what you're
saying with that but i i'm personally
very comfortable with our present
position
and
regeneration that's been an important um
uh
signal that we sent to our community
that was badly damaged
um was far worse damage than proportion
anywhere else at the time
and we've done that work and we've sent
that signal really importantly and our
community have appreciated that
leadership that this council has shown
through that time and continues to do so
so when the time's right there'll be a
conversation here but at the moment i'm
presently comfortable with where we're
heading there council atkinson
yeah look i i want to reiterate that i
was one of these people i went to uh
to the mayor at the just
just before
uh the last election you went to me and
then um
end to end to uh david ears at the time
and said well when are we gonna wrap
this up i had conversations with uh with
al about that
i think what jeff has just described as
the natural progression of wrapping it
up
as it comes as projects are completed it
goes back into a wrap up because it goes
into the ba you and and that's important
that it does that i don't think anyone
has got any less priority over kayapoy
apart from in the initial stages we had
a regeneration plan which we spent a
million dollars on with the government
to make sure
that
that we would get on and do things we
have done exactly that
and it took something like four or five
years to get ourselves going and make
sure that that happened that was never
going to happen in five minutes and
12 years in that may be true it's 12
years since the earthquake we're not 12
years into a regeneration plan
and there is no one when you talk
my experience on natural disasters with
the many meetings that i've been to with
the experts that are there there is no
one
that talks about less than 10 years
no one
so these are the tail end of these
projects and and the natural progression
i'm pretty happy with i think that it's
actually going the other way the
prioritization of other
of other
areas such as pegasus all those other
things they are written in their
long-term plan
it is there when we will be looking at
using the funds that we've set aside to
put
put things in place
for those communities and we continue to
do so the other thing is there is no
area
in our whole district that actually has
what is called a regeneration zone that
needs to grab opportunity when
opportunity arises
and that's one of the things that we
need to continue to do
is make sure that when it does come
across the table that we're not
ignoring or putting in front of other
people which we're not doing at the
moment i might add
not putting other things in front of it
to stymy projects that can happen there
does that cost us money sometimes it
does sometimes unfortunately and does it
does it get prioritized above generally
because they're ppps
and that's
that you know makes a big difference to
what we're doing and we need to seize
those opportunities and make sure that
they happen so i'm not uncomfortable
with where we are i think that we're
actually
we're sitting pretty good with it really
um as long as all of those items in the
uh
in the priority list which is our annual
plan
are um
uh adhered to in the time frames that
are there
thank you any further speakers
thank you um uh
chris and duncan i appreciate your work
in that space duncan thank you
right at the end of your budgets chris
um tracy we might um yeah thank you for
all your work
excellent um tracy we might come to your
overheads now and then um we'll break
for afternoon tea and be my
plan so if that's page 362
to 368.
i'll leave my mask on i feel more
comfortable doing so but hopefully you
can hear me so
um thank you for the opportunity it's
exciting to be here presenting budgets
for the first time um and i'll have my
support crew with me for the other
budgets so they can give me the nudge
when i get i realize it was your first
child this is my first
so be gentle um awesome
well now we can ask all those questions
yes
uh so overhead budget is very
very hopefully boring and
straightforward and no changes might
have been outlined in the ltp
um but i am happy to take any questions
thank you i think it's a very
straightforward budget questions counsel
tracy just on your actual budget on plan
management 368 there is a 30k increase
which are just in operations i just
wanted to double check what that was for
because that is to me 30k is significant
um i believe let me just get in there
sure that that is share of the change in
there is the share of corporate
overheads well what i'd turn being
corporate overheads
um
just from the general overhead
correct um budget correct that's right
it's just when you're writing an
exception i'd like a reason yeah thank
you i think i think that that actually
sorry just jeff i think that's applied
on a few budgets there's been a bit of a
re-look at the corporate overhead is
that correct
because i've noticed in a few that it's
sort of increased
yeah
yeah that was a trend yep yep
council award
i was going to add would that be because
of the increased workload that you have
as well
that because i'm blaming you
no that's uh
that's all the um the uh the money that
we all have to contribute towards to
keep this good place running yeah and
that's a reflection of the share and
allocation across us also not directly
from our unit
all right
um if there's no further questions uh
tracy i think um look hard to believe
you've been here it's almost a year
i think you've settled in really well
and making a fantastic contribution here
so
delight to um approve your um overheads
and keep up the great work that you're
doing thank you
thank you any all right we might um well
clean them
plan implementation unit we might as
well deal with that one now why not
come forward matt that's page 369 to 377
and a break soon
warren's hoping he'll get through as
well
yeah we thought we thought we would
optimistic like that
369 matt anything you want to have
perfect not not really probably just key
thing which you all know um very
uncertain times in the resource
management space along with the number
of other spaces
and we will just have to pivot and roll
with the legislative punches and so this
budget sort of prepared on the basis
that things will stay the same
but as we know as early as august things
are going to change for us as well so
happy to take any questions
thanks so any questions counts about it
this is actually not about your budgets
but it's about a customer service
comment that's made later on that limbs
are going to decrease in the 2022-23
year based on your projections do you
think that limbs are going to decrease
over that time
well
i would say probably not from from what
i know of the
amendment tech that will come through
but to be fair we don't actually know
because that's going to be market driven
in terms of what happens there so
um it may not be limbs but certainly
this year we'll get a lot more inquiries
on can i subdivide doing the three
stories in three bedrooms it might be
that limbs are saying well that actually
won't flow through for a couple of years
okay any further questions if i say the
the point around insurance i think
that's an excellent move uh really
pragmatic i
like that suggestion so
um where we can resolve things if we
have to and we're in that space makes
perfect suggestion a perfect um
i think solutions so well done thanks
matt thank you excellent work is um
you're dealing with one of our
regulars has just contacted me so i'm
sure he'll be in touch with you too so
thank you for all the work you do in
that space thank you
excellent um warren you're actually out
of order but i'll take that because um
we have the development planning unit
but um
you're doing that but maybe it seems
warren's looking so keen maybe we'll
just do that first
386.
do you anything you wish to highlight
there mr taylor
well the highlight really is the budget
is predicated on about
720 houses for the next financial year
we did nearly 900 and something rather
this year
and if the budget keeps going the way it
is for the first
seven months of the year we'll hit 950
again
doesn't look as be slowing up to be fair
so it's got its own issues with that and
particularly it comes with staffing and
resourcing is the biggest ticket in town
for us to be fair at the moment but
we're working a way around that so we
will
hopefully you know be able to meet the
demand
but i'll take any questions you have i
do know the comment about insurance so
yeah thank you i see the same applies
here in your budget i highlighted that
as well i think it's a very good
solution any questions
uh council blackie
comment you made um
about
taina um envy putting out a um guidance
document on tiny homes can we have a
copy of that
we've had so much coming and going over
the last i think i have no idea what
their what their deliberations have
actually said
can you is there a request
i'll send you a link to the website and
just sit down and have a read book i
think i think a briefing dp would be
helpful for us at some stage when you
have a briefing of the legislation in
what's actually going on in the district
that would be great
awesome yeah all right that's fine any
further questions
warren thanks for all you're doing 920
houses or 960 has helped us out
significantly today so thank you very
much for
all that extra work you're doing oh
sorry council redmond see
i was just going to make a comment
warren that i had some feedback from one
of your customers they were very
impressed with the service they realize
you're under
under the pump and uh they were very
complementary with the communication
awesome there's someone in your
department must ring them or they talk
to i'm not sure who it is but they were
very pleased with that okay thank you
that's some of the feedback i get from
people very pleased and in fact
quite often get the builders which
construction firms have a differing view
when you go back through and then they
are able to go back to people and say
well actually it wasn't the builder
sorry it wasn't our counselor too it's
the builder uh more often than not
that's the case so excellent customer
service well done
all right um
that's the building unit i think we
might have a break here
and we'll come back and we'll deal with
plan implementation and your other items
tracy just after we make that just after
around 3 30.
okay everyone will understand adjourned
at this point
[Music]
so
the main drive there's still quite a lot
of uncertainty in this area although we
are narrowing it down hence the increase
so we now know the number of
emissions we had so approximately 425
with a rather um significant six and a
half thousand submission points within
that so
um
that is
then allow us we've got two years to
complete that statutory time frame so
we've been able to work back through now
and say what fta do we think we're going
to need to acquire so there's additional
fix to mft just for the like for getting
that process through
which is more cost effective than
consultants assuming we can find them
because experienced planners
at this level aren't easy always defined
so
and also an increase in term generally
in terms of again as we've narrowed down
and been signaled in prior at ltp we'd
have more information getting closer to
this time but there are needing to do a
review of the district that would create
a lot of the input into the district
plan
it needs to be as we
need to update it right
um
increases in
estimated in terms of hearing costs but
they are it is loan funded so uh no
effect on the rates next year in a
minimal going forward
but they are the key drivers as outlined
but i'm happy to take
any questions
thanks tracy any questions
but you can take that as a sign off oh
thank you
um
okay
environmental services page
408 to 417.
that's also me because we are um
down
uh
with murray and away on parental leave
so warren is assisting in that area and
i'm also assisting so
i've looked
after this budget again
uh no notable changes we obviously
have had a fixed term position and
shared with planning so it's something a
bit innovative to say actually can we
get a resource in and share it and get
some flex and see if that actually
assists our planners and other staff to
get out and do what they need to do with
better backup support and it has proved
its worth
so hence the request
with some of that cost obviously being
recoverable on fees
so no particular changes there we have
increased some fees and charges really
just in line with inflation
we've certainly got as noted they're
increasing
dog numbers
and they we believe that we increase
revenue with food premises and that's
simply because we're getting
uh really good at ensuring that we are
charging
um
directly the time it was taken yeah that
had not been as robust as it could have
been so
the main points for environmental
services unit
thanks tracy questions council bala
sorry tracy i didn't quite get to do
this send these by emails
yep um just on the pound it suddenly
jumped up from 7 to twenty eight is that
from a previous report or something can
you
sorry
the pound on page 416 on our agenda yep
under stock control item
and it says the pounds jumped from seven
to twenty eight
i don't actually know why bobby hasn't
had any money spent on it a while it's
probably what it is
we're looking at building a new building
at one stage we are we are certainly
treated then they reduce the reserves
yeah um
but because we've had because of
microchipping they're reducing the
service is what they were saying sorry
about that because of microchips dogs
going back earlier so they were less
than the pound is what we've been told
previously yeah i actually don't know
why that must change because i i know i
didn't amend it
yep
now you've clicked me actually we did do
we sat down we hadn't changed because
environmental services got different
budget lines we sat down and did a
review of where people's time was
allocated yeah so that is why thank you
very much
and just on that page on the 417 can you
just
explain to me what random property is
there's a line that says random property
above accommodation cost and that first
block of expenditure
and it's gone up
uh i'm just and i don't want to i don't
random
inspections or something no no
i'm thinking but i'll come back to you
but i'm thinking
we have to have access to spaces for
stock as well as the pound so other than
dog holdings and i know we have got some
properties so
that may we all be there but i'll come
back and confirm by our email just just
looking at that whole dog control budget
yep it's gone up 70k from the forecast
ltp figure which means the rate the
movement movement's gone from 4.99 to
7.19 now that's a classic of the net for
esu hasn't changed but we've done a
reallocation of our costings and
staffing because they hadn't been done i
don't think in a really long time right
so we've
you know attempted without
the benefit of the team don't carry
detail or their time sheets down to
allocations of mixture of duties so i've
had a bit of a readjustment around that
to try and say particularly when it
comes to dogs are they covering their
fear sheer yeah um but the neat impact
on the unit
is not minimal okay i just yeah i
appreciate all so that you put in a
whole lot of new things and that that
you didn't have time to do that before
the ltp so i totally appreciate that
there could be some movements so just we
haven't um i haven't uh
really have not authorized anything
additional or new
um really other than our
a shared administration resource thank
you
thank you
council atkinson
and
any any further questions
uh thanks tracy for the environmental
services budget and this is any general
remarks no
so now come to 418 429 which is civil
defence
you're going to cover this as well tracy
no brennan is
well let's just
let's just keep going okay if brendan's
on his way yes but
i might just quickly um just give him
that opportunity
oh thank you cool
there may have just been a
miscommunication about timing on that
um so but i'm happy to kick off
so you'll be aware and this
brennan talks about in this budget
requesting consideration of an
additional mo at this stage
it wasn't included as a budget line it
was again management team really
carefully looking at all of those
requests
and while um
we absolutely it's more a case of if we
want to do more so it would be a shift
it would be an increase in level of
service and that's primarily around some
of the issues we bought as part of the
briefing around
more frequent weather events and there's
one happening again for our poor friends
on the coast currently
but also preparation for afa and trying
to grow community resilience
so
that was the driver for it but we
absolutely understand fiscal envelopes
and that there may be a timing aspect
so brennan i think is well laid out what
would happen
with that investment so it's still up
for your consideration
um
and then looked at i certainly have
looked at with timers spent
in the unit and trying to say well if we
really want to grow broader community
resilience are there things that we
could do less of and reallocate hence
the option around the cadet program um
having said that i totally understand
the value it brings to those people in
the community but it would be remiss of
me not to
bring that forward as an option because
it is quite
resource people resource hungry not so
much on the dollars
so they're the main driver sitting
behind there um
you know we
certainly don't
budget in there for
per se for events so they do as a cost
overrun
anyone's guess we we certainly assume we
will have them more frequently so that
may be something we consider as part of
the next long-term plan around whether
we actually start to budget for some of
the costs that
are related to running an eoc that we
cannot get back from government to make
sure that we're budgeting for that so
that's for a discussion for another day
questions
i'm just genuinely going to say that i
think it's really well laid out the
budget here
um
i i don't support us moving to a third
role right now
but i i would be open in time assuming
we survive our performance review
processes at the end of the year
um to transitioning um
to some more resource once that's being
considered so i know the new guy he is
in fact here is the new guy right now
hello paul
and brendan
um
so i think i think so brendan we just
tracy's just kind of given a really good
summary of your budget i don't if you
want to add anything to it uh
further
you're welcome too tracy's done a good
job for you but um
have another go and and then i might
just pause my comments and give them
again
[Laughter]
um
uh we'll we'll we'll give you your views
on that yep
probably
yeah i do i just want to highlight what
i think is really important
for any community but particularly for
our community and that is an awareness
of our risk profile
when i joined this council nearly 11
years ago the risk profile of the
district was quite different to what it
has been in the last
four years
and it's no surprise to anybody how
global warming is shaping that
difference feel free if you don't want
to have your mask on you can take that
off
cool
so only if we if we have members of the
public here which we don't appear to but
from those within our bubble go for it
so my proposal
through the submission is really
recognizing that shift that fairly
significant shift
in risk profiles and natural hazards
elements to it and
it's a it's a big ask for any council to
keep standing up people and resources to
protect people from a physical threat
something that's probably more
sustainable in the mid to long term is
enabling people to take that stand
themselves and to invest in the right
decisions
and write measures and physical things
in their homes to protect themselves
so how do we do that probably through
the right messaging the right
discussions with them to encourage them
to understand the risk and make those
clever decisions to invest wisely
aka public engagement
and there are some people who can do
that extremely well and there are some
people like myself who will try their
very best
and i have no doubt that this council
wants the best outcomes
and i think a wise decision to invest in
the right people can make a big
difference for us it saves our
ratepayers in the mid to long term
and that's probably the basis of the
concept that you have in front of you
and of the concept that i've been
espousing through the the current ltp
and i'll continue to do so
i'm very very aware of our need to save
money
and to keep the um
rates percentage down low
but we are competing with mother nature
and it's outrunning us when i say yes
i'm talking about the planet
and this might sound highly emotionally
charged but that is exactly what this
council has been experiencing if you
were to read the debriefs
of the probably dozen or so small to
medium emergencies that we've had in the
10 years that i've been here i didn't
bring those here either by the way
they're followed
um so
that's probably that's my patch
do we really acknowledge
truly what our risk profile is
and how best can we enable our community
to look after itself in that context and
in that framework
and i think public engagement if we
don't have the resources to keep
throwing physical equipment at them
and building structures where they can
take safe haven into
then how do we enable them to look after
themselves and i think the right message
from the right people pitched the right
way can save us right power money
that's my pitch thank you and welcome
paul um day two which is really great
you've turned up
um
brennan um thank you for those remarks
and can i just say for me
it's not just about rates i'll continue
because i was
um it's not just about rates um i
i genuinely do believe in investing in
civil defense it's really important what
i'd like to see
in this here is perhaps a bit more work
done on establishing a third role
and i would be open-minded to to
considering that
when it's socialised a little further
with colleagues that sort of come up on
the budget papers
around that whether it's a part-time
that moves to full-time i'd like to see
some more work done on that but i i'm
not
personally not opposed to seeing that
work done and then tracy and and
yourself and and and paul as it is uh
now i work with the ce around um
how that's presented and brought back to
us but i i'd like to see the new um your
new chat get in in the role first to see
how that goes
um but i certainly am not opposed to
that being considered but
i'm just not
i'm just not sure that the case has been
made to us right at this point i think
we need to do a bit more work on that
but i'm not saying no
just not right now um
around um
and i'd like to the other thing i'd like
to see uh we've had quite a lot of
conversation with
um
the gets really work which sarah
saunders uh certainly has done a very
good job lobbying a number of us nicely
um and i really like sarah i think she's
a real a real find to neighborhood
support
i'd like to understand how
we could get some more out of that
partnership too so if they put a bid up
during the
annual plan plan round i've got an open
mind to
personally to considering that she's
looking for some resources to augment
the work she's doing which then helps us
with some of that work so be nice be
good to know how that could work
for us as well
i do
i do think around the cadet program i
support that program
and i would like to see it continue but
but i would welcome uh tracy a workshop
at some stage around that as we've
discussed
um to see where that can go and how that
can be supported whether it needs our
staff leading that or whether there is
actually some volunteers that might be
capable of leading that program within
parents or however be interested to see
how that could be
considered but look we we do
we do spend around quite considerable
amount on civil offence is it up there
with some of the other councils you're
right brennan to observe um
that we've perhaps got you know some
things to think about so i think in the
next 12 months six to 12 months i'd like
to have that work done um and see where
we get to but i've got an open mind for
the future to see how that's resourced
but i want to acknowledge you and the
you particularly
um for the leadership role that you've
played and and with events
there is no one better than yourself
around i know what you're supported by
the organisation when things come up but
your leadership is amazing and even on
uh
sunday just with the certain tools
getting that set up that was fantastic
so
um it's i just yeah you've got my
personally my support just like to see
that work done a little further
nev
very elegantly put mr mayor was nothing
like that i've seen the budget and the
line items there that um the sandbags
have come out
twelve thousand dollars for sandbags why
are we not uh
budgeting to
supply more sandbags and for events
or are we getting them are we getting
them for nothing brendan is that what's
happening
you notice the beach is running out of
sand
no i believe it's still in there if you
refer to the ltp i think it's every
third year we we look to restock that
even given the events is that does that
need to be increased
just it's one of the biggest demands we
have for immediate assistance when
things go wrong
and i just wonder you know i mean
certainly being here last time you know
um
you know you you were pretty close to
the knuckle and and you could almost say
it wasn't a huge event um but you were
pretty close to the knuckle of them gone
just in that small event so i just
wonder whether we need to uh whether it
be evidence today just to allow a bit
more in there for the for
more of them
i think it's definitely a an option to
do that uh if
if i was to rate it on
importance it would probably be less
than the middle for me
uh we have some there
but we are looking more now at
some purpose manufactured devices
that takes one person on their own to
put it up really really quickly rather
than 20 sandbags which could take us a
person one to two hours to do
so it's a smarter way slightly more
expensive than sandbags
um but you know i would never say no to
increasing the stock holding but um if i
was to be honest i don't think it's
critical
i think the three yearly boost is is
enough
so we i'd already asked for questions
before that's why i moved into um giving
general remarks it's okay so but so so
questions or general remarks
bill
uh thanks mr mayor you've discussed a
number of topics that i was going to
mention um one of them relates to the
cadet program
that's been in hiatus for a number of
months
i wouldn't like to see that continue for
very much longer or we may very well
lose the impetus
i understand
uh paul has expressed an interest in
continuing with that
so i don't know whether we need to give
a direction or
how that program can be resurrected
but it'd be fantastic
did you want to add or or brennan i
think i just also note that a part of
that hiatus has been covered in limiting
the ability to do training so that's
been quite a driver and we've had um
i really commend brendon for the good
communication that he's had um and it's
very recently has been in contact with
him about what does it mean for you
going forward how do we keep you safe so
there has been part of that as well
um it's i guess really a direction of
council uh brendan put the option up
there um i'm hearing the direction we're
getting is keep the cadet program going
but look at other options in terms of
sustainability and who we might involve
um to look at that resourcing and come
back to you with a briefing or a paper
potentially
do you want to and um probably if i just
add that we are
reconnecting we reconnected it
just eight days ago with our teams
a lot of the
parents and the cadets weren't available
because they were one holidays so we've
agreed with them to reconnect after
school starts back
so we also agreed for the five families
that participated eight days ago
that once paul is on deck we will invite
them to another microsoft teams hui
to talk how and when we will start
actively getting back into things i also
explained that we are waiting also on
the outcome of the annual plan uh
process but it won't stop us from
restarting training as early as march
we need to have some conversations with
the cadets and the parents themselves
prior to that to get agreement on how we
can do this in a way that gives them
confidence that it's safe for the kids
to attend our activities
uh council
just just a tiny question and then a
comment um
is there still a waiting list for the
get program like there was last year
we did interview more cadets so yes
there is a list per se
whether those cadets who didn't make the
cut
are still interested i haven't
tried to approach them
of the 20 cadets that we had prior to
christmas one has left
she notified me in our meeting eight
days ago
and just a quick comment from what i've
seen in the program that um although
it's under civil defence it actually
covers a lot more than civil defence um
it's about resilience it's about youth
mental health it comes under our youth
strategy youth development strategy and
so although it's in this budget it's
it's actually quite a small amount of
amount to pay for the value it gives to
the young people in our district and i'm
glad that you're connecting with them
still because i know our young people
are struggling a little bit with the
lack of face-to-face connection
and they're very comfortable in an
online space but i'm sure they want to
get back to doing things as well um i
really like the middle approach you've
taken here where you've just increased
the engagement budget and the fact that
you've noted you've almost spent it all
on tsunami and you know we just seem to
have emergency after emergency after
emergency if it's not a tsunami it's a
wind it's a fire it's a you know we are
having a lot of of um opportunities
where we do need to help people help
themselves
and even the connections you've made
with the lifestyle group and
the emergency services and the linking
together of groups i've seen over the
years that's been essential but as you
say someone who specialised in actual
education
it's not your role
your role is to manage the whole overall
and get us ready for an emergency but to
have someone who even part-time to start
off
and see how we can grow it
to actually help our community to be
ready for the next emergency which there
will be one um so i'm really really
uncomfortable with the middle approach
and this is the one time i don't mind
the budget being above ltp
any further contribution i think you
around the cadets i think you're getting
a cl sorry oh wendy i'm sorry i didn't
see that wendy
thank you report
i'm i'm just very interested as as
always with this gets ready program and
north carolina neighborhood support and
i can see the benefit of those two going
forward to help for the community side
of things so
going going forward
do you think that you will probably in
time
uh make more adjustments
to bringing them on board
uh yes definitely so sarah saunders and
i met last week actually
to talk about how we can strengthen the
partnership
as opposed to bringing them on board so
yeah we do have a deliberate mutual
intent to do that um and we
she's agreed to join me with a an online
microsoft teams hui with our trained
volunteers to talk about how we can make
that happen in our operational sense
so that's something that's going to
happen probably in the month of february
sierra is still looking to come to us
with a submission has she been in i
understand that's the case yes
around the cadets is um so the status
quo budget what status quo in here
includes the funding for the cadet
program so
around the mechanics of whether it's
pool leading or how that's done you'll
work that through just keep us informed
great because uh like uh councillor
redmond says we get approached i get
approached a lot by the the kids that
are part of it really excited and want
to see it continued so they keep saying
please make sure there's funding in the
budget for it so we have got it in there
so
tell them that all right
certainly pass that on and i think just
to holla it's not the funding because we
actually accept that that's the it's
it's the time and point to do it really
really well
okay eddie
right so i think we've done the
that's the civil defence budget
thank you brennan
i hope you hope you're back tomorrow
pool yep
look looking forward to working with you
kia ora thank you
thank you for being kind
to me
yeah that's you that's your first one
tracy well done this
come again
okay so um
i think these are going to fall on you
um jim aren't they so these next ones is
that correct
um do we want the deal go into px first
and deal with site security that falls
under the hr budget
so let me just get that
asif we might as well deal with the
council software at the same time says
me having to come back out again
are you ready to do that or would you
rather win wait
is andy coming
we can flow that on after i said okay
all right so
so yes i'm just going to move that we go
into public excluded for items 6.2
and 6.3
seconded
americans in
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried
so we're now in public excluded adrian
can you just confirm
[Music]
okay so we're now back an open meeting
so we're now going to deal with um
hr and organisational development and
jim you're taking the lead on these
yes the you'll notice that in the last
five years there's been a hundred extra
staff that have been employed by
waimakariri district
in order to in an addition in the last
year the staff turnover has gone up to
about 15
so what that means when you put it
together is that the the load um the
human resources load
has increased significantly and we
haven't had an increase of staffing in
that area for a number of years
the hr advisor position that's one of
the two ftes there they give advice to
line managers on recruitment and
retention which is and if that's not
done in a timely fashion along with the
hr administrator then we lose good
candidates because there's a lot of
competition for them and if you can't
get your documentation done quickly
referee checks followed up
contracts drawn up all those sorts of
logistics things done
then you can lose candidates extremely
quickly and we have lost candidates
because we haven't been able to get some
of that back of house work through in
time
as the more pressure comes on your
people and more uncertainty with
omnichrome you can expect to see more hr
advice needed for individuals and their
leaders on how to and to keep them safe
if we want to keep a high performing
organization at times
you have to deal with poor performance
i'm surprised i've had to deal with a
few since i've been here more than i had
in dunedin and not even years and they
take up an inordinate amount of time
because of the whole of the legal
process the touring and throwing the
costs and so on
and the hr advisors are critical because
if they're not involved early then you
just have to make one procedural mistake
and you're on the back foot so
we need quality advisors to support the
line managers and those sorts of things
then there's also the recruitment and
retention piece that you heard from
kelly lovely about that
and that's ensuring we've got an
appropriate reward structure
but also that
that's packaged in a way that's relevant
to engineers versus planners and so on
in order to do that work you need bodies
on the ground and if the people who
the past have been doing that are also
providing the strategic direction on
those things
which has been the case then essentially
you burn your people out and you're not
getting the best results so that's why
there's an extra hr advisor and an hr
administrator position in there
um similarly with health and safety um
you know the world's expectations change
significantly
in order to do a lot of the admin work
around that um there's a 0.5 ft for that
as well so when you put that together
that explains the sort of staffing
increase and that's driving most of the
cost extra in this department area
jeff do you want to add anything further
as a gm on this one
any questions
thanks jim
um kirsten
again it's only been one year since cltp
and i realized we've had a lot of
changes but why 30
since cltp and couldn't it be phased in
with say one in one year and one in the
next
um well i wasn't here a year ago so i
had nothing to do with your ltp and if i
had been here a year ago
with the sort of things i've seen in the
hr area
and the number of the matters that i
touched on i would have been
recommending to you to increase staffing
earlier
because we have had
major challenges here
and they essentially come back we just
haven't got enough people on the ground
to deal with it
further questions
okay anyone want to speak to uh please
okay that's ticked off
hey
well
it's um it is what it is paul so uh
all right so we come to now community i
understand that and
um i have developed a zero rate increase
in my career so i know about cost
cutting
but all of us are only as good as our
people
and we've got a we've got more pressure
than i've ever seen on people in local
government or anywhere we've got more
competition for those scarce resources
as well
so
and we've also got obligations where if
we don't set up the right work
environment we can be significantly
liable for
health and safety failure and so on and
i could end up in court if we don't
we'll deal with security issues so
you know when we put that together all
of us need quality people who committed
we've got some pretty good house voice
survey results but there's some of these
areas which have dropped a bit in the
last few years since we did it
so it's incumbent that we'd have the
right resources and support for our line
managers to do the right thing
i support i support this recommendation
that it's um
we might not like the fact of
these things coming up but our chief
executive working with our hr manager
has come to this recommendation and we
need to make sure we support make sure
our staff are supported adequately so
i'm in support of this so anyway there's
no no one else wants to hear anything
let's move forward
okay um so now we're in communication
engagement is alistar coming in for that
probably no need to necessarily who's
going to handle al's budget are you
doing that jim
i don't know if else
just see if he
no hey
no i know but if he just wants to speak
but do you want to handle that jim
there's really no change from last year
to this year in this budget so
and again in terms of communication
this is a critically important route
group for all of us because
they essentially put into english the
complex world that we all live in
and that ensures a lot of confidence in
the community with things we're doing
your communications ratings are
incredibly high for local government
and that's a tribute to this department
in being able to write in plain english
and there's a plus 50k from ltp with no
commentary i assume that's jeff's fault
again
in operations
can we clarify
jeff no i don't think so
um
i think there was a there was a transfer
of cost wasn't it between departments as
i seem to recall when i
looked at that but there's an 8.71
increase instead of a 2.79 in the bottom
column in the rate movement
yeah i think the transfer is up which is
not insignificant
all right so which which line i should
be talking about there operations 443
bottom line
second the one that says 706 at the top
there's about 50k extra
and then the bottom line says the rate
moment is 8.71
opposed to 2.79 is that to do with the
accommodation costs again
anyway
oh you know just putting some commentary
on that increase that's all as to why
um identifies towards the bottom of that
page
that in the 2021 annual plan there was
some cost shifting around internal
recovery transfers all of that
and that the full effect of those
transfers are now flowing through to
this budget so that might be
the explanation of that 48k extra
perhaps we perhaps perhaps for purposes
of this maybe get some uh
they could with uh when owls back we
could get a
an email sent with just say the
explanation further i think jim's right
with what's there but let's cover that
off in an email back is it okay
that's absolutely fine i'd just like to
comment that to me 50k is not an
insignificant rating impact so that does
need to be identified on the budget as a
50k impact
all right any any other questions
sorry
will
oh well done paul oh
gosh you hit you'll have the the
sugar rush is heading in good work
okay um is there
all right um any further questions
any comment
that
we get really well served in our
communication space alan and his team do
an absolutely superb job
and
so their budget carries my full support
i understand council barnett's question
i think it's perfectly reasonable to get
an explanation back around
what that's actually uh containing so
we'll get an email sent out to you to
get that explained
fear the speakers
all right let's move on
rob um we're dealing with um property
and uh housing elderly
is that missing a comma in between there
g'day it's oh my it's his property and
housing elderly i think i'm missing a
comma in between
all right thanks rob that's now that's
pages444
that's correct
good afternoon mr mayor councillors and
staff
i'll take the
budget papers as read but just highlight
a couple of points for your
consideration and
a couple of areas where there have been
some
subtle changes
you may recall that
last year we agreed to bring back to you
a report on the use of the portacoms
so we've been underway with planning for
alternative uses for them
however this has been superseded
by the anticipated need for project
teams associated with council's i.t unit
which you have been discussing earlier
this is anticipated to utilize these
spaces for
in the order of 18 months to two years
so
we have deferred that
body of work for a future
discussion in reporting
in relation to those porticons
budgets also budgets associated with the
campgrounds
are currently under some review as a
result of changed circumstances since
preparing the budget
and you will have received a little bit
of an update on some of those changes
we will be bringing a briefing and
report to council in april to cover um
several particular matters
with the report in may
that will in turn have some impact on
the budget allowances or may have some
impact on the budget allowances there
a note that the rents associated with
housing for the elderly service are
increasing this year after no increase
last year
and that was due last year to the
legitimate legislative change that the
government brought in
which meant that the timing of
that rent increase that
had been
proposed
was difficult to implement
so in order to put things back onto the
normal cycle we skipped effectively a
year of the programmed rent increase
that had been in place
so just
to that you will recall that
we have a pro program of
a six to seven year step rent increase
um that was signed off by council at the
last ltp
just as a point of interest
we have recently completed a
satisfaction survey
which
covered
the individual units that tenants have
the complexes and our tenancy services
so we will be bringing that report back
to council or a report i'm covering that
survey back to council
later this year
however the headline result
for that is that over 90 per cent of
respondents
were satisfied or very satisfied with
the overall service so a pretty pleasing
result
and some good
intel for us to learn from from that
survey
uh the adoption of the
property acquisition and disposal policy
generates the need for an implementation
planning
and this will be progressed in more
detail
level with the paid working group
however the budget does recommend the
creation of a new property projects
manager role um to enable a more timely
delivery of outcomes sought by the pad
policy
and you'll notice
that within
the body of the commentary
the aim is to generate
solid returns from those sales that
eventuate from that or are anticipated
to eventuate from that
which are
aimed at making that not only neutral
but clearly exceeding
the cost of that
so it does allow us to
respond and bring forward
some of that body of work that we
are now wanting to engage in
this is being progressed alongside a
change proposal that we are close to
completing
after consultation with affected staff
and this sees a team leader role being
created in the unit to support improved
service delivery um and free up some
bottleneck areas um so at an operational
level um we
see that there's
some room for improvement and
this will allow that to
to occur
and it also
allows a number of other work streams to
be progressed around initiatives
associated for example with council's
role in housing going forward
in the disposal program alongside others
with the support of the team leader role
several current vacancies are also
proposed to be filled
with
officer roles are somewhat more junior
to
the ones that existed
so there are some cost offsetting
factors within the change proposal
and collectively however this will also
support business continuity
and succession planning
you'll notice there's a few gray hairs
um emerging so
i think it's very wise and sensible for
businesses to
make sure there's a
a good business succession plan in place
and this will support that
business continuity
is also around
the challenge that we have because the
individual staff
are quite specialized in different areas
and while they can provide some level of
cover um the value of that team leader
role
will really be able to step in and
support that business continuity in a in
a better way
but uh with that i'll
put that over to questions or thank you
comments did you want anything jim
okay
any questions of colleagues
all right well that's ticked off
thank you rob
appreciate um appreciate the work thank
you thank you and stepping in
cheers all right um
just having a look here we've got next
to strategic projects and economic
development simon
so
four six four and four seven four you
you're taking care of both of those yep
thank you
good afternoon mr mayor councillors
a bit of a
nothing to see here budget with the
strategic projects and economic
development area i just wanted to make a
few notes and then happy to answer any
questions councils might have
the the budget reflects a merger between
two units that occurred in december last
year that is a merge between the former
business and centers unit and policy and
strategy unit to
essentially form the strategy and
business unit that i'm now fortunate
enough to lead in this new year
you'll see that's reflected in the
budget in that
we have consolidated
some of the expenditure lines into a set
of expenditure lines under the
operational area
that reflect the activities that we
undertake such as the policies by laws
and reviews plan and strategy
development so on so forth the
underlying operational budget has only
slightly shifted as you'll note by 60
odd thousand and uh a significant
chunk of that is the bringing forward of
the wooden pegasus area strategy which
was designed by council when we met with
you last year we brought that forward by
one financial year into the next
financial year 22-23
other than that
the majority and of of the budget stay
exactly the same um and move across uh
with the changes only to coding
essentially that were made so i'm very
happy to answer any questions counselors
may have where i can just noting that
mr markham is not actually present today
so i will do my very very best now this
is
new to this budget still
thanks simon so any questions council
williams
can you fill me in please on the
monitoring changes you know from 11 000
to 69 000 and external scanning from 36
119 000 on page 470.
sorry councillor williams can you just
repeat those two
budget lines
um yes uh so
uh
essentially you'll see that the two
codes the state of environment and the
district planning effectiveness codes
beneath the national legislation code no
longer exist so there's been an
amalgamation of codes there this has
happened across the budget in a number
of areas where we've essentially deleted
some budgets and we've created them what
we've added to other budgets so the
overall effect of the budget is actually
very little or no movement it's just
that some codes will now see a
significant increase and others will see
um basically a zero uh sum there in the
in the new budget
okay any other questions by the way um
simon sorry for the question cass
williams
yeah that answer doesn't add up actually
there's
quite a lot of difference here
even if you take those
forty nine thousand and thirty thousand
away from that there's still a huge
difference
anyway do you want to answer this or are
you if you already
addressed that question i worked there
somehow to be pretty close um
and and and look you'll see you'll see
that across across the fields uh a
little bit so under the business
incentives codes for example you'll see
in the yellow column there the budget
2223 they're all nailed out uh and that
full that comes up into the um
the policy strategy and projects columns
uh or rose and you'll see that there has
been some increases but that's simply
just a shifting of money around the
codes to reflect what the new unit is
now undertaking i think the overall
budget position is actually very very
similar with the exception of the
audient pegasus area strategy that noted
before
simon this won't be a surprise to you
but i'm around strategic projects um
south brock
i do regularly bang on about that one so
i certainly support woody and pegasus
strategy definitely but i would like to
know that south brook's on the horizon
particularly that we have a working
group the council signed off yesterday
on on
on roading related matters there are
also
um
business related matters that does need
a strategy down there and i'd
just like to ask you when that's been
considered
that's a very good question we've
thought about that in two ways the first
of which is that it's very possible that
we could look at the south brook area as
part of a wider commercial or industrial
areas uh component of the economic
development strategy that is currently
being
scoped and and the brief being put
together at the moment with consultants
so so there is an opportunity to have a
section or a subsection of the waimak
economic development strategy that deals
with those if it were to be a separate
strategy just for south brook we would
then want to think about what is the
scope of that and
then does that set a precedent for other
commercial areas that are not south
brook but not town centres either which
have a specific uh pro
specific strategy
and if that was the desire of counsel
then we could absolutely scope that up
bring that back to council but we would
then just have a look at how that
strategy set within the priorities of
other strategies so we've got a place
making strategy and the waimak economic
uh sorry the economic development
strategy along with the woody and
pegasus area strategy which are
there for development and a framework
that's also under development so we just
need to look at where that sits in the
pipeline of strategies that's underway
the economic so will you be coming to
council with the economic and maybe you
could answer that question as part of it
i'm not necessarily saying it needs to
be a but if it's considered as part of
that in a considerable part of it
because there's lots of areas
in our district now that deliver
economically not that it hasn't been
before but i do think it does need to be
considered so if it's coming in there i
i'd be open to considering that
yes and there'll be a briefing to
council uh and the community boards on
that strategy and and how that's shaping
up uh in the coming months okay uh jim
well also in that context the council
obviously has a district plan out there
at the moment and it it's owned land for
commercial industrial purposes so that
needs to be built into the thinking
okay any other quest questions uh nikki
casa meanings
um
hey simon i i just want to just clarify
because i've kind of been pouring
through it looking to see where i can
find it but i understand that your new
sbu is now charged with the
sustainability and climate change
side of things and
and the
new rule of lead advisor sustainable
development establishing underneath that
i don't i haven't really been able to
find anything in here that looks like it
might match to that so where where is
that hidden
uh it's primarily hidden and the codes
that sit under the policy strategy and
projects so
a number of our staff will have roles
across strategy development policy
development by law reviews and so on and
so forth so we apportion their time
across a number of those areas so that
it so we can sort of essentially report
on how much time and money is being
spent in any one of those areas so the
lead advisor role
for sustainability has been factored
into these budgets
as has the replacement of a senior
policy analyst
and a new business and centre's role as
well so all of that is
factored in and it's essentially paid
for by some of the roles that we've
actually
lost in in recent times so there's no
change to uh wage budget as a result
any further questions
thank you simon for the
strategic projects by the way i don't
think we've had a chance to officially
congratulate you on the meeting on your
new
title which is
strategy and business manager so
congratulations on your promotion well
done
um
economic development pages you're
leading that one as well 474
to 481 so
i'll just take that as read it you'll
see again that there's very little or no
no change in this
in this budget but very happy to take
questions from councillors about what
sits in there
thank you any questions
no that's
that's done thank you
simon oh jeff sorry thank you simon we
appreciate
thank you for your time jeff you've got
an answer of the comms budget
thank you that's that's very helpful
thanks jeff
all right will you come forward now jeff
finance your name
thank you
i think you're here with us for the
remainder
thank you so we're page
and there's a there's a staff
progression movement sitting in the
financial accounts area
which hasn't been explained um so we
have a new crca there that's uh that
we're trained on since uh since he went
as a provisional member
so there's a bit of a movement there on
top of normal uh the normal two percent
so take that one as uh
uh payroll you might question that one
there
there's a uh
a 30 hour
person that was in the role let's move
to 40
that's to support the
payrolls it's one of the most important
jobs in the business isn't it well yeah
other than that um
just take budget as read thank you any
questions do you want to add anything
done
does dave want to add anything
he'll chime in with the ict bill oh
sorry pardon me he's dealing with that
one yet sorry
okay
sorry did you want i was just going to
go to the next one kenneth yeah i'll
just see if there's any questions
no so there we are jump into canterbury
museum uh so canterbury museum i've
received the
draft budget it's got cpi movement they
were forecasting 5
movement in their budget which they have
brought to us
the
development
that got for the new museum that's
been
had a cpi adjustment on it
and
the overall rate
has actually decreased that we were
forecasting for both the levy and the
development levy
security questions
counselor williams
have we got a legal
um
definition of whether we have to pay
that four million dollars development
levy because
the museum don't quite know whether
we've um obliged to or not
we've been over this many times paul we
have not had a legal opinion on it
in my case
going down that direction but you're
welcome to answer jeff yeah no we
haven't we haven't got a legal opinion
but the opinion is uh that if we don't
pay the levy all they'll do is uh raise
a loan themselves put it into the
operation maybe and charge us under the
act
and so we'd end up paying it anyway and
we could end up paying more
uh than what we would normally pay
because of our credit rating to loan
fund fees
and so we'd be in a worse position i'd
say and would that be legal for them to
do that yes yep
under the act that they can charge it
for operating costs
so jeff you do say in the report be
really good uh sorry the commentary it'd
be really good to get an update from the
museum so that's been scheduled for them
to come and brief us at some stage
sierra's nodding so i know you
referenced that in there
um around there particularly around the
consensus and process and how they're
going with the redevelopment yes
we do have a confirmed date and i think
it is the one that's
yeah
so the 12th of april i think uh
want to brief the council great thank
you any further questions
thank you um
information and technology support it's
your moment yeah
dave
i'll do a quick overview four nine seven
so you'll see you'll see there's a
change in philosophy here around
where we do projects to bring it more
in-house than now out of house and so
you see a 200 000 movement from a
capital project into the operations
this budget in terms of the capital
budget
we've just covered
uh
and so that's
going to revise some of that capital
works which we'll bring back to the
council with a report on once we've done
an rfp
okay
i was just checking there was nothing
else to
do any questions do you want anything
dave no
any questions
thank you
right
uh water unit um
uh which is page 510
uh this is
thanks dave this budget is is more to
an internal charge to the
cost centre for the three waters
you'll see some
changes in the training
budget there to make sure that we've got
the health and safety requirements of
the job covered we've done a significant
amount of work with the water unit over
the last year
in terms of
what that strategy is and where it's
going
this budget actually allows for
two apprentices to be taken on this year
for succession and two apprentices the
following year
we find it very difficult to find
qualified
water treatment offices in the current
market and so that's a strategy to
for this budget for the next year
there is some upward lift movement and
some of the
costs and
one of the exercises we're doing here is
to
procure one years of material ahead of
time to try and take the risk out of the
market getting
pipes and fittings
other than that just take that as read
christian council award
just a query on page 515
um two thirds of the way down down time
uh bud projected budget 395
but it's 277 960
and the annual plan budget that's not
that
definitely not there no
good spotting uh we'll fix that i'll
have to go back to the wood paper and
see what's on that that might bring our
rates increase down a bit
here we go we can afford this well done
well done jane
just paid for
and i'll leave you to resolve that
jeffrey
yeah
uh
council thank you
why have
fees and subs gone up 70 who's doing
well out of that
sorry can you
511 membership fees and subs increase
from 690 to 1200 70
rise
i was quite amused by that downtime
um
i can't answer that i have to bring that
so maybe maybe you could just bring that
back by an email um to clarify that you
have those two points
it's only
it's only four hundred dollars
all right okay is there any other
questions
uh that's the water unit budget uh is
marie joining us for customer services
chief
have a moment for a stretch team if
you're watching
nearly there oh we might just have a
pause for a minute for our live stream
so we're just attuned for a couple of
minutes
she switched
[Music]
so
here we
go we resume
we're back on live streaming stream
everyone so
um we come to governance in sick
material
529 to 539 jeff and zero
i hated your warning to be prudent with
our budget so take it as read that we
have kept within our ltp
guidelines
oh good girl
all right any questions
any questions
no questions so
that's one assume everyone's got there
thank you very much
jeff uh so jim why don't we go to
district management 540-544
yeah there's a new paper everyone say
that replaces the old papers
they were on you they're on your um your
tables
oh there we go
it's new paper it's a very big type you
can't miss it put that one there unless
you're gonna do it
that's it
yeah
so this
all right jim thank you district
management yeah i think i'll just take
the um the papers read there's nothing
of any great significance this is where
my costs are the eas are all in here
there's been provision for salary
movements
minor increase in travel
and a little bit of support for
attendance of staff at corporate events
so 4500 that's about it any questions
no excellent right thank you jim
um
perfect timing customers customer
service so we're going to deal with a
paper
yeah i think it does tip 10 sorry my
computer's just about died so just hold
a second
excuse me just while i get the paperwork
right
um
she should be i should be okay thank you
i've got a battery if you need it thank
you
tab 10 so that's uh remissions
operates on multi-freehold land oh
thanks jim
thank you um marie thank you
we are on live audio stream just let you
know
thank you mr mia um this paper is
regarding a
review of the remission of rates on
maori freehold land that we're required
to undertake before the 1st of july
as a result of the new legislation that
came in last year
so
the majority of remissions that we have
been applying under this policy
were for land that was unused
in multiple ownership and
that land became non-ratable under the
new legislation so
instead of striking rates and remitting
them
the land is non-ratable so no rates are
charged on it at all
so
that part
has come out of the policy
the other
item that we had in the previous policy
or the existing policy
was regarding land that was used for
conservation purposes
and some of that land if there's a
dock conservation
covenant in place
then that land is also non-ratable
so the changes to the policy are
basically
taking out the
land that is now non-ratable
and
leaving in
a
an option for land that is used for
conservation purposes but isn't covered
by a covenant
and also
leaving in
an option for rates remissions where
there may be some use of the land but
there's no direct benefit to
the owners so that some consideration
can be
given to that and
an example could be where there's
someone squatting on the land
who doesn't have authority to be there
but that provides the use and therefore
the owners can't apply for a rates
remission
the other change is regarding land under
development
and the new law requires the council to
consider remissions
on
land that is under development so we've
included that in the policy as well
and the criteria for
those remissions
are outlined in the act so we haven't
repeated that in the policy workforce
any questions thank you any questions
councilor redmond followed by council
students
thank you marie i think it looks a good
policy at the end of the day we don't
really have a choice i just wondered
where no rates are charged our service
is still provided to that property
yes
but the services aren't consumed so
for example the tahiri water supply
would run past the property but the
property is not connected to the water
supply
council stuart
yes councilwood could you just turn your
microphone off
yes i note um
paid on
6.1 you've quantified the
effect of the previous
policies
as eleven thousand dollars do we have a
handle on
whether this is you know how many
properties this affects in our district
and
yes how many are affected by this new
legislation
it's hard to say at the moment
in this current rating year we're not
applying any rates remissions
under this policy
because the land that we previously
remitted rates on is non-rateable
it's generally because of the multiple
ownership and the values are discounted
the amount of rates on the land is very
low anyway
the development one will be interesting
because
you know we will look at
getting the information out to people
and
the applications for development could
come in from people who
are clearing land
to
to put it into a farming use or
her wanting to put
build houses on it so
development isn't defined so there could
be quite a range of applications that
come
under that there could be none you know
the people have to have the resources to
be able to develop
um because of the the range of
possibilities for development we have um
delegated authority for those to the
audit and risk committee rather than
through staff who who do the remissions
at the moment
further questions
so we've got a recommendation there
somewhere prepared to move move to
councillor redmond seconded by council
stewart
should i speak
just briefly to say
i think a new policy gives
audit and risks and flexibility and we
have to meet our statutory requirement
so
i thought um you've done a good job with
the policy
council stuart
any further speakers
i've got the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carriage
so we now go back to the budget page 517
so
thanks murray if you want to cover off
your budget paper sid
thank you
there's not a lot um different than what
was proposed in the long term plan
limb
incomes the numbers have dropped
again this year and
we will be
we'll be short on the income this year
and
reduced it slightly for the following
for this year's budget
it's difficult to predict what the
numbers are at the moment i think
they're low more because
there's a lack of properties on the
market rather than
your interest in the property market
but
that seems to be the the trend
that we're looking at for the coming
year
the
other main change is just an increase in
staff numbers
for the team
both this year and the coming year
you'll recall that we were looking at a
cadet role in the previous year's budget
and the council supported that
for a number of reasons we haven't been
able to fill that role and
we are looking at putting those
resources to a systems and training role
just to give a bit more emphasis to
keeping the team up to speed and getting
the most out of the technology that
we've got available
we've also found that
our team are attractive to other units
in the council
and in the last two years we've lost
four staff
two other units and last year there were
three of those four
so
that hits the team quite hard because
there's a wide variety of skills and
knowledge that they need and
when we're
bringing people up to date of course
that takes
the existing resources
out of providing service to the
customers so
we have allowed for additional staff
both in the customer services contact
team
and
in the lims slash rates area as well
again because
there are
a lot of effort
involved in getting those people up to
date
thank you
any further questions
do you think our
um uh accurate for canterbury regional
council um production because i
see their rates proposals 24
so well i think it might do you think
our commission
estimates about right yeah we might have
to revise it um yeah it might need to
sneak up or weave it um with that but
i'm sorry
i know
unbelievable
it's a um
a silver lining
thank you
all right um
no further questions oh sorry sorry
kirsten pardon me
um
just i know limbs are really really
difficult and i know it's a real an area
um
but
talking to matt bacon and what he's
seeing in the sort of planning and
subdivisions and things that are
happening
he doesn't see that limbs are likely to
decrease
as much as they did in 2021
what would happen if they increase are
we able to meet the capacity and
in your budget you've actually got
additional staff
in the limbs team but you've seen limbs
have gone down i'm just trying to
reconcile those two things
when the limbs were at their peak recent
peak and
towards the end of 2020
we struggled to
to
deal with those volumes and
it was only really i think through the
commitment of the team to working extra
hours that we managed to get through
we've lost two members of the team
internally
and
if that had happened when the
peak of 2020 occurred
we couldn't have coped
we did have a staff member moved in but
fortunately it was within my team and i
was i put them back
so it's it's just really i guess future
proofing
the role um
and
anticipating that if numbers do go up
um
that we've got enough people in place
the other side of that role is
the rates team an extra resource there
rates can struggle because
the work when the property numbers
increase it it just incrementally
increases a number of roles
and um
it's hard to put a person in a
particular place when a number of staff
are
feeling precious so
what we're looking at is being able to
put somebody else in that property set
up
role and get them trained so that
that will complement work in the limbs
area and so that
if there isn't work in limbs then that
person can take some of the pressure on
the rates team
so i guess the overall question is
you're saying limbs will go
you're still predicting just a contest
on that 2020 was our second biggest
limbs
yeah
in history
even though there was only only the
earthquake period so what we're saying
is the budget's not going to sustain at
that level so we're dropping that down
the number
for example if we look at last month
january
that was the lowest level of limbs that
we've received since
i think it was 2015 or 2016. so for
january
yes for january
and yet for last year total
we were only about 50 short of the
previous year
but in the previous year we had a couple
of really low months when we're in
lockdown so
it's a bit of a gamble but we have to
look at what the um
you know what the numbers are that are
coming in now and try and predict
what um what is going to happen
because the indicators in the property
market is that it's actually getting
there's more properties coming on the
market
at the moment like starting to come onto
the market there's actually an increase
in supply
going forward which will mean more limbs
and there's also a huge amount of
residents moving into the rest homes
which will be selling their properties
now that summer seat is live
yes um
but
we had
budgeted for a higher level and we're
just bringing that back
so from last year yeah so even with what
we have in in this budget we're going to
be ahead
of or around about what we were in in
2019 before
it it went away
thanks marie what's the full-time
equivalence
of people dealing with limbs exclusively
how many people are doing ones i turn a
half
two and a half
yes
no
okay
i think unless there's any other
questions thank you marie and thanks for
what you and the team do um
excellent job okay thank you thanks very
much
all right um i think we i've just been
through um my summary and i think we've
done everything
but we've needed to today
so
if perhaps we just go through the
whiteboard but i don't think there's any
necessary consequences off that that we
haven't already considered
and i was thinking that we probably need
to just
finalize this something along the lines
that all budget resolutions with reports
be approved and recommended to council
for adoption on the 22nd of february
it's probably what we need to do to
cover off but can we just go through
those is there anything we need to do
with those jeff
no not at all
other one was the uh
very very minor changes to loans and
rates
so we'll put those
so there's two there's a briefing to
consider
with this raiding cold stream road
blake durham and i guess the
consequences of the parking building and
updating
council and the community board here on
that one which we talked of earlier so
we'll need to see how we can factor that
in
pretty the 22nd
and the others are just
as it is we will have you there
sorry
there's an 80k which is point zero one
but there's a regular sewer says
it's i think it has been hasn't it jeff
rengaro silva
it's already included isn't it ringura
still
yesterday
okay
so
do you i think i think it would be
helpful perhaps just to have a
capture resolution at the end are we
so
i suggested something like that all
budget resolutions with reports
be
approved and recommended to council for
adoption on the 22nd of february
someone prepared to second that
well you can move it yes counselor
anchors they moved secular council award
do you wish to speak
just really to uh to say thank you to
everybody for
for the day really it's um
everybody conducted in in great spirit
and it was
i think to get through it in one day
probably the first time i've sat around
this table in one day and
done a full annual plan so you know
um i think that's great that we've got
there and we've we've um
done very little in the way of movement
which is good to see in the
recommendations good reports from the
staff so thank you to the staff
thank you
i'd just like to say a big thank you to
the team to the staff and to jim uh for
presenting such a great
annual planned budget
and one that is very thorough and very
precise
and thanks to all fellow councillors for
being patient today and getting it
through in one day
thank you mia dan too wheelchaired thank
you
just just just briefly if i i just
quickly acknowledge our staff as well i
think they've done an awesome job the
budget papers were a very good quality
excellent quality and
all of us have commented that on the way
through
really good spirit here today so thanks
for acknowledging that neville thanks
for your leadership of the team uh jim
just note that in other localities
um
you know they'll be in the fives and
sixes there's one not so far from us
that'll be in the tens in terms of their
percent rises and then there's a
something that encloses all of us it's
sitting at 24 which is just outrageous
apparently so
it's going to be um and then
for us to have done our work and keep it
at around that 4.3
um is pretty exceptional so a really big
thanks jim and your management team and
all the staff underneath that have got
us there so thank you
um i interestingly enough i learned a
new term today to describe the
underpinnings of a road the guts of it
so thank you councillor williams
we also discovered a new councillor oops
so we have to try and find that one
[Laughter]
all right okay everyone so um by the
reply
so anyone else wants to say anything
because about it one very quick thing i
want to especially thank governance for
getting the papers out so early to us
because that really helped me to get
through the budgets that was a huge even
though we had some changes after that
they were minor it was really really
helpful to have them out so early so
thanks to governance yeah i should have
sorry that was remiss a bit tired to be
honest but thank you very a huge thanks
to governance um and also for the
catering which has been fantastic and
the sugar-free lollies too so thank you
so much
for all that support of us today thank
you
all right with that um unless you want
to write a reply i'll put the i'll put
that
recommendation uh all those in paper
please say all right
contrary to clear that carried the only
thing
left on here
um
budget summary which we've dealt with
and our next meeting where it says it's
the tuesday the 1st of march it's
actually the 22nd
so
that's all good go well everyone thank
you
see you next
next meeting
you